good morning everyone sorry about the
delay just accommodating uh various
people's wishes and can I welcome
everyone to this meeting of development
control committee a of mids District
Council just need to run through some of
the domestic arangements before we get
going uh could I please just ask you to
ensure that you maintain social
distancing from other uh other people
whilst in the chamber and in the
communal areas can I ask you to please
ensure that you wear a face covering at
all times apart from when you're sitting
down or of course you're exempt from
doing so and that can we please continue
to use hand sanitizers and wipes that
have been provided can I ask you to
please ensure that your microphones are
turned off when not in use and please
can I remind members not to interrupt
other speakers or hold hold separate
conversations While others are speaking
if you're attending a meeting to speak
uh and persistently interrupt we will
ask you to leave the meeting uh very
importantly could I ask everyone please
just to make sure your mobile phones are
at least on silent or Switched Off um
and we will be using EV voting for this
meeting on the modern. goov doapp uh
modern. goov app um and the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting today you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to having been
recorded by entering this meeting as a
speaker you also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of the sound recordings for
webcasting Andor training purposes the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcasters meeting when the public and
press are not hopefully
excluded if you hear the alarm ring it's
not a practice can we please leave the
building immediately via the fireex exit
and make our way to the assembly point
which is the ipsr toown football club
next door uh please follow the signs
directing you to the fire exits at each
end of the floor and please do not enter
the atum the ground floor area and
walkways if you are in the time if you
are in the eight at the time the alarm
please follow the signs the nearest fire
exit please use the stairs and do not
use the lifts please do not re-enter the
building till we're safe to do so so um
there are a lot of people in the room uh
today uh and just uh for the quick run
round as to who's going to do what uh
just some introductions so we have uh
starting on the back row here is
probably we have Emily Yu who's the
monitoring officer we have Luke barara
who's here from suff County Council
highways Sue Hoon who's here for Ecology
Paul Harrison who's here uh for um
Heritage we have Ian Dee our legal
advisor uh we have uh Phillip isbel uh
Who's chief planning officer and Gemma
Wy who will be presenting later on and
then at the top table here um I have
um CLA uh and I have Mandy who hold
everything together let me assure you
and make everything tick so thank you to
them uh for all they've done so far and
we'll do throughout the meeting uh we
have Ward members present at mids
District Council Ward members may speak
on an application before them if it's in
their own Ward but may not vote uh so
you'll see people moving around around
or or not being able to vote that's the
reason why okay we have a packed agenda
today um and the proposal is that we
will have appropriate breaks uh we will
also be finishing around 6:00 because
the doors are locked at 6:30 so I don't
propose so wherever we are just before
then we'll either finish at that one but
that is the sort of Target for the day
um we probably will not get through all
the applications that are on the agenda
before us but there is we're not here to
rush them we're here to give them the
time and Justice they deserve and where
we end up on the end of the day is where
we end up um just one item to note that
the uh planning application d7d in the
agenda dc2 04921 land of east of Hawley
Hill weaing set that has had to be
pulled unfortunately the case officer uh
has gone down or has been pinged so
can't come in
yeah Council maner uh thank you chair um
given what you've just said uh and there
are a lot of uh contentious cases um on
both of our half agendas if you like um
uh I would like to make a proposal that
we defer some of the later um
applications um on the grounds that uh
some officers could contact those people
who wanted to come in and speak
otherwise they'll have a very wasted
Journey if you're saying it's unlikely
we're going to get through them all
could we not make the decision now to
defer um some of them um in the interest
of public immunity really
uh because if someone has come all the
way from palra for our last um case
today um and then we find that we're
still on case four at 6:00 they've had a
wasted journey and I think in the
interest of public uh um benefit and and
you know open um I would like to propose
that we defer some of them now what I
think we should do fine uh what I think
we'll do obviously we'll go we could ask
members but what I think we should do is
at lunch when we get to the lunch break
see how many we've got through and then
at that point make the calls because we
may find you know we rattle through some
quicker than we think you just never
know so I I I my view is we do that at
the lunch break at around 12 or 1:00
that will give people plenty of time to
contact them yeah Council Manel well
well I'm sorry that that I disagree
actually no you've made your point and
we go you've made your sorry thank you
you've made your come back on my
proposal no no You' I not allowed to
come back on my proposal no you've made
your proposal now go to the vote on that
that's perfectly acceptable you've had
your say uh we don't need to spend a lot
of time talking about this does anyone
else wish to comment who hasn't already
spoken yep councelor p very quickly
thank you chairman I think your
suggestion is eminently sensible um just
to check that we have got the contact
details for the relevant people should
that be necessary but I do think um that
is a very pragmatic approach thank you
thank you okay yes Council yeah ju just
just just to add that that the um people
will take some time to get here and and
probably lunchtime will be a little too
late to save them traveling um varying
distances and pal graes mentioned Lun
time give people two a few over two
hours two to three hours but it's up to
members we'll happy to take that to a
vote those that would like to now choose
to defer the last how many items would
you like deferred
um what should we say the last two last
two items okay uh those in favor of that
can we have a the electronic voting yes
it needs to be set up uh so those in
favor of deferring the
last two items we'll go to a vote on
that at the sorry now no doing it now
rather than waiting till
[Applause]
12:00
thank you chair uh members if you go to
your modov
app
and select the cross in the top right
hand
corner vote in this item is now in
progress Council hadingham
you may have to scroll
down it's disappeared from
there you might have to if you go down
and then click the little button on the
left hand side a little
arrow
scroll
down okay has everyone voted that needs
to
vote
chair you need to
confirm thank you chair
that's four votes for and four votes
against we'll make the call at 12:00
thank you unless people want to go to a
vote for that but I think we're just
happy to move on okay um so uh let's
move straight on to the agenda uh
apologies for absence and substitutions
do we have any apologies for absence
please chair we have apologies from
councelor Richard mayor and councelor
linia hading him is
substituting okay thank you very much do
we need to declare uh receive any
Declarations of pecuniary or
non-pecuniary
interest by
members yes a personal um non-pecuniary
interest on the um freshing field
one okay thank you
um sorry counc
H thank you um nonary I'm a member of
Stow Market Town
Council thanks very much anyone else no
okay thank you um decorations of
lobbying I think
we're I think I think um Okay so we've
all been lobbied on the uh Gateway 14
application we've all been lobbied on
wakands um I've had emails and phone
calls on cross
street
um I not sure about
bton y okay
bton
Bungalow The Bungalow at bton okay great
bryett no okay and the land at Ling Road
palgrave
yes okay so it's all but one actually
yeah um chair if I may um could we ask
that the minutes for the lobbying on um
7A that's Gateway 14 actually I I don't
know how they get specified but because
we've been lobbied by residents we've
been lobbied by the applicant and we've
effectively been lobbied by the council
with presentations and so on that I
think just for clarity and ensuring
public kind of in the public interest
that's very clear in the minutes thank
you chair yeah lobbied by all parties
fine thank
you okay um any Declarations of personal
site visits funny enough I've yeah drove
past gateway 14 purely by accident
looking for the eso petol station but I
did go past it only two days ago uh
anyone else got anything they want to
declare yeah same with Council passal
okay thank
you um confirmation of the minutes held
on the 21st of July 2021 um members we
have those in front of us um just happy
to go through them is any points of
accuracy that people aren't happy with
um otherwise can I oh no sorry I can't
sign those we have to um go to a vote on
those so can I have a proposer for the
minutes to propose the minutes as they
are as a true record yep councel M and a
second yeah councelor parore
okay we have to go to an electronic vote
thank you chair members of that vot is
now in progress councelor hading would
you I was there
thank
you thank
you
yes thank you chair that's three
exstension and five votes for so that's
carried thank you uh just in that break
it suddenly occurred to me that I am a
LEP board member and I know the LEP is
speaking today and I think has been
involved to some degree in Gateway 14
had dealings with it so just for the
record I'd like to just declare
that okay um so uh do we need to receive
any notifications of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme non received okay thank you very
much we'll move straight on to the
scheduled planning applic ations and the
first one is
dc21 407 Gateway 14 the line between the
a1120 and A14 and Stow market now i'
like to invite the case officer GMA
Walker to introduce the application to
the
committee thank you
chair this is the application for
Gateway 14 in stay
Market um so we've got the application
site outlined in pink and we
can see the A14 to the top of the site
and the a120 running down the uh left
hand
side constraints map for the site we can
just see there are some uh flood zones
just running onto the very edges of the
site um we have also got a foot path
coming across from creating sorry for
the mouse through the site and and onto
Mill Lane um and finally there are
listed buildings they
are highlight in Black so just reference
that's
um the cedar Hotel we've got clamp Farm
in here but I will run through those
specifically later as well but just just
a particular flag up we have got various
list of buildings and just just see them
in Black again we've got the church here
but I'll come back to those as well this
is our red line application site um it
is split up into various parts because
we've got a hybrid application so partf
part
outline um this summarizes the two
different parts of our application so
essentially the parts inside the red
line in green are our full applications
so we're looking at the road through the
site uh and also coming up here and and
the um realignment essentially of mid
lane the Strategic landscaping around
the edges also is included in our full
application along with uh a substation
just in here and we've also got surface
water attenuation in this area uh and
also foot path connections through the
site the outline section is essentially
the parts in yellow uh and what we're
seeking on by way of this application
would be the principle of employment
uses EG which is B1 as was and B2 and B8
uses this then informs the parameters
plan which essentially gives us some
guidelines for the development we've got
um specific Heights and specific uses
probably of of most particular uh
relevance is the area in pink this would
be limited to class EG uses and have a a
lower height um restriction otherwise
we're looking at a mix of uses across
the site in the blue areas uh and then a
a height restricted Zone through
here and then we do have an indicative
site now now this is
um based on the outline so this is not
for approval but it gives an idea of how
a development might come forward on this
site just for reference and it has been
used um in some of the plans to show
what the buildings might look like but
essentially we are looking at uh an
envelope for buildings rather than the
actual design or anything else today
that would come back later for Reserve
matters moving on to site photographs
we're at the uh a120 roundabout with
essentially tesos and McDonald's behind
us looking forward to the site and this
is the entrance to the application site
uh on the right hand side on each photo
hopefully um are a a DOT indicating
where where we are uh and looking
through so if you're not clear there is
also a a diagram there of where we're
looking from but I'll try and reference
that as we go through so again we're
looking down the a 1120 towards mountain
and the site on our
left and then on the Mill Lane over
Bridge essentially looking down to the
roundabout we would have the A14 behind
us essentially and the site to the left
again coming round we're now looking at
the M Lane overbridge um properties and
stay Market here and looking down to the
uh Industrial buildings and that
essentially in the site
now and slightly further back the site
is both to our left and our right we're
on M Lane and looking into stay
market and then again looking through
the application site for mil Lane we
still just see some development in State
Market on the
horizon and then we're now looking down
towards Mountain across the main part of
the application
sites and again slightly further on
we're just starting to see the edge of
clamp Farm coming into our view now to
the
left and then as we come around this
clamp Farm you can see M Lane winds down
to our left and comes down to clamp
farm and then looking um essentially on
the A14 over Bridge so creating to our
right and the application site to our
left and again just a a view we're now
over that bridge um from greting and
looking across Fields into the
site um and finally now we're on the
site and we're looking back and you can
just see traffic on the A14 in the
background so this is essentially the
northern part of the site just in front
of
us and again very top of the site
essentially now um adjacent to the A14
looking back towards
creating uh we now move right down to
the very Southern aspect of the site now
so we're essentially looking along the
river gipping boundary and with the
railway and mountains on our
left and then we're looking back up the
[Applause]
site so the application site was
allocated by the core strategy Focus
review in 2012 by policy fc3 and that
included specific land amounts and as
you can see from the uh plan excert from
the um core strategy Focus review that
is essentially the site we're looking at
there are some differences to the
boundary uh particularly this area there
is not within the ownership of the
applicant as it stands um but
essentially we're looking at the site as
allocated in that core strategy Focus
review this was then uh subsequently
further allocated in the state market
area action plan in 2013 and policies
7.9 to 7.14 are the particularly
relevant policies um excert from the
main policy 7.9 on the screen um about
the different phases and the expectation
of it being the state Market business
and Enterprise part
Park uh policy 7.10 of the state market
area action plan required a development
brief to be produced this is the plan
from the development brief it um
specified land uses across the site so
we can see there's slightly different
shadings uh and there are different
hatchings but I will come back and just
detail the hatchings um in more detail
later um essentially there are different
height zones you perhaps just see the
bottom is is red and that was a higher
height Zone whereas we've got lower
Heights particularly around the clamp
Farm area but I've got a zoomed in
picture to come back to um so these
policies provide for the allocation of
the site for employment use and as such
the proposal is considered to be
acceptable in
principle to go back to the summary plan
the road layout in green is part of the
full application and that includes the
closing of Mill L to
Vehicles there
um providing a new connecting mod the
a120 roundabout as an
alternative um and that is as the
development brief expected concerns have
been raised particularly about the
realignment of the road around clamp
Farm you see there's there's a corner a
collection of Corners as we come through
the site um however suffer County
Council highways and highways England
raised no objection to the proposal both
the travel plan and construction
management plan are proposed by way of
condition uh and as you'll see in the
update on the late papers in the
recommendation just to clarify that both
of those would expect and and require um
the use of the a1120 and A14 Junction um
as part of
that as mentioned the proposal includes
a parameters plan shown proposed uses
and Heights these include a maximum
height above ordinance
datum the development brief itself also
set expected Eaves Heights but it is
silent on any expected works to level
the site and where this height to Eaves
might be measured from in this respect
so just to pick up as I've mentioned the
the different heights so the the bottom
Zone would have been 15 M to Eaves then
we've got 8 m to the eaves through here
uh and then a lower height round clamp
Farm hopefully you can just pick out the
different colors um but as we can see on
on the orange slide colored pit diagram
there were limited ordinance datum
included and that didn't set out any
levels detail
specifically
[Applause]
this application includes above
ordinance datum levels and an indicative
cut and fill Proposal with maximum roof
Heights above ordinance datum as well a
condition is proposed for maximum
building Heights and this provides
control of the proposal and a maximum
envelope against which the impact of The
Proposal can be assessed so essentially
we know our maximum um possible levels
that would be agreed through Reserve
matters and we know the heights we're
talking about if the levels were to drop
because we are proposing a maximum
Building height condition the building
would also drop in the landscape it
wouldn't then be 25 or 30 m tall to the
top of our envelope that is the proposal
to control that by condition so we are
talking about the absolute maximum and
that is what we've assessed this
proposal against so we have got that
envelope that we know is the maximum and
then the detail we can control through
Reserve
matters this has been further
demonstrated by indicative site sections
these are in your bundles me members but
apologies it doesn't come out very well
on A4 so I've zoomed in on the relevant
bits so you might be able to pick these
out as you go um particular relevance of
DNA so perhaps I'll I'll come to those
in more detail but we've got section A
here which is across the site this way
so we're
coming from the
A14 down through the
site and then again we've got section
B where again we can see how we come
through the
site and see I said I'll dwell on DNA
perhaps so see we can see it across here
through the potential larger
building and then to come to section
D we're looking look at at Um mountains
towards the bottom and then we can see
how the site would be leveled but come
up in phases across the top of the
soite and again e um this particularly
coming through would be looking at a
clamp farm to our right hand side the
gap between clamp farm and the sight
coming through to the Bund
a the Gap in here which we can see is is
essentially the Gap through here coming
through through the various different
buildings towards the A1
hunting as such whilst there would be an
increase in height over and above the
expectations of the development brief we
do have a an envelope against which to
assess it and this is the basis on which
the application has been
considered this includes a landscape
mitigation scheme as part of a strategic
Landscaping plan uh which is part of the
full application that we are looking at
today um the landscape mitigation SCH is
subject to conditions and is confirmed
by the landscape consultant that the
impact can be mitigated through the
proposed strategic Landscaping this plan
shows broad areas proposed such as
Street planting through the center of
the site along the newly proposed
roadway and for example Woodland along
the eastern boundary to offer a
different type of mitigation in that
area detailed proposals are provided for
the site with plans for each area um if
we briefly run through each plan I have
included this on the bottom corner of
each so you can see where we're at on
each plan because it covers such a large
area um just a brief look at the key
there are a variety of different areas
different plantings and plans in order
to make sure that we maximize the
benefits of the
Landscaping so we're looking at plan one
here this shows the top corner of the
site looking at the
a120 uh and I'm I'm aware I think the
the Landscaping plan provided in the
bundle shows uh distances which I know
some members have crewed saying oh that
includes the land outside the site so
I'll clarify the distances inside the
site and say yes that plan does include
essentially the full width of the
Landscaping rather than necessarily that
which is proposed so hopefully I can
clarify that so here for example we're
looking at 8 m at the widest point which
is approximately there through to our
red
line coming along to the A14 boundary we
start to see the uh proposed strateg iic
Landscaping come along here and we're
looking at a width of 15 M along the
boundary to the red line as well as the
highway Verge that's in
addition and then coming to the top
corner of the site essentially again
we're looking at 15 M width across that
boundary and then as we come down the
east side of the application site we'll
just see the uh existing foot path
coming in
there uh and this this is all correct in
your plan because there isn't uh
Landscaping outside of the boundary so
the dimensions that are in your in your
bundles are
correct and then we can see we're coming
through the center of the site to the
proposed uh roadway with the um Street
planting
proposed and then out again to the uh to
the
roundabout with that proposed new access
road and again um plan Eight coming down
the a120
and through the site
again and to the corner we're now coming
out on the essentially the exit to M
Lane with clamp Fon just to our
South and there we go coming out we can
just see the clamp Fon buildings this is
the the next plan coming down we've got
the Bund also proposed in
full and then we come across the site
with not so much more information onra
but pass then we come across to the
corner of the bottom of the site with
the a120 and mountains in here with the
railway uh and we're looking at that
point at uh just over 14 m in this area
I menion to the for the landscaping and
in this area uh just over 22 M
wide and then coming down to Mountain
again we can see the proposed
landscaping and the bottom corner of the
site coming into our um
attenuation and again just the the final
detail on that attenuation
then down to the corner of the footpath
which is the very bottom right hand
corner of the site down here essentially
oops so as mentioned that is a strategic
Landscaping plan and hopefully that
clarifies the Landscaping that is
proposed on site just to confirm this is
an updated version of the plan you've
got in your papers so it does clarify
that it is 30 m overall of which 8 m in
that area is on-site landscaping and
hopefully I've run through all of those
details so you um clear members on what
it is exactly that's on-site versus
Highway Verge with regards to the amount
proposed this is reduced compared to the
development brief which we can just see
on the top right hand side you can see
there is a a wider swaye of green
proposed on that right on the um
northern boundary with the A14 on the
application site in the development
brief however a reduction of that
Landscaping belt had been accepted by a
previous consent on this site provided
that the landscape aping still provides
the appropriate mitigation for the
proposal as previously mentioned the
landscape consultant confirms that the
impact can be mitigated by the proposed
Landscaping furthermore the proposal has
been assessed by a consultant ecologist
who considers the detailed landscape
proposal acceptable and noting that the
proposal demonstrates
13.59% gain for habitats and
148.5 gain for linear features so that
there are clear measurable net gains for
biodiversity in addition a condition has
proposed to secure 20% on plots of
landscaping uh which if I just draw your
attention to the plan on the bottom
right hand side you can see in the
lighter green additional areas
particularly around the edges of the
site which would be part or could be
part of that when we look at Reserve
matters so there is also further
opportunity to secure um additional
Landscaping over and above that proposed
but but as mentioned there are
significant gains as a result of that
currently
proposed an lvia was undertaken as part
of this assessment which shows the
proposal and the landscape mitigation
over time so hopefully taking you
through these we'll see the differences
proposed over time so we're looking at
the uh A14 Dan mtons in this slide uh
this is as existing and then we move on
to the
proposal coming on to year one and year
15 so that is the expectations of the
Landscaping proposal and that has been
assessed by our landscape
consultant and again
looking
at Mt and to our left and looking up to
clam farm this is
um where we are at the moment and then
day one with no
mitigation and then Viewpoint 14 we're
looking at the
drivethru up towards uh the A14 the
offices that are up there and the
residential development we can see the
proposal
what we would anticipate the Landscaping
to look like which particularly the Bund
would be expected to be delivered um
before any built form on site so perhaps
this view is not uh characteristic of
what we would expect at any point
because we would expect the bun to be
delivered in amongst the Strategic
Landscaping but it does give you the
idea of what it might look like so we
have then the bun just essentially newly
planted and then coming up to year
15 longer distance use of the
proposal and again with the Landscaping
in
place and then we're looking Southward
from the A14 on this one again with the
proposal and with Landscaping in
place from the east of the site
proposal let run through so you can see
these are a long distance views where we
just catch some uh views of the site but
hope that gives an idea of the
expectations the landscape mitigation
also mitigates against impacts to the
setting of listed buildings in the
vicinity as mention said I would come
back to this so hopefully you can see
listed down the left hand side are the
uh listed buildings that the
conservation officer sorry Heritage
officer uh particularly specified there
are others which you can see in black
across the plan they're unfortunately
fairly small dots but hopefully you can
see that there are others but these are
the particular ones identified to
working through clamp farmies number one
coming down to badley Mill House the
cedar
hotel Woodland Farmhouse at number four
coming all the way down to the bottom
for number five greeting
Hall sorry not greeting Hall number
number five is badle Hall um number six
is greeting hall seven is the Church of
St Peter and eight is the old recory and
then number nine the map on the left
hand side is essentially in exer I've
tried to make that as clear as possible
it might not be so what we've got is the
badley church green Conservation Area
this is the area it runs through so it
runs all the way from the road here down
around these two small areas of Woodland
either side of the road and then comes
down around here and apologize the shape
is not great with the mouse but
hopefully you can see on the left hand
side that is the shape of the
conservation area said it it does run
all the way down to the to the road down
here the proposal has been assessed by a
Heritage officer who confirms that the
proposal would cause less than
substantial harm to designated Heritage
assets as such as required by paragraph
202 of the mppf where a proposal will
lead to less than substantial harm the
harm should be weighed against public
benefit noting the harm must be given
considerable importance and weight this
proposal nonetheless offers public
benefit the site is expected to provide
an excessive 3,000 jobs providing
employment in a sustainable with a
sustainable match between homes and jobs
as such the harm is considered to be
outweighed by public benefits to
economic growth gr from bringing forward
this allocated
sign whilst The Proposal does not comply
with the full requirements of the
development brief as a whole The
Proposal does offer appropriate
mitigation of impact and benefits to
result overall it's considered to comply
generally with the development plan
whilst material considerations in favor
are notable including significant
economic benefits economic benefits
themselves form part of the overarching
aims of sustainable development in the
mppf whilst paragraph 81 confirms that
signific weight should be given to the
need support economic growth and
productivity just to clarify a couple
points on the late papers just to F to
finally sum up um there are two errors
just for correction particularly one
point about the mppf um that obviously
we had the new addition come out uh
essentially right before this report was
published just a correction there um
there is also an update to the
recommendation just to clarify a couple
of the um condition recommendations so
the the recommendation itself would be
late papers on three three pages 3 to
six rather than that in the bundle then
we've got a Heritage um update paper and
finally we've just got some very slight
amendments to the Earthworks plans uh
and particularly a clarification of what
the different colored lines were because
that wasn't included but that is
essentially the the update from the late
papers um and as such the recommendation
is for approval as mentioned on pages 3
to six of the late papers thank you
chair thank you very much uh for running
through that now we have uh we have um
Sue here from the ecology perspective
who's only here till 11:00 so if members
are just mindful of that if they have
any questions for that particular era
first off was councelor maton thank you
chair yeah I wanted to ask if if we
could I mean there's about six or eight
different um kind of topics about which
um members are likely to have questions
I wondered if we could in some way group
those um so that we don't keep dating
from one topic to another as we take
different members questions um I mean we
can see the the the issues of principle
related to the
sap the development brief and then there
are Landscaping issues Heritage issues
travel access transport type issues and
and
uh and a few more yeah well let if you
want to get yeah I'm happy to give that
a go it probably makes sense to lump
them together so why don't we start off
uh with the ecology uh as as Sue uh we
haven't got sue for the whole day so any
members want to just pick up on
questions of ecology councelor parore
you're first um thanks Matthew thanks
chairman morning everybody uh yes very
pleased to see the uh landscaping and
plans there one of the questions I have
on this and I I know it would be
conditioned were it to get per um
permission but there are issues here
about local provence of tree planting
schemes hedging and so on to make sure
they are local speci and so on but one
of the things if this goes through is
going to be a bit of a flagship
development that will be very very
visible what can we do to make sure I
don't know how you describe this that so
for example the trees that we plant are
of a decent size so we're not just
planting them about five or 6 ft tall
but maybe 12 15 ft I'm I'm not an expert
on this but it's really important that
if it goes through we soften the impact
as you go along the a114 and down
towards Stow Market down to the seeders
roundabout there as much as possible so
how could we um condition that or can we
condition that at this stage to make
sure it's a really or is it already
conditioned I guess is the other
question well yeah so did you see where
I'm coming we don't want a load of how
can I put it cheap um lower standard
imported things like that at all thank
you um yeah so that's exactly what we've
been looking at as I mentioned we had
that um envelope against which we've
assessed uh and then we've looked at
that strategic Landscaping on that basis
does it mitigate against the proposal
successfully that's the advice from our
landscape consultant is that it does
offer the appropriate mitigation and
that we can secure that by condition and
that we would require its implementation
essentially first before we do uh any
further
development just very
quick yeah right okay um um make sure
that they are maintained properly loed
after and trees Hedges need looking
after fertilizing grass cutting watering
and all these sorts of things because
it's really really important that is
part of the condition for whoever has
the overall responsibility for that yeah
can I come back to there is a proposal
to have essentially a a
maintenance plan as part of the section
106 agreement so that would be secured
by 106 that that would be uh looked
after
maintained going
forward thank you councelor uh eburn you
are next
thank you very much chair um I've got um
probably three questions on the um
landscape um
firstly um the original development
brief I think was 40 m um
landscaping and so I just wanted a a
view again as to why we've cut that in
more than in half and where you refer to
um some parts of the Landscaping being 8
m um but that landscape outside of the
site so therefore it would be a wider
bit but we obviously don't control the
landscape out that side of it so
highways or whoever could completely
chop down all the Landscaping outside of
the site and we'd be back to 8 MERS
which is a rather big difference from
the 40 in the development brief so if
you could just um ex explain that one
for me please um secondly um you zip
through them rather quickly but the view
from Cedar Park
uh I think is a very important um in
terms of what the Landscaping is there
for um people looking across from ceders
Park especially with the heights of the
land um concerned and um finally
the actually sort of maintaining kind of
corridors um the corridors through the
um site of Street trees so how are we
sure that they will actually become
Wildlife corridors as rather than just
single decorative Street trees thank you
very
much thank you um y so the in terms of
the Landscaping I probably can't answer
the why it was reduced this is the
application that has been made and we've
got to look at but I said that has been
assessed on that basis as mitigating
against the proposal in terms of the 8
meters by the A4 to the a120 sorry so
the uh additional Landscaping is outside
of the red line it is in the Highway
however the majority of that on the
corner by that roundabout is a roadside
Nature Reserve so has other protection
as well uh and it I see correct me if
wrong is that's the area with the
shepherd's
needle no right there
go um but it is part of that protection
um so it's got that roadside Nature
Reserve designation on that corner as
well so essentially that would protect
that width of landscaping
um the view from Cedar Park Mandy I
might need to go back to the slide and
then we can have that up in full councel
did you recall which slide it was
particularly no there's a lot there
sorry that's
uh
sorry I just just to pick up on that the
the areas um hatched to the roadside
nature reserves
particularly
so that's probably looking
towards the McDonald's in that area down
by the roundabout and then across
through to
um the uh commercial use there just see
so the A14 is s right is that helpful
slide um I think i' bit it was looking
in because it's the obiously the cedus
park a residential area and people
looking at and given the height of of
cedus Park um and I on the previous
slides when you picked up views from
clamp farm and from creting and so on I
couldn't pick out one from Cedar Park
looking in so and what the Landscaping
then um protected the residential areas
effectively from that view uh so I don't
think there is one in the lvia from
there but I'll be corrected if anybody
is aware of one specific specifically I
think I'd picked out the the predominant
ones uh but in terms of of here we we
are looking at that 8 MERS of
landscaping over and above the um
Highway Verge and if I pop back to the
side where we look
out there we have that one so we can
already see it it it is um essentially
because there's a slight drop in the
ground levels um and the existing
Landscaping plus then proposed
Landscaping there is limited views
across already so that additional
Landscaping would offer that buffer and
I said that that is part of the overall
assessment by the landscape consultant
thank you I think you might have had
another question or I covered everything
sorry the wildlife corridors which I
might defer to S
on thank you chair um the Landscaping
obviously will be secured by condition
I'd like to think that ecology would
have an input into that um
in terms of ensuring Wildlife corridors
are delivered and as you said are not
just lollipop trees down the streets
however Street trees do have to um
confirm to um highways requirements um
but I would like to think that there
would be a deliverable network not just
am munity value for those using the
area thank
you uh yes Council M thank you chair um
yeah there were there were a a large
number of of um
additional landcaping um parameter plans
in fact um and um we hadn't wish hadn't
had the opportunity to see in in the
papers that we received um we must say
we went through those a disappointedly
fast pace and I really couldn't actually
get my head around where we were um
Slide by slide which which was quite a
problem um what I wanted to ask
particularly Sue hooton
um there's some very very very precise
um biodiversity gain percentages on page
43 of the papers um what I was wondering
was what period in the
future is is that are those percentages
um achieved let's put it let's put it
that way um that that's one question and
um I think the others are mainly on
landscaping or things that councelor re
ebone has covered so just just on the
ecology first
then thank you chair um the calculations
have been provided by the applicants um
team and they have
been pulled together from the available
land
and the planting that could be delivered
so this is a potential that could be
delivered within the site and that's how
the government's defa biodiversity
metric both two and the new version
which is version three which is now
available so this is the
potential available and there will need
to be an
actual metrics calculated at the time of
each of the future applications coming
forward for Reserve
matters so the calculations are based on
a baseline assessment of what's actually
on the site for biodiversity habitats
and separately for linear features and
the linear features are things like
hedge rows but also water courses um so
as there aren't many HED rows on the
site there is a huge
potential for net gain for linear
features however the habitats gain I
would like think is um
more or similar to a lot of development
sites in that it's at least demonstrates
that net gain can be delivered above
what will be the mandatory 10% when the
government's um environment Bill comes
back as we understand it um but to
answer your question about when will
those percentages be
delivered the final percentage will be
or could be different to these but at
least the site has the ability to
deliver these and the metrics
calculations have been designed that
different harats being created have a
different lifespan to achieve that
calculation and off the top of my head
Woodland is at least easy to create but
it does take time obviously trees take
time to grow so I from memory I think
the calculations are likely to have been
based on
15 years for some habitats and up to 25
years for
others so I hope that answers your
question 15 to
25 for for
Woodland thank you check can I continue
onto the onto the more Landscaping
related matters W with the the views
that we saw um
I happened to come from clayon on the
A14 yesterday um and it struck me that
the going in that direction there was a
very big and clear view of the site and
I projected back in my
mind from where I was on the road back
into towards um kingon Peter and um and
creating Hills and I just just wondered
what sort of um visual impact there is
um from those sort of
perspectives up on the on the high land
so the landscape consultant as part of
The Proposal did review the um
viewpoints from which the um lvi
assessments were made of specific points
and assess those I can't answer that
specifically but that was the landscape
consult our landscape consultant agreed
the viewpoints from which was assessed
and undertook that assessment and as I
said did did it say that he accept
accepted that the mitigation was
appropriate and mitigated the
impact thank you have you got more
Landscaping questions John um no I I'll
need to have a look fors okay anyone
else want to come in on before we move
on to Heritage randomly picking subjects
Heritage councelor
field just a question on on the uh
So-Cal linear
features obviously it's Farm or has been
Farmland so not a great deal of Hedges
on it at the moment uh just some
Assurance are we talking about uh
meaningful gains here or um you are we
talking about just any ditch happens to
be a linear feature you say do tend to
be somewhat linear and they may or may
not have an impact on on wildlife and
its ability to move around what is your
assessment is this a meaningful gain or
just a large number to impress
us thank you chair um the Baseline will
have included all in your features
however from biodiversity Net game point
of view the whole point is to deliver
benefits to biodiversity um and
therefore any that will be proposed as
gains will need to be appropriate both
to the landscape but from an ecology
point of view so I'm talking about
Native
species um hos that are
appropriately
um managed in the future the long term
because that's the whole point because
if you just plant something you ignore
it it's not going to survive and it
won't deliver any benefits so the
planning Authority in assessing and um
considering applications and Reserve
matters will need to ensure that
biodiversity Net game is going to be
delivered not just
deliverable
C pass
thanks hope it's going to behave itself
uh I don't know um whether this is
exactly the right time to ask this but I
think there are ecological implications
I would say one of the concerns that um
I know has been raised in the past and
that's about um the um risk of pollution
to Water Co and aquifers and the reason
I mentioned that chairman is because of
course mountains down at the bottom end
of the site is one of our primary
companies that exports to over 80
countries all around the world and any
compromise on water resources for the
molting business is actually a real big
threat so um what I'm really asking are
there some kind of mitigations within
the planning policy I don't know whether
exactly he would answer this question to
do everything possible and design to
minimize the risk should anything happen
I know the environment agency have
responded about foul water drainage but
there is another dimension here and it
also applies to air quality as well that
will clearly depend on what sort of
industry is there but it's important we
have that and a further question I have
and I'm not sure whether this fits in as
well but when you look at some
industrial Estates some of them are kept
absolutely pristine and and look very
very smart one thing that really winds
me up and a lot of other people there
sometimes at the entrance ways and
around the vicinity there's a lot of
litter rubbish detritus what can we do
to make sure that doesn't happen I'm
thinking up at the I Airfield where
cranswick have got their facility I'm
fed up with driving up the a140 there
and seeing at times a filthy old mess
outside the entrance to that particular
facility I'm not blaming cranswick but
what can we do to try and make sure that
happens because any pollution like that
clearly compromises the ecological
balance and apart from that it looks
pretty unsightly and shouldn't be there
in the first place thank
you um yet might need to defer to S on
some of the the wildlife points but but
if I if I start backwards um so as said
we are looking at having a management
and maintenance requirement through the
one6 and I see no reason why that
couldn't include that kind of management
expectations that there is a degree of
litter picking if that were necessary or
general site tidying along with the
management to make it correct for the
biodiversity so I think in that respect
we do retain the control um perhaps this
might come on to when we have the uh
applicant and agent speak they confirm
that obviously it the expect at our
sight so I suspect that would also leave
us further control but from a strictly
planning Authority point of view I would
feel confident that that 106 regardless
of of who that might be would give us
control on that point
um sorry in terms of the wi Grand yes
sorry um so we don't have details of
occupiers or what might happen so I
think that would be something for the
reserve matters particularly at the
moment the surface water drainage
essentially is only for the um
infrastructure going on site so that is
controlled in its own way if there were
to be an occupier come in who had
specific issues we would be able to deal
with that through their surface water
drainage at their Reserve matters point
when they submit that um and that's um
part of the advice from County floods
has said they want a particular package
um for Reserve matters as part of the
surface water drainage uh and they have
also requested on both uh full and the
outline a construction surface water
management plan so again that we would
have that control during construction
thank you very much thank
you okay yes Council madon yeah the um
yes I found my my other two can I first
ask um sue hooton you know in view of
those answers about the 15 to 25 years
and so on um is there a significant
short-term ecology loss that we we're
going to suffer
here and um then I wanted to move on to
the the
Landscaping in the papers that we we
were sent the we
slides um 30 to
34 um landscape sections and Views 1 2 3
4 five um I wanted to explore how many
years um was assumed in the in those
sectional drawings of of showing that
you won't be able to see the buildings
from various
places thank you thank you chair I'll
I'll try answer the ecology questions
but I'll have to defer someone else on
the Landscaping
ones um your concerned about shirt time
losses I think have been um considered
appropriately by the applicants team
they have used the mitigation hierarchy
as it is defined in ecological best
practice um so initially impacts have
been avoided um we did provide free
application advice to the applicant and
were um able to see that when the
application was actually submitted the
meas measures to avoid impacts have been
taken impacts have also been mitigated
in terms particularly of timing of some
Works um proposed um and where impacts
have been deemed unavoidable um
particularly in relation to the
shepherd's needle that Gemma mentioned
earlier um which is an endangered plant
that thrives on arable land but it is
very um much appreciated that details
have been provided in terms of a method
statement to collect seed and sew that
on the site obviously not within the
area that's going to be developed um and
that will be managed in the long term so
there have been compensation measures
included within the development site um
and the additional planting is all going
to be enhancements so I'm satisfied that
there will be no short-term loss um but
there
is possibility of considerable
gains if the applicant is
consented off the can you turn your mic
on please sorry officers found the
landscaped sections and Views that I'm
referring
to right yeah uh perhaps I can kind of
come on on to both of those points so um
that's one of the expectations of the
phasing as mentioned is that we're
delivering the Bund and the Landscaping
before anything else is allowed that's
one of the requirements on the
conditions so we make sure that the the
Landscaping probably both in terms of
biodiversity and in terms of the
mitigation is expected to provide for
views would be one of the first things
that's implemented on site in terms of
the time scares of those views I don't
know what when that's based on but that
might be something per pick up with the
applicants yeah yeah on the band the
band Only refers to clamp Farm though
there aren't any other BNS no there is
some there is some Earthworks around the
site which is the the plans and the
bundles which are the the line plans
that um adjust some of the heights
around the edges of the site but not
specific bunding the bunding is around
the clamp Farm area than
you okay any move on to another area uh
happy to be guided by the committee by
questions you may have is there anything
else you want to pick up while we've got
the officers here or should we go on to
the rest of the speakers then if you've
got more questions come back to the
offices Council Master yes um I have got
some questions but they're not related
to those topics that you any topic you
want any topic it well I I've got a
couple of questions I have no idea
whether they come classified in the same
sort of area um the papers talk about um
uh excess of 3,000 jobs uh being created
by this development um can you tell me
if that is based on a you having this as
a manufacturing or a
wehousing um sort of basis um how are
all these employees going to get to the
site um those are two questions about uh
employment I've also got a question
about lighting which may or may not be
related to ecology um I notice on our
conditions we've got Wildlife friendly
lighting as a condition um is that uh to
be sort of like smart lighting that's
only on when it's necessary to be on or
is it on
permanently thank you chman if you can
answer those if you can't we can we've
also got the applicant we can ask them
later um yep so job numbers um I'm just
looking I think it was the focus review
specified the numbers I'm just just
looking for um so that was the there we
go
sorry
chairman if I can assist I think it was
of the order of 8,000 jobs was in the
focused review for memory
you um I'm
sorry what was the other part of the
question apologies Cel the lighting yes
so there is a a a condition for lighting
it is essentially a strategy to be
agreed so if there are specific things
in there I would expect that we would
consult Sue or hopefully soon um on that
point as as when we got that proposal so
we could look at that for each site so
that it is um the Lux levels appropriate
the angles are appropriate that it's
turned off as needs be and all of those
details would be something that would be
controlled by that condition then it was
transport to the
site so um that again might be something
we can we can pick up on essentially
there is a travel plan that comes with
this and that's been approved with
County and it does include a shuttle bus
um and we would expect to provide the
appropriate levels of electric vehicle
charging parking that's been proposed
along with cycle parking as part of the
reserve matters but pH want Philip wants
to come in as well chairman yes in my
enthusiasm um I did say 8,000 and 8,000
is the districtwide figure it's actually
a little bit over 3,000 probably 3,2
3,300 uh is set out in the uh Focus
review
thank thanks okay yeah you want to come
back sorry yeah I I can read it says
8,000 jobs are needed in the district
and it says in my papers the application
site is expected to provide in excess of
3,000 jobs all I've been told is that
that's what it says yes so so you could
ask the applicant when they come up
right and can I just make one other
point about the presentation and the
papers that we've been sent um I am a
map person and I can rotate Maps but I
find it very frustrating that the maps
are not all in the same orientation
especially when you gave us those um cut
through whatever you know sectional
things to try and rotate it work out
where you were when some maps are one
way up one maps on the other just a
point I'd like to make it doesn't make
it easy to follow can I can I suggest
that you just ping an email to David
burn after just pointing that out and
then we'll TR try and pick it up to we
want to make it as easy as possible for
members uh yes councelor Manel then
councelor humph sorry councelor eburn
then councelor
humph um thank you very much chair I've
got four um questions um if I may um
first simple one just in construction
management um can we confirm that that's
not using the a1120 through Stow Upland
that it's only using the a112 to get to
the
A14 um secondly um it talks about
recreational
um uh an amount being spent on um
recreational facilities
190,000 um can
confirm where that will be if it's not
going to be on
site um
thirdly um many workers will use the
facilities near to their place of work
so obviously some people live near but
near hopefully but others will be
traveling and they will use those
facilities so what are the plans for in
infrastructure such as GP surgeries um
for those people that are working on
that site and will go to use a GP
surgery at lunchtime for
example and finally I'm just I'd still
just like some clarification about the
differences between this application and
the development brief because in the
papers there are some points where it
says this such and such has been in the
development brief and it's now carried
through into this one tick that's fine
and there are other points where it says
it's not in the development brief it is
sorry it was in the development but it's
not in this one oh and that's fine as
well so I just kind of there's seems to
be a little bit of a confusion as
between whether it's okay to not have
items that were in the development brief
or it is okay to have items that you
know we in the development brief so if
you could just have a bit of clarity
over that from s of policy perspective
please thank you very
much thank you chair um yeah so in terms
of the a120 that would be the
expectations is the 1120 up to the A14
Junction and that that would be um
written into the construction management
plan um in terms of sports provision um
perhaps Randy if we can go back to the
PowerPoint already and I'll pick up that
point through the development brief as
well
for
we go um so the orange land just in
there was originally allocated for
sports provision uh neither of the two
previous permissions provided any land
at all they both had uh 106 payments to
contribute towards employee Sports
provision and that's what was proposed
in this case as well of the amount
previously secured is carried forward to
this proposal uh and that we would need
to spend that money on appropriate
Sports provision for employees
essentially so it is one of those things
that development brief did expect but we
have got an alternative um funding for
that and then we can take that away to
um improve or provide additional Sports
provision the GP infrastructure wouldn't
be something that we would particularly
expect an employment site to Prov that's
based on houses and comes through sill
if there were particular demand that
could be uh requested through the sill
funding uh if there is extra demand as a
result of this but in general we would
take that as a basis of the residential
uh position uh and I think most GPS
require that to be in the locality of
your home address so again that that
might have an implication but that would
be potentially controlled through S
funding and then to pick up on the
development brief so it is adopted it is
a material cons consideration as said
the pre previous applications sorry
could we go keep that up
sorry um the previous applications um
both varied from it in certain ways I
said the sports provision is probably an
easy one to say that y we did vary from
it we did take that away but are we
still providing appropriate mitigation
yes we've secured the money towards
those sports facilities and similarly
with the Landscaping what we're saying
is that's gone out to our landscape
consultant and been assessed and is
providing the appropriate mitigation so
perhaps I pick up on the several points
where where there are differences so
we've got the let me change hands we've
got got the um Whitland area uh in this
area that is outside of our Redline
application site and it's not blue line
land so it's not within the applicant's
ownership so that is not something that
we can control or secure through this
application but equally it doesn't
prevent it coming forward it wouldn't
have implications as far as I Can See
For It Coming forward in the future and
we do still provide the footpath coming
down the edge of the site onto the Gin
Valley way so if that were proposed at
sometime in the future there would be
Public Access onto it including from
this site as well as from the ging
Valley Way um mentioned the Landscaping
we've got two areas we've got this area
to the north um which is again outside
of red line is not blue line land that
is exactly the same as we dealt with the
application for what we call phase to
the northern part of the site
essentially um it was it was outside the
application site in that for that ation
we again assessed the landscaping and
considered that it appropriately
mitigated and that therefore we have not
ever secured that area of land expected
by the development brief I think I
mentioned the Landscaping across here
that that narrow width and then the
other main area would be the height so
the development brief expected 15 m to
the eaves in this area 8 m further up
and think six and a half in this area uh
adjacent to clamp farm that as I
mentioned was never are based off a set
level aod we've got some aod examples
but the site is I think we saw from
photos you can see mountain is at the
bottom of the valley the A14 at the top
so you would need a flat level
development platform to base that off
the other uncertainty essentially from
the development brief in terms of of
height and scale is we don't actually
know roof Heights that's not set it is
an EES height I think it's described as
clear to the haunch essentially the
underside of the eaves so they are
unknown essentially
um I think from a reasonable assessment
um I've tried to put that out in a table
in the papers for you that there is a
difference in height this would increase
the height but we're content that the
Landscaping would appropriately mitigate
against that height does that help
clarify the
differences yes that's that's great
thank you very much but can I um just
come back on the um recreational um one
again so we don't know that there are no
um ideas or what whatever about where
that what that funding will be used
towards whether it'll be to create
another area within St Market town or or
or improve C I mean I know we've got
lots of projects going on and we can we
could have certain uses for the money
but specific to this to say is that
funding going to be used for anything
specific so not at the moment I haven't
had a specific request for a particular
facility so what we had done previously
was Secure that for sports provision or
facilities for the employees of the site
so we would have to be content that it's
in a reasonable distance so people who
worked here would be able to make use of
them but not for we haven't at the
moment got a specific um
plan okay councelor humph thank you Mr
chair um very quick question I know we
don't know what type of jobs are going
to be created on that site it's too
early for that um but does the 3,000 or
so jobs also include the construction
jobs
I don't know definitively from fc3 Phil
May uh chairman so uh the C straty
focused review talked about the split of
jobs from the uses itself not from
construction so we don't have visibility
over that and just going back to the
point Council Manel had raised uh
effectively at that time the the notion
was that the sort of light industrial B1
uses will be 833 of those jobs that the
B8 uses will be 1250 of those jobs and
that the other uses potentially here
would be of the order of about 1300 a
little over 1300 so that you had a
balanced split but ultimately the world
of employment perhaps is not the same
world that uh was was then when the
focus review was agreed thank you
chairman thank you councelor
[Music]
field thank you just to uh consider the
highways issues for an instant here um
much of the uh lobbying we received with
people concerned about traffic issues as
is often the case I just wonder what
whether we know what uh assumptions uh
highways made there's a discussion on
page 37 a brief summary of their views
which uh mentions a using a highways
model and it says that um uh with with
permitted development traffic flows
whatever they may be uh Addison Way
brownford Road Junction
gun cotton way Etc were operated within
capacity I think Addison Way brownford
Road is in great bling them some 10
miles away so perhaps it's cheering to
see they look that far out um but could
it be clear just what area did they
cover and what sort of assumption about
the amount of traffic did they make
we've discussed a wide range of job
possibilities from I think there's a
report somewhere that mentions anything
down from 1500 up to uh several 6,000 or
so um what sort of assumptions did they
make about that and the hgv traffic that
this development would uh generate thank
you hi good morning um yes the
applicants uh provideed a transport
assessment um to support the application
which sets out uh the assumptions which
uh have been agreed by the County
Council they include the trip rates
generated for these uses and these these
quantums based on um agreed parameters
agreed trip rates you know per per meter
squared for these uses um the list of
committed developments included
development in excuse me and great
lenham um which you've highlighted and
assess the
Junctions in and around the vicinity of
the site and found that they had
residual capacity um the suff model does
cover the whole of suffk and has
coverage into Cambridge here essic and
Nori so uh yeah the the scoping is
extensive did you want to come back John
and the assumptions on uh employment
rates you're saying are based on
um numbers of vehicles per square foot
of development is that what you said or
per square meter of development actually
yeah exactly it's a a National Database
um that surveys similar uses all across
the country and the applicants um select
the sample of sites that are as closely
applicable to the development as
possible um to and because there's a
range of um sites included in that
database you you build up a you know an
average um which is the
agreed um sort of methodology for
calculating trips on you have the
exactly the same approach on on
residential development this is the
agreed approach for generating trips and
has been agreed through the scoping with
the County Council case
officer thank you could I return to my
other point um there's considerable
concern about the uh use of the uh Road
um from past clamp Farm down towards the
A14 or the a140 A14 Junction um and I
think if I picked out correctly you're
you're going to provide some sort of
advisories um are you to to prevent hgv
traffic using that route uh no mention
of any sort of weight restriction or any
more effective control are you confident
that that's going to be
sufficient um yeah I mean that that is
the approach that the applicants are
taking through the travel plan to
control um traffic from the development
to go out um um via the 1120 and not use
mil Lane
um as always the devil's in the detail
in terms of the travel plan you know
that does have to be robust it does have
to be enforcable um to control traffic
um and that is something that we would
expect to be conditioned uh highways
England have also expected it to be
conditioned and we will obviously be
consulted on the discharge of that
condition in due course should the site
be
approved and you're confident that
that's sufficient
well frankly until I see it now but you
know I'm confident with the approach um
to secure the travel plan through
condition um but in terms of the
efficacy of the travel plan I I'll
Reserve judgment until I till I see the
detail secured by
condition councelor passman um thank you
very much Matthew just don't know why it
does that I'll lean away um just a
couple of points to raise actually
following on from traffic if if we do
have 3,000 jobs there and obviously a
lot of traffic going in and out
presumably there will be some need for a
traffic light system Etc that's a detail
to come up later if it's coming out on
to to the roundabout or or where
wherever it is um the other point which
is um I'm not sure where this really a
planning matter but I think it's an
important issue um if this gets planning
mission is developed um how we situated
here for supplies of things like water
power clearly on the A14 Corridor for
super fast broadband that's important um
but if it isn't sufficient are there
going to be other consequences when we
need to upgrade Supply or has that been
taken into account I've already where
the applicants may wish to comment on
that but it is an important point I
think that is worthy of consideration
and then a further Point uh if this is
to be a Rolls-Royce development and one
that we're all proud of if if it goes
ahead I hasten to add um looking at
overall site security I know the
constabies responded but if you if you
have some really high value high-tech
Industries there site security is
important um is that something that will
be conditioned or section or something
um if permission were to be to be given
so in other words keeping site secure
and tight is it going to be fenced or
parts of it going to be secured how
might that happen or is that a detail to
come up at a later stage thank you very
much thank you um so in terms of
infrastructure we are um as part of the
full application have a proposal for a
substation so that is uh essentially
proposed as part of the early
infrastructure to come in um beyond that
um that would be something we'd have to
come back to but generally that would be
the explanation and perhaps we can ask
the uh the agent for any further
information
umur thank you sorry soorry Focus um
yeah s security said we are literally
looking at the the outline we haven't
got any details of that but we would
expect ECT that as part of any reserve
matters any fencing and similar that
that's the case with the lighting that's
why we leave it for Reserve matters so
that we can have that site
specific Council
man
uh uh thank you chair um while whilst
we're on the highways comments I'm just
looking at page 38 of our papers where
we've got a summary um about public
rights of way network uh and the last
bullet point says um that we would um
anticipate that public and employees
will use um the foot path from the
gipping valley uh to access the site on
foot and would' like to see improvements
made to that path I presume that you're
talking about the path alongside the
river gipping um and is that um part of
the condition or not can you please
clarify thank
you the
um requirement for the 106 is uh Works
to W grade foot path 1 and 25 which are
across the top creting
um with that and then there's a public
right of way Improvement of 2,700 to
footpath 57 which is the one referenced
by the public right of way along the
giing
valley councelor Matson yeah while we're
on these topics the right moment to to
ask a a smallest question Mr Barber
probably um the when we were actually
drawing up the the um the development
brief I think um I asked particularly
and went and looked on site at the
connectivity once you'd come from the
site over the Mill Lane
overbridge um how that the cyc and
walking path connected into the cedus
park site and and at that time it was
very poor and very poorly signed and
everything and I I can't see anywhere
that that point has ever been taken
forward um in in the in the papers um
it's offsite I know that but on the
other hand you know access and
connectivity um it'd be reasonable
assume that people on Cedar Park going
to work on this site and and this is the
way we would prefer them to
travel so can we can we do something
about that or have I missed in the
papers um yeah I think I mean clearly
the the master plan is predicated on
stopping up Middle Lane um once it's
over the overbridge so there won't be
any vehicular traffic um or very limited
traffic on that section of the road so
it's it will be more safer and
convenient for walking and
cycling as I will apologize I wasn't the
original case officer so I'm might have
to defer to Gemma but I don't believe
any specific mitigation was sought that
side of the
1120 no I think we we the expectation is
that the it's closed to vehicular
traffic and retained open for pedestrian
and and cycle traffic that it links
through the application site uh through
various foot paths and roadways in that
way so there is good connectivity into
the site uh and then as Luke said the um
the road would be closed and it links
down over the over Bridge and down ever
slightly onto um further into I wonder
Mandy perhaps we could pop the slide
back up
again there we go what we do um wrong
Mouse you can just see so we've got the
M over bridge and then we come all the
way down so there is that projection so
there is it does go beyond the end of
the Mone
Bridge so
that line can you turn your mic on John
just
sorry yeah that that that line where you
you've gone away from again now across
across the 1120 so that that's where the
the T and Crossing would be is it that's
the T Crossing through here yeah and
then the and this is the overbridge and
then down slightly Beyond
there yeah um yeah I think I think what
I was looking at at that time was was
the obvious desire line once you've come
across
into into the top of Cedar Park that
that that was particularly poor and and
probably still is unfortunately so not
nothing for that then is
proposed okay councelor eburn you're
next um thank you very much chair um
just on the um travel plan um I know
that's in in the conditions just as
travel plan but on page 37 there's um
points about the bus travel and the fact
that there are it says no evidence of
discussions local bus operators etc etc
um is a bus stop being put in in the
hope that there will be a bus service
because um if there isn't a bus service
it seems um you know very we've got to
get 3,000 people to and from this site
and they we don't want them all to drive
and some will cycle and walk but we we'd
like someone to take the bus will a bus
stop be provided thank
you so travel PL is including a shuttle
bus um did it include stop specifically
what
we I don't believe u there's any
specific um stops identified but again
that would depend somewhat on the on the
uses and what is a logical routing with
within the site uh but as it's an
outline that could could potentially be
dealt with as Reserve
matters okay well what we'll do is we'll
move on to is everyone happy to keep
going
yes yeah if I might I've got one one
remaining group of of of questions
really and that is is you know is the
relationship between the application in
front of us um the saap and the
development brief again and what um
there's two two things really one is
what I would broadly describe as the
intensification and I wonder if if um
officer can tell us the um um the sort
of the
percentage um increase in the the built
area that we have here compared to what
was previously envisaged um I did have
the page a minute ago um looks like it
might be some of this stuff on page 53
perhaps and um and also the having heard
what you said about mitigating The
increased building
Heights by changing the the land level
so the effect is I don't think you said
eliminated but is less than it would
otherwise be so how much you know and
obviously it's a broad average across
several different heights of buildings
are specified how much are we adding to
the to the the volume by making the
physical building from its ground to its
roof um High you know if you took it in
terms of of of pallets would we put
pallets in you know what's the sort of
broad those two measures of the
intensification of the site we got we
got the question JMA um so I can't
probably do that in a percentage terms
um so we were
looking
check
[Applause]
at
sorry so we were looking at uh 58
hectares on Phase 1 and 21 hectares on
Phase 2 is the allocation in the state
market area action plan
7.9 uh whereas we have got that increase
in um area essentially under this
application neither the state Market era
action plan the the development brief or
the applications we've had to date have
come in with floor space specifically so
that has never been set down in stone so
I couldn't say that you know we had this
amount of floor space previously it is
and has been in outline so far so we
haven't got a specific amount of floor
space that we could compare to there is
an increase in the overall area as we've
seen we're not proposing the areas in
Orange of the development brief for the
sports area there's been the reduction
in the Landscaping buffer so there has
been that increase in net developable
land that has been anticipated uh in the
joint loal plan coming forward and there
is a a larger designation of employment
land in the joint local plan policy but
obviously we we're not at the point of
uh having that adopted just yet so there
is that difference in where we were with
where we could go in the future um in
terms of levels so I said the Vel brief
didn't give a a flat surface to build
from it it didn't give an um above or
stum for a flat level it left the site
with its natural topography it then gave
us a height above that for evees level
so at what point we would say it would
be reasonable to say you're measuring
off the lower part or the higher part
and where the development platform might
have been isn't unknown from the
development Brave what we're saying now
is we've got a um maximum height above
ordinance datum and we've got a maximum
Building height so we know that that
would be the top of our um envelope and
if the level changed so that we've got a
lower building level the building would
come down it wouldn't be that we'd
suddenly say oh we're still at the top
of that and our building is now 30 m
we've proposed by condition a very
specific building height and a maximum
above ordinance datum so that we know
that that is the top of the envelope
that we're looking at and then we can
secure the full details by condition and
Reserve matters does that that clarify
thank
you yeah I I don't think it actually
gives much of a handle on on
fundamentally asking the question
answering the question of what what is
the degree explain that you that that
detail isn't available so we
can't okay councelor
field sorry can I continue on building
Heights for a moment first of all
looking at your cut and fill plan if I
understand that that correctly you've
got some green areas where you're adding
2 m to the existing landfill land
height and some red areas right adjacent
we were taking 6 to 7 m off the height
that's about the height of this room I
think roughly so quite dramatic shifts
across
there and in the southern area of the
site you're talking about
adding if any my eyes were better on
these tiny print 6 to 7even M to the
existing ground level so we have a site
in which you're taking off six m in one
corner and adding on six m in the other
corner to make it level I guess the
arithmetic fits but I just then looked
at the height of the
buildings which in the development
brief well they EES but you've estimated
a building height particularly on the
plot 4,000 you're talking about 12 M
Building height in the northern half
that's where you're taking 6 M off
nowadays and 19 m in the southern half
where it's sort of sitting in a 6 M
Hardway and you're proposing to change
that to a 21 M Building height
from the mid level if you like that does
seem a dramatic change did I understand
that correctly or have I got it wrong no
I I think that's a fair summary that it
is somewhere in the Realms of perhaps a
10 meter difference overall if you look
at building Heights versus
aods but I said it's difficult to tell
against the development brief because it
hasn't got that same levels information
and it didn't predict a level platform
to build from but yes essentially there
there is a significant increase over and
above what the development brief might
have been anticip iated to provide and
I've tried to look on that as a worst
case scenario so the development brief
being at its lowest point this the
levels we know it's
at but we're starting off because you
filled the ground up 7 m further up and
then you've got a building that's 10 m
higher sitting on top of
that it's quite dramatic Y is it also
practical to have a site at which you
remove and shift around that amount of
spoil have the dramatic think that's one
[Laughter]
the okay I'm going to move us on uh
people content to keep now for about
another half hour before we have a break
there's no one desperate for break good
okay so we'll go straight into the
speakers um so thanks and if you've got
questions just save them up and we can
come back to the officers for more
questions if anything comes to light as
we go through so I'd now like to invite
the representative from creting St Peter
Parish Council to speak to us welcome to
Lyn Jardine Lynn you have three minutes
we have a timer here we do ask you to
please keep to that three minutes and
over to you when you're
ready thank you I start by saying
creating St Peter Parish Council in
principle do not object to the
development but feel that insufficient
steps are being taken to mitigate the
impact on the parish and therefore ask
councilors to refuse the application
today our main concerns are visual
impact fact the village is not shown on
the plans in the briefing document but
the edge of of it is just 450 M from the
development we have continually asked
for increased screening along the
eastern boundary of the site we would
like to see a 4 meter Earth band and
inner and width of 20 M mature tree
planting along the eastern boundary this
has been offered in the past at a public
meeting by the developer but is not
shown in the scheme it needs to be
ensured the screening is maintained and
trees not allowed to die
doing this will mitigate the impact of
light noise and dust
also we're concerned about the lack of
community benefit we would like to see
more green space areas in the current
proposal there is just 1.5 hectares on a
site of approximately 70 hectares
representing just 1 and a half% we need
to know how this area is going to be
maintained in the longterm and
confidence that it will not become just
a jungle of weeds please confirm what
the country contribution will be to
upgrade foot paath one in the village to
a cycle way unless full funds are
available this cannot be achieved
planning conditions our experience of
planning conditions in the parish has
been complied with and en forc gives us
great concern we have an industrial site
in the parish where for years planting
has not been carried out as agreed
lighting and working hours restrictions
ignored but the LPA LPA have failed to
take any remedial action the result of
which has led to a lot of residential
amenity and a blot on the landscape we
need assurance that any planning
conditions imposed will be adequate
adequately complied with and
enforced provision of facilities we urge
that full and proper consideration be
given to the provision of services on
the site at this stage there is already
a problem along footpath 15 in the
village with Lorry drivers parking up
and using it as a toilet littering is
also a problem since McDonald's arrived
there was a massive increase in litter
around the village thrown from
Vehicles highways there already many
incidents along mil Lane at pinch points
including clamp Farm Bend and the road
is not wide enough for two hgvs to pass
we are concerned the development will
lead to increased traffic as people seek
to get through the back entrance to the
site which will make this road even more
dangerous for cyclists and pedestrians
perhaps our biggest concern is people
traveling to the development from the
north will use Pound Road which goes
through the village Center as a cut
through no doubt satnavs will direct
them this way particularly in TR times
of traffic buildup our village is narrow
with no Pavements and it's poorly lit
and this will lead to significant danger
there are a number of school bus stops
along this route so in summary I
emphasize that creating St Peter Parish
Council are not against this development
in principle but we need far greater
consideration of the concerns we raise
and steps taken to mitigate the impact
to the development before permission is
granted so for the safety and well-being
of par parishioners we urge counselors
to refuse its application today thank
you thank you you go about 20 seconds
but it was your last sentence I I ran
with it thank you thank you um so just
I'll do the same with the others just to
be fair okay do we have any questions at
all for the parish council yes councilor
M yeah perhaps I could return to my my
question about the missing um View um
perspective um you might remember I was
asking about the um what what the what
the view would be like from from the the
the northern side of the
A14 um as one got into the rising land
um and
and what what you feel that you know
that is you know to what degree is is
there actually Landscaping on the north
of the A14 um or what's what is on the
south of the A14 come to that um you
know are you going to see it a bit a lot
or or you know what what's the
understanding of
that I think we feel we'll see see it a
lot um the village is split by the A14
as you probably know the the main
village Center is a raised area compared
to the development site and we will look
down into it I mean you look down you
can see the lights of Stow market and
such like um and the the mitigation
proposed at the moment it's not as per
the original development brief back in
2014 where there was a lot of
Landscaping on the East it is now just a
narrow strip of about 10 m um and
obviously we're talking about buildings
that are 10 MERS higher than they were
proposed sort of 10 years ago so it is a
major concern for us we can see where
where I live on the south side of the
A14 you can see McDonald's for example
so that area is very visible for us
thank you yes thank you yeah I was
particularly
thinking John your microphone the north
of the the north of the
aout roughly speaking the north of the a
you know which side I mean um yeah where
there the height
yes yes the village is higher there is
great deal I can't picture them in mind
what the Landscaping existing is like
that's going to there is an existing
small Woodland known as plot 51 which
was um donated The Village when the A14
bisected that piece of land that does
provide some
screening um but but not sufficient
screening for the type of development
we're looking at and the scale of it
okay thank you Council and
anel uh thank you chair um I'd just like
to ask about the upgrades to footpath I
think it says 1 and 25 in our conditions
um it looks like they are to be upgraded
to Bridal way status which means that
legally you can cycle on them are you um
trying to ask for them to actually be
surfaced so they are suitable for
bicycles uh and then depending on your
answer I may just want to ask the
officer about
that yes I think they would need to be
surfaced because at the moment people
going to the Village will perhaps drop
down onto M lane and then go through um
and that just won't be a suitable route
it would need to be a surfaced path and
in the in the brief it says that a
contribution will be made um that
contribution could be a pound as far as
I know um and obviously the parish
hasn't got the funds to upgrade that to
a suitable um
surface could I just come back there is
a condition for the officers uh I think
we've got a condition on our late papers
well I'm that's where I'm reading it
anyway
that we've got public rights of way
works to widen and upgrade footpath one
and footpath 25 to a bridal way um is
that to surface them or just to create a
legal route for cycling um and uh does
that money um cover the work that's
needed to surface it suitable for
Cycles I believe that's both the legal
side and the works Luke
nodding and and can can we just clarify
I I think I get where footpath one is
which one's footpath 25 maybe you could
Point them out on the map for me thank
you
I can tell you if you're not sure
JMA I think it's because they're not
coming out on
the apologies thank you so foot path 25
um comes through
here and it's just to the corner
essentially
and then foot
path one line would be the one that
comes through the site so we can't quite
see on here and it then comes across mil
Lane essentially so they are sort of
interlinking you if you were going to
cycle from Cedar Park to creting you'd
go along the on the new if this
development goes ahead you go along the
new estate Road onto footpath one and
then it becomes footpath 25 and then it
ends up on the little lane to meeting um
have I got that right uh yes that's what
it looks like from the map and I know
we've had various discussions with
public rights of way both midu and suff
County Council to make sure that it
provides a linked route through so that
you don't come to a dead end essentially
exactly
yeah thank you very much thank you for
joining us today so we'll now move on to
an objector Mr Russell St again you have
three minutes to address the committee
and welcome good morning thank you Mr
chairman um I represent the views of
many local residents as the chair of the
local Gateway 14 campaign group and like
Lynn let me be clear on the whole the
residents do not oppose development of
the land for employment use but we have
been seeking to make this development
tolerable to its neighbors and more
ambitious in what it can achieve for the
community and the environment whil
remaining a financial success
unfortunately we are very disappointed
that the applicant and mids suffk
District Council have largely ignored
our points which is especially
embarrassing for a council L
development therefore I ask you today to
reject this application as it stands and
then create changes to and conditions
upon the application that help your
community by strengthening
mitigations and second seek greater
scrutiny of this application
it is a large complex and controversial
development and we're surprised Mr
chairman that this isn't before the
planning referrals committee and we
wonder why it doesn't deserve more
time regarding
scrutiny the application relies heavily
on the claim that in the planning
balance the economic benefit of the
development outweighs its considerable
harms but these claims for benefit come
without analysis evidence or proof that
we have seen and we've asked for we
wonder if mids suffk have fallen into
the Trap of assuming that if you spend
the money the benefits will follow is
mere Assumption of benefit good
enough the economic benefits are
unproven but the harms are
proven where is the investment case why
does Stow market area need a 40%
increase in jobs
why is it not possible to designate more
parts of the site to non Logistics to
meet mids suffix stated claim for a
mixed use site intended to inflate
average local salaries the site could be
almost entirely Logistics which should
not improve average pay nor generate the
number of jobs anticipated and finally
why do the agreed Community facilities
have to be
abandoned
regarding my second request of you
conditions to improve mitigation I've
listened this morning with interest the
northern boundary in areas has no
Landscaping on the site nor does the
northwest corner overlooking Cedar Park
and the the boundary Landscaping itself
generally is not deep enough is not high
enough and doesn't provide a true screen
for buildings 21 M high and nor
unfortunately does the planting in that
landscape and provide enough variety for
wildlife we've been asking for a more
imaginative and rewarding scheme which
should actually make the development
more interesting to uh
occupants you have gone over three
minutes if you could have the last
sentence please yes my last sentence is
design code the design code is not
rigorous enough doesn't provide what we
need at this stage and again we ask you
to reject the application and come back
and give us a better
development thank you thanks very much
right do we have any questions yes
councilor passman um thanks Matthew I
think I heard you mention about the
community benefits that no longer appear
to be there what what what was it that
either been agreed or were you looking
for um well one of the key benefits in
the original scheme was a working
recreational sports facilities uh there
was talk of a Community Hall and there
was much more recreational space within
the site the density of the site now
with regard to buildings versus that
space is much much
higher any other
questions okay thank you very much uh
we'll now move on to uh uh uh a
supporter to speak on behalf of the
application Chris starky again over to
you uh and you have three minutes
please thanks thanks very much chair uh
so I'm here from the new Anglia local
enter price partnership our role is
supporting private sector jobs growth
across suffk and Norfolk uh and I'm here
today because of the significance of the
application to to the suffk economy but
also the wider Regional economy um I
should say I come here with the
endorsement of the Chamber of Commerce
in mids and in suffk as well as uh the
clear support of The Wider business
Community um as we all know our local
economy has been severely impacted by
the pandemic thousands of businesses in
mids suff alone have been relying on
grants and Loans from local and central
government to help them through the
pandemic um while we're optimistic about
the recover recovery we can take nothing
for granted we need well-paid jobs to
rebuild our economy and fund the public
services that we all rely on uh no more
so than over the last 18 months and the
Gateway 14 site offers a great
opportunity to provide growing space for
existing businesses within Stow Market
mid suffk and The Wider area many of
whom already need more space and are
already being lost to the local area but
it also provides a huge opportunity to
attract Innovative new businesses
offering high quality jobs for our local
residents the site has been an important
part uh of the leps space to innovate
Enterprise Zone for a number of years so
we're supportive of the high quality
application before you as you know the
site's been granted gred free Port
status by the government this will help
provide funding to develop the
infrastructure needed on the site as
well as provide incentives for
businesses to locate and grow here it's
often said suffk is overlooked by the
government and its leveling up agenda
this uh is evidence it's not the case as
part of the Free Port it won't simply be
a stopping point or Storage Point on the
way to the port that's to fundamentally
misunderstand the Free Port the freedoms
given by the Freeport State as a
designed to help attract highquality
manufacturing and other additive and
Innovative businesses who would
otherwise have chosen to locate
themselves overseas or in other parts of
the
UK the site will not simply be a
logistics Hub it'll have a skills and
Innovation cluster focused on
manufacturing and green energy enabling
local businesses and young people from
the area to benefit from the development
as you know the development could bring
an extra gva per year between 75 and 250
million and more than 4,000 direct jobs
the number of jobs actually isn't the
important Point here because as we've
heard earlier it will depend on the
precise specification of the business
it's the quality of the jobs that are
most important it's also fair to say
that contr to what's been said earlier
there is already a strong pipeline of
interested businesses uh who are ready
and interested in coming here
but will simply be lost to other parts
of the country or Europe if this site is
not granted planning permission this
year you have again gone over three
minutes if you could have the last
sentence please put simply the
development is the most important
commercial development in suffix for
some years and granting commission will
be a clear signal that suffk is open for
business thank you very much any
questions yes Mr chairman thank you um
just a question on the employment
obviously Stone marking last 20 years
increased by 4 3% population so there's
a need for jobs um do you have any
figures on what the unemployment level
is within Stow Market midic particularly
I can't give you the I can't give you
the data off the top of my head in terms
of the
unemployment the the the challenge is
around the existing employers within the
town where they can locate to move to
this provides an opportunity to do that
because it's a mixed site plus also uh
plus also uh attracting inward
investment from from further
field in a sense the is the issue is
less about the number of new jobs but
more about the quality of jobs uh the
wages that are being uh that are being
provided for and in combination with
improving skills improving the
opportunities uh then the then the wage
levels wage levels will increase because
as I think everyone in the room knows
suffk is underperforms in terms of its
average
wages thank you councelor eurn you were
next
um thank you very much chair um thank
you for that um Mr starky the you you
talk about well-paid jobs um and it not
being the quantity of jobs but um the
skill of them how the this site is being
marketed um as Logistics and business
Logistics first and everything I've seen
about it and um you know I've got the
site open here this is logistics and
business and we all know Logistics isn't
well-paid jobs or high quality
um so how do you see the that kind of
slight conflict that it appears to me
that um if it was saying a manufacturing
park or business park or whatever it
might be different but the how do you um
yeah work CL that sort of site conflict
there thank you that's that's a that's a
very valid question were this site well
the the difference is that this is one
of the Freeport sites compared with the
other sites along the A4 that are not
which are tending to attract Logistics
businesses it's not to say we would
there wouldn't be any Logistics
businesses on this on this site on this
park but the freep port is about more
than just shifting Goods about the whole
purpose of the freep port policy is
about the additionality about
manufacturers so so the interest we've
had uh collectively since uh since the
Free Port status was was uh notionally
granted has been from manufacturers from
Innovative businesses so businesses who
would not have ordinarily been attracted
to to to a site like this if that makes
sense so so I you know I I I I would be
I think the future's brighter as a
consequence of that councilor
par thanks Matthew yeah um hello Chris a
couple of points just to ask you about
you mentioned earlier that the gva could
be up to 250 million quid that's a hell
of a figure um very impressive what's
the sort of evidence to get I know that
was the top end of your expectations
that I think that's important I
absolutely agree with the need to have
high value jobs we know suffk added the
whole of the Eastern region has the
average lowest wage economy of all six
counties so we need to do something
about that without a doubt so how do you
see this fitting in to be enable us to
do that and the other other thing that I
think is potentially quite important
there is this talk of reing and bringing
back in high value manufacturing there
absolutely pointless people who talk
about carbon Footprints in my view
exporting the carbon footprint to other
countries and bring it back in is there
opportunity here with this develop for
those high value jobs on that basis well
and have you got any evidence for that
thank you the short answer is correct
yes um so so in terms of the gva look it
is it's it's a spread so it's 75 to 250
people tend to get hung up on the
highest number is same with the job
number let's let's go with somewhere in
the middle because because estimates
tend to be could be either way it would
depend depend on depend on the type of
the the type of uh business so if it was
office offices then it's higher density
higher value and so on if it's and so on
as youve members already articulated ear
and the same with the job numbers
reshoring is a is is a significant
opportunity um and in terms of uh so so
we operate inward uh the inward
investment service for northc and suffk
and we are seeing an increase
particularly uh with the A14 Corridor
the opportunity not simply to bring
stuff in from China store it and and
move it to retailers that that was that
that will still continue to be the case
but ruring absolutely businesses the
pandemic interestingly with the troubles
with supply chain with supplies in China
lack of all of that stuff businesses are
seriously thinking of and indeed
starting to reassure which will you're
quite right reduce the carbon footprint
of in the embedded carbon footprint
because otherwise we're just exporting
our our carbon our carbon footprint so
so absolutely reshoring is a big
opportunity for this site much thank you
next up was councelor
field thank you just to continue with
the uh
jobs theme obviously we all want high
quality jobs I was just going to
question the Free Port issue as I
understood it is you avoid business
rights National Insurance and you
include if you bring in things that
on which there's a high tax and then
export them having assembled them with
low tax you can claim the tax bank and
all those things are relatively small
costs surely to the sort of companies
you're talking about with high value
jobs for software Engineers or so it
just is just not a concern so I wonder
why you think that this will bring in
high value jobs the the short answer is
and I I'll give you I'll give you an
example I won't name the company uh but
they are company which is manufacturing
robotics uh robotics for uh for um
surgery uh for uh theaters all around
the world um operating
theaters they were being incentivized to
go to Eastern Europe to open a facility
there and uh their R&D headquarters is
in Cambridge um their Chinese owner said
well why isn't the UK why can't the UK
provide some sort of incentive every
single government in in in the Western
World provide some sort of incentive in
order to in order to attract the best
sort of businesses now it's not
necessarily the uh you don't have to it
doesn't have to
be a very very high amount of money it's
often certainly with Chinese governments
uh businesses American American
businesses it's more about the approach
so can you uh can you get on site with
certainty and with speed and secondly
some sort of incentive to to to level
the playing field compared with moving
to another part of part of the world so
this is about attracting businesses who
would have gone elsewhere um and and
this is a they they've chosen not to
come to Stow Market because guess what
the Planning Commission hasn't been
granted yet uh but um uh but um and they
they're going somewhere else but they
were a live example of of a business
that that could have could have brought
their manufacturing instead of being in
Eastern Europe and importing it in from
there the R&D stuff in Cambridge so it's
those are the sorts of businesses that
uh that potentially we could land here
thank you councelor Mansel uh thank you
I just wanted to ask uh with the talk of
the Freeport status whether the uh this
may may not be your field it may be the
officer got to answer this whether the
um tra transport assessment has taken it
it was done before the Free Port status
was announced uh and whether it has any
effect um whether it being free Port
will affect the travel to and from the
site again we might have to touch
basically Luke on this but I mean the
the actual travel plan itself obviously
is that's condition and we'll come back
to that in due course the Baseline I
think Luke said that's across the county
can I ask you to yeah I mean the um the
data that's used to drive the trips is
National Data so that takes in a range
of different sort of delivery models um
so I think you know by taking this
aggregate approach of averaging them out
you do get different slightly different
higher end and lower end trip rate
numbers to get this average biger so it
is it is considered a robust approach
thank you c ma thank you yeah we we um
there was some very interesting stuff
thank you um I feel we're going to be
dragged back towards material planning
considerations eventually and what I
wanted to ask was um looking at uh
other other other um councils other
areas of of Nork and suff
um are you aware of of of how in
planning
terms um we we can get those good jobs
that the higher quality better paid jobs
Etc um as you've heard the objec to say
that there's nothing to stop it all
being um
all being Logistics and you said well
it's it's not going to be all just L
just
Logistics and um you know has anybody
else come up with any any good planning
ways of doing that John I well I think
that's been answered already we've been
we've heard because it's a free Port
status it has different driving models
that will bring in businesses I don't
think we're going to get a different
answer to what was given before yeah I I
I was think beyond that yeah I
understand that part of it of course
I've read that but but beyond that other
planning
policy ways in which one can push things
in the right direction so to
speak well I I can I can answer in in
general terms if that's helpful chair um
so our Enterprise zones uh we have 16
sites including including uh part of
this site which will
uh get with 14 site um and in and I will
defer to my planning colleagues in terms
of in terms of the terms but but in
terms of how those sites are marketed
how a cluster of businesses developed
around them um and um and uh so so so
how what we try what we try and do is
ensure that uh th those particular sites
have a theme attached to them so in
Great Yarmouth uh particularly The
Beacon Park site is around an energy
theme uh and uh so it is possible to uh
prevent other use her classes on it but
that's that's it's less of a planning uh
planning issue and more of an ownership
of the site and so on so you would do it
through through those sorts of
incentives and so on it's it's harder to
do it it's harder to do it strictly
through the planning system but uh I
would be content for my planning
colleagues to answer
that Mr chair thank you can I can I just
make a point that some of the things
we're discussing at the moment as far as
I'm concerned not planning issues here
to discuss planning um the way in which
it's marketed and the companies that go
in there is not planning so therefore
can we stay on track thank
you thanks any other points that anyone
wants to bring up to the uh supporter no
okay so we're going to move on uh we now
move on to the uh agent Rachel Crick
over to you and again uh three minutes
please I think we perhaps at the time
where we should have after this after
this speakers yeah
good morning councilors and thank you
for your time my name is Rachel Crick
and I'm a planning director at Aon young
Gateway 14 provides an opportunity to
deliver an allocated strategic
employment site for the district which
will create sustainable and highquality
business and Logistics Park generating
thousands of jobs the scheme includes 53
hectares of developable land to provide
business Logistics and Commercial uses
including an innovation and skills
cluster with in a comprehensively master
plan scheme the site benefits from
Freeport status which will establish
Gateway 14 as a hub for trade and
investment sustainability has been at
the Forefront of the scheme design with
sustainable features Incorporated
throughout connectivity and permeability
will be greatly improved M Lane will be
closed to traffic allowing the
overbridge to provide a new pedestrian
and cycle link which will connect
through to creting St Peter and the
gipping Valley Way a new tuen Crossing
on the a1120 will also be delivered the
application has been submitted in hybrid
which means that the proposed access
RADS and framework Landscaping are
submitted in detail and will be
delivered in the first phase unlocking
the site for development the rest of the
scheme is submitted in outline which
means that the future Reserve matters
will need to Accord with the development
principles set out in this
application we have engaged positively
with stakeholders throughout the process
consultation has taken place with local
residents parish and Ward counselors and
others resulting in a number of changes
to the proposals including reduced
building Heights revisions to land uses
and access
Arrangements I'll now summarize the
benefits of the scheme the significant
economic benefits include creating
thousands of jobs and boosting the local
and wider economy by at least 75
million buildings will meet briam very
good standard as the minimum briam
excellent where possible and all
buildings will be designed to
accommodate
PVS substantial areas of land landc
aping provide biodiversity enhancements
immunity zones for recreation and the
planted Landscaping buns provide visual
screening of the
buildings biodiversity net gain
requirements are enhan exceeded through
the proposed planting and green
corridors and appropriate ecological
mitigation has been
secured improvements to the road Network
are proposed and the master plan allows
for greater connectivity through the
site sustainable transport will be
promoted through the installation of
electric vehicle charg ing points and
the provision of a biofuel electric
shuttle bus service for
employees section 106 contributions are
secured towards local footpaths travel
plans and £190,000 towards Recreation
facilities we want to thank officers for
what has been a really collaborative
process and we are pleased that they are
able to support our application we hope
that this is a scheme that members are
also able to support today I'm joined by
various members of The Wider consultant
team so we're happy to answer any
questions that you've got today thank
you thank you um I've well I'll let
others go first I'll coming at the end
uh we start councelor paral and M and
even thank you um thanks very much for
that um could you just comment on the
issue about Community facilities that
were raised by um our friends just in
front front of you is there any any way
that could be developed further to um to
look at that you may already have done
some of that but I think that's an
interesting point clearly if permission
is given we want to make sure we're
working with everybody and I know you've
made some efforts but what else might
you be prepared to do on that
please
sorry um in terms of kind of recreation
immunity space um we have got a
biodiversity immunity Zone which can be
accessed by both workers and local
residents um in terms of formal
Recreation spaces they weren't included
within the previous two applications and
a financial contra contribution was
secured and we're proposing the same
approach this time around um in order to
provide those kind of more Community
facilities is there any room for
negotiation on that you
think it's
on in respect to specific facilities
yeah um I
mean the the premise of the scheme is to
deliver a business Logistics employment
oh yeah of course scheme so um it in in
terms of additional facilities it's
quite Limited in in any additional um
things that we're were able to
offer Council maner uh thank you um you
you mentioned that you've done some
collaboration with the local
communities um and made some changes um
but um what are your comments regarding
the buffering and bonding sort of
landscaping to the north of the site uh
where we've heard from the residents of
cing St Peter that those have been
vastly reduced since the um sort of
initial discussions and the area action
plan uh and yet they seem to be quite
minimum now so could we have your view
on how you've um met the community's
aspirations in that particular field
thank you yes so in respect of um kind
of landscaping impacts um and assessment
that's been undertaken we are we aren't
providing the same kind of depth of plan
um as envisaged in the um development
brief but that doesn't mean that we
aren't providing um decent structural
Landscaping that will act to provide
some screening towards the development
obviously due to the site levels this
the scheme will be visible there's no
way that we're going to be able to um
completely obscure all of BU all the
buildings on the site through the
Landscaping um even if it was of a
further depth and so what we've done is
we've undertaken a really robust
assessment of landscape visual impacts
including views from the north um from
the north of the site and those have
been deemed by your landscape officer to
be acceptable in terms of um mitigating
the impact as far as we can can I just
ask a follow up on that particular
question so if members decided that the
landscape proposals don't go far
enough uh let's say and we decide we do
want a bond or we want something like
that added is that something that they
you would
consider
um I mean we we feel that the buildings
are adequately screened um and we we
don't think that would be um necessary
to make our development acceptable
that's not the question I'm asking
though well we'll come we'll come back
to it we'll see where the committee goes
um okay uh we move on to councelor
eburn um you want to switch
your um thank you very much chair um
funny that was the question I was going
to ask um the um firstly a couple of
simple ones there's a query about Anglia
water um but chy confirm that you're
working with Anglia water to um U
resolve the points they make um secondly
um You referred to a a bus could you
confirm whether there'll be a a bus stop
to service a bus and um on the point of
landscaping um I was exactly going to
ask um if the committee was to condition
that the Landscaping was a deeper depth
particularly um towards creating St
Peter and the views from Cedar Park then
then if we were to condition that um
would um how much of that would you be
able to um resolve and I've I have got a
further question if I
may Philip wants to come in on the point
I we've both raised thank you chairman
yes just so we're clear about what we're
talking about we have a hybrid
application part of it is outlined part
of it is full the framework Landscaping
is within the full part of that to amend
the area of the framework Landscaping
would be to amend that part of the
application so any change to that will
need careful thought um because clearly
that full element is what you have in
your uh application before you today uh
and simply to change the area rather
complicates matters greatly and would
need officers to take just a little time
to look at if that were where commit
where to go
chairman thanks and did you want um yes
if M may come back then um but
presumably on on on that if um the
committee was saying that they wanted um
to see greater Landscaping particularly
um protecting those communities
then you know that could be as a
condition and they could go away and if
this it can't be done then it would come
back
to committee is that correct
or just thinking about this as as you
describe it uh uh counselor I think
there are various potential ways you
might achieve the purpose um uh and I'm
conscious that uh we don't succeed as a
planning Authority where we delay
development so I wouldn't wish to do
that but I understand the objective so
that would probably need five minutes
for officers to think out mechanisms
what committee chooses to do with this
application is entirely in committee's
gift um thank you can I just on a a
final point I think I think that would
be very helpful thank you um Philip for
that um just on the Mind understanding
of um us looking at planning
applications is that we have to look at
the public benefits and as one of those
points is the economic benefits and
therefore I just wanted to check with a
legal officer that we are able to ask
questions about the economics because
that is part of the public
benefits is this is this the right
microphone yes I the short answer is yes
yes you can certainly test what being
being said to you by asking
questions okay we have no yes Council
Mason thank you yeah um if I could
return to to the question I asked some
um some people ago on the these
landscape sections and views of which
there are several and my question which
couldn't be answered earlier was that
you have provided these
um and my question is how many years
ahead
of today well of development
starting
um are these are these uh indications of
views Etc um they used to be SL slides
30 to
34 um in the papers if that's any help
to anybody because the numbers are all
different up on the screen um so John
just very specifically what's your
question well the question is is those
those those four or five slides
show views they they show sectional
views yeah of the where the buildings
would be and and where people are and so
on and what my question is what is the
Assumption about how many years into the
future so so how many years the they
showing okay yeah
thanks thank you I'll answer that
question and then I'll go back to the
previous questions that I didn't get an
opportunity to answer so in respect of
the landscape sections what we've done
um these will be planted during um these
um for full approval so they'll be
planted as soon as possible the
assessment stages have been done up to
15 years so within the tree species that
we are proposing um the heights of the
trees will range from 8 m to 40 m so if
you consider that the tallest building
that we're seeking approval for is 21 M
that gives you a scale of the planting
that we're proposing and um and the
assessment work that we've done has been
based on the Imp implementation from 15
years in respect of the query um on
Anglia water we have engaged with them
and we will continue to do so um as we
go forwards um regarding the bus stop we
have looked um as a team to see whether
there would be the ability to provide a
bus stop within the site it does fit so
once we get to the point in the travel
plan monitoring that we need to provide
that that is something that we can um
deliver I think that was all of your
questions okay yes last question my my
other returned to to earlier questions
really is is about what I sort of
broadly described as
intensification and um we we've got this
we've got this figure of of 39 hectares
and and 52 hectares um or 53 hectares
we're on page 53 at the moment and I
also noticed joh can I just shortcut you
you've already asked a question the
officer couldn't answer should we just
see if the applicant can answer the same
question that you asked before CU I'm
sure yeah yeah I I just wanted to point
to page 153 where there's a similar uh
there's a similar stat from the County
Council uh which might help everybody
possibly can you answer the question
about the the comparables that we that
we raised with Gemma before yes so in
terms of quantum and percentage increase
um the Stow market area action plan and
the development brief don't set a
maximum floor space Quantum so when you
look at the two previous permissions on
the site the total floor space approved
is
166,50 square m we are seeking a maximum
floor space of 227
830 square m which through my quick
calculations is a 37% uplift terms of
Flor space right yeah what the other
half of that if I may check the other
half of that was what the um I mean in
terms of say excluding the the office
sort of buildings and so on the you know
what is the the increase of the volume
of building that you're getting through
the building being higher if it is
higher and and we've been struggling a
bit with with pinning that down in I
have anyway yeah in terms of volume I
don't have those calculations for you
I'm afraid the square meters gives you a
good
indication yeah yeah yeah up yeah well
we've heard it some's taken off some's
added across the site so okay uh I'm
we're just about there then okay
councelor field just as I was about to
say we're there cancer field wouldn't
like you to get away with that um I I
did ask a question of the officer that
couldn't be answered so I thought I
would repeat it to the agent uh the the
amount of cut and fill that's shown on
the indicative cut and fill plan seems
quite dramatic I was just questioning is
that a realistic plan on which we're
basing our views some seven MERS off in
some parts of the site over what appears
to be a tiny distance and some okay
similar amount added on in others you
just introduce yourself and your name
just so we know who are you're answering
the question please thank you chair uh
my name is Mark gettis I'm a director of
Richard Jackson Consulting engineering
we've been involved in the preparation
of the application in terms of
engineering and transport um I think the
best example I can give you is a current
site in suffk where we are going down 12
M and up 9 so yes the cut fill is
entirely feasible and when you have uh
to deliver development platforms on a
slopey site there is a over 20 M level
change from the north west it's the
North Point to the South Point there
will be significant changes in level
it's entirely practical it happens all
the time and indeed you'll note the A4
has some significant level changes from
the the uh the location through which it
runs in some parts it's in Phill in some
parts in Cut hopefully that
helps thank you okay so what I propos
now is we've got the ward members to
speak but before we I propose we take a
break before them because we've been
going uh we've been going quite we've
been going for two and a half hours and
we normally try and have a break every
90 minutes or so so can we have a a
10minute break and we'll start again at
10 p with the ward members uh and we'll
go straight to that you're going to take
take a decision now about the def mday
it's not lunch yet but I'm I thought you
said at noon at noon at noon at was your
words well I can be flexible uh yeah I
think I think in all reality we're not
going to get to the last two are we I
think looking at the time now so I think
thank you okay so we'll leave officers
to to make those calls the reason I
didn't before is because you can get uh
and we have had it before at this
committee where at the last minute you
get an injunction that a case can't be
heard and that has happened where we've
suddenly had to pull applications at f
25 minutes past 9 so that's why I just
wanted to hold off you never know what's
going to happen with these I still think
we'll be lucky to get to the uh the the
one before the one we well let's have a
break and enjoy our coffee see you in 10
minutes
[Music]
so welcome back everyone uh thank you
for coming back so quickly we're going
to move on now to the uh Ward
members um now we have uh obviously
councelor
Müller uh councelor Norris and coun coun
Carter who are going to speak I have an
email from councelor Carter would you
like that read out first second or third
what order would you like to
do
okay okay fine okay so this is the email
received from councelor Carter who uh
who can't be here
today um I'd like to start by thanking
officers developer Representatives
representatives of the council and my
fellow counselors for allowing my my
participation in active public
participation for the informative and
concise presentation from the developers
and generally proud to be involved in
this standard setting development
representing both the views and ideals
of the community and the council an
effort which we can all be proud of
unfortunately however neither I nor
judging by the overwhelming amount of
lobbying received our constituents
believe that any of this to be the case
so instead of doing so I should be
rather I should rather be moving swiftly
on this new proposal fails to reflect on
the original agreed plans which I was
not originally opposed against not to
borrow too heavily from the materials
provided by residents it's fair to say
that a wide range of lower density lower
rise commercial premises alongside
Community facilities have been utterly
swept aside from an unproven
profit-driven proposals lacking
straightforward and viable changes to
make a more successful development which
could have avoided looming problems
better reflecting the recent adoptions
of declaring a climate emergency while
simultaneously failing to better serve
the community not just infrastructure
but also by proven provided job
opportunities I'd be am Miss to fail to
note the weak inadequate design code
fails to deliver the benefit of of
requiring a consistent appearance and
style of the site to blend into its
locality ignores the potential power
generation from solar lacking a
requirement solar panels on the roofs
whilst the boundary Landscaping of only
10 to 15 M wide in most areas and none
in others fails to create the deep and
consistent screen you'd expect for the
unusually high buildings The Limited
selection of the species fails to
capture the opportunity presented by
seeking advice on supporting planting
for a much more rewarding
outcome my astute colleague counselor
Dave Müller is certain to detail the
lack of foresight in the traffic
management measures whilst barely
meeting policy models won't address the
current and foreseeable problems in the
surrounding areas to note invisage
congestion increased traffic on narrow
PVE pavement rat runs inadequate
lighting unsafe narrow bends and lack of
requirements for adequate vehicle
parking and facilities for hgv drivers
help me out here Dave if I've missed a
few if councelors have yet to read the
letter by Mr Crosby I suggest you do and
read it well knowing today is limited to
the shackles of our current planning
process I doubt I'd be allowed to note
how mids suff position in handling this
application being the land owner the
applicant The Beneficial developer and
at the same time being the local
planning Authority will never look right
to the public your decision here today
reflects on ms's role as a developer and
that will reflect on every councel we
need the council to stand by the
supplementary planning document it
approved in 2014 and tells its
development arm to think again come up
with a higher quality development we can
be proud of mids suff should be setting
example on how a green sustainable
beautiful development can be created
with imagination and determination
instead there this going to be another
load
sorry Instead This is just going to be
just another load of ugly sheds thank
you kind regards
Terren okay over to you councelor
Müller members will have received
comments from a number of cedus Park and
creting St Peter residents stating their
concerns about this development they are
concerned and in many cases angry that
these new proposals do not reflect the
original agreed plans for the site which
had a wide range of lower density lower
rice commercial premises alongside
Community facilities and the case for
the new proposals is not
proven the boundary Landscaping needs to
be a minimum of 20 M deep around all the
site to give 2 m trees depth and the
species planted must grow to at least 21
M high and in sufficient number to
create a consistent screen on the
boundary I believe the height of the
largest Warehouse will have a far
greater impact for residents of c and St
Peter and despite the bond particularly
for the residents of clamp farm and the
dwellings next door bearing in mind that
these trees will not come to full growth
for at least 15 years I do welcome the
ecological enhancement measures proposed
and hope these will be an excess of the
10% biodiversity net gain for the site I
welcome the integral bat and bird boxes
bug hotels nectar Rich flowers to
support local population of butterflies
moths bees and other insects wood and
Brash piles to support invertebrates and
H bacular near to water bodies for
amphibians and reptiles I also welcome
the retention
21,6 40 square m of existing habitat and
enhancement of
2,432 square m virtually every resident
expressed concerns about the amount of
traffic driving through Cedar Park
estate as a resident of cedus part
myself I fully endorse these comments as
I have on many occasions witnessed what
they are telling me about I do however
welcome the closure of Mill Lane and the
proposed cycle footpath onto the site I
have received complaints from residents
about speeding traffic where Mill Lane
is being used as a Rat Run however I do
appreciate this will not help the
residents of creating St Peter as the
road by clamp Farm cannot be widened and
local re residents of the village are
unfortunately still likely to see their
part of Mill Lane still being used as a
rat run I also welcome signage on the
A14 directing traffic to Junction 50 and
the
a120 however whenever the A14 has been
closed in the past either through Road
works or an accident despite signage
directing traffic along the a120
invariably the traffic has come via
kastal drive and Swift Drive which are
totally unsuitable for large hgv
vehicles and on several occasions I have
seen these
vehicles becoming stuck as a result of
other par Vehicles across the estate
also with the closure of mil Lane hgv
Vehicles should not try and access
Gateway 14 via creting Road East
Mortimer Road and gun cotton Way Gun
cotton way is becoming increasingly busy
with increased traffic from the Tomo
industrial State and the Industrial
Development along the road traffic will
become even busier once the 141
properties are built traffic has also
increased following the opening of
McDonald and Costa Coffee two years
ago I have recently received complaints
from local residents whose properties
are next to gun cottonway about the
increased traffic and the deterioration
of the road surface I question whether
the Lo local Road network will cope with
the additional traffic going to and from
Gateway 14 bearing in mind the
congestion residents currently
experience at the top end of gun cotton
way I have to question is the proposed
transport plan even fit for
purpose I appreciate it may not be
possible to include a condition for
contractors not to use a state road but
I know residents will be very annoyed if
they do if members are minded to approve
this application I would ask those
responsible for appointing contractors
Etc to take into account of the views of
local
residents residents are also concerned
that no no contractors Park their
vehicles on Cedar Park as parking is
already a nightmare sufficient toilet
facilities and parking must be provided
on the site for contractors once
construction
begins I do welcome the proposed biofuse
biofuel stroke electric bus this will be
of benefit to local residents and
hopefully that will be made available to
local residents as well as res as well
as people working on the site who do not
own a car and wish to travel into town
and back public transport is virtually
non-existent on Ceda park at present a
point which several elderly residents
have mentioned to me and they would
certainly welcome the use of this bus
service any construction on the site
should utilize low carbon Technologies
wherever possible and any lighting
should be smart and perhaps with LED
bulbs I support the use of air source
heat pumps rainwater recycling electric
vehicle charging points but with
electric vehicles expected to become the
norm will 20% active and 20% passive
points be sufficient in the
future residents are very annoyed the
proposed development seems to have more
warehousing than original original plans
indicated The Innovation Center is
welcomed but residents feel this is not
an Exemplar site as originally proposed
which would have offered a far greater
variety of potential job opportunities
in line with the comments Etc I have
receiv received from local residents I
do not support the proposed Mega
warehouse and not one resident has said
to me they support that particular uh
Warehouse I would argue in accordance
with paragraph 126 of the nppf the
national policy planning framework that
the creation of high quality beautiful
and sustainable buildings and places is
fundamental to what the planning and
development process should achieve good
design as a key aspect of sustainable
development creates better places in
which to live and work and helps make
developments acceptable to communities
local residents do not consider this to
be the case with these proposals
paragraph 127 States design policy
should be developed with local
communities so they reflect local
aspirations and are grounded in an
understanding of each area's defining
characteristics once again residents do
not feel this is the case and have
mentioned to me they would welcome more
input so the development can be an
Exemplar site which we can all be proud
of I would also question the Pelican
Crossing on the a1120 is this actually a
safe place for a Crossing bearing in
mind from what I have observed vehicles
are not slow moving along the road and
tend to speed up once they have come off
both a Tesco and Cedar's roundabouts at
the bottom although I welcome new jobs
which will be created by this proposed
development with a potential gross value
added to the local economy of at least
75 million and possibly as much as 250
million residents need to be convinced
of the number of jobs proposed as from
what I hear of the logistics industry
large warehouses tend to be mainly
automated with some jobs for example
forklift truck driving jobs the
inclusion of the site as part of
Freeport East will will be of benefit to
businesses operating within Freeport
sites and have the potential to attract
500 million of investment to the region
over the next few years providing a 650
million pound boost to the UK economy as
a whole in summary despite some positive
issues being proposed in the application
the inclusion of the vast majority of
local residents who have contacted me is
that they do not object to employment on
this site but the current plans fall
well short of what is required or should
be expected of a development owned by
this Council there are feasible sensible
straightforward and viable changes which
could be considered to help avoid
looming problems in the future as one of
the elected representatives of the Stow
thorny Ward having listened to what
residents have said to me I am able to
give my wholehearted support to this
application thank you thank you um do we
want to do questions to each Ward
members as we go do we have any at this
point or we can take them all at the end
yeah so councilor humre is then
councelor Ian Mr chair thank you um just
a question keep
saying I
can my mic is
on I don't like to something people's
backs but I'll talk louder um those a
really good presentation you talk about
the residents a lot um I know it's the
largest state with at least 1200 houses
how many residents actually contacted
you I I could tell you the exact number
I speak to people regularly on a day
sorry on on a day-to-day basis um counc
humre I I regularly meet them in tesos
I've had two further phone pres this
week expressing their concerns about
this particular development although as
I said overall people do not object to
employment land on this site using it
for LA employment I also do not I'm not
against being used for employment land
but obviously I need to take the um um
What the residents have said to me and
not one has actually said they like the
mega
warehouse thank you councilor Manel
sorry
Evan um thank you chair um thank you
councelor Miller for your um
presentation and also chair for reading
out councilor Carters um just with
regards to traffic through um Cedar Park
um the well firstly actually with
regards to construction management I
assume that we can condition in terms of
construction management to not use Cedar
Park not park on you know park on the
site and all of those um relevant
conditions because it's a nightmare
there um and um you know one of these
planning committees
did create that issue there to start
with but however we are where we are um
and but with regards to um cedus Park
particularly are there any um
suggestions as to how um it can be
mitigated in terms of um not using this
the estate as a cut through once the
site's up and running um are there any
suggestions on that front thank you J um
thank you councelor Eber um person Al um
I agree that once the site is up and
running that would be very difficult um
as I did mention in my in my speech
we've had large hdv Vehicles actually
become stuck one actually got stuck in a
CER sack and nearly went into somebody's
house we've had situations where the
traffic instead of going down the a 1120
have come all through Cedar's Park
therefore the residents from the side
roads cannot get out of the side
rows the the problem with gun cotton way
that has got increasingly busy since
since McDonald's and Costa coffeee
opened and residents regularly tell me
that they've sometimes waited 20 minutes
to try and even cross the road if
they're a pedestrian it's absolutely
horrendous and will only actually get
worse um and I have found that myself as
well um trying to cross the road to sort
of you know to agree What the residents
have actually told me but no it's
parking on Cedar Park is horrendous as
you as you may well be aware and any
large L is going to have great
difficulty getting through so we need to
have something in place that hopefully
people will will take notice of that
thank
you um thank you for that chair if I
might come back I don't know if we can
ask the officer from highways whether
there is any mitigation planned for
Cedar Park within the in the travel plan
on the points that have been made thank
you um nothing specific at this stage
but you know the travel plan is
conditioned so the travel plan will have
to be um consulted on we will be a
statut constitute that process so we'll
obviously respond accordingly when we're
when we're consulted so that point could
be picked up at the next round okay
thank you yeah Philip uh thank you
chairman yes I mean you have conditions
which talk about uh construction
management plan uh using access via the
A14 and a a120 and it will be possible
uh to include a specification in there
to um uh avoid using ceders part if you
wish to amend it okay thank you uh
councelor pmore you thanks Matthew um
though wanted I think we can deal with
some of the issues if um regarding the
landscape we had an extensive discussion
on that on these Community facilities I
don't know if you had any anything you
wish to add to that what might be
expected or what you would like to see
that would actually help um nullify some
of the residents concerns please can I
just expand on that same point that that
Council pass so so we've heard that
there's money coming forward which
matches the previous two applications so
where should if if you had a view where
should that money go that would help the
local residents thank you chair um I can
certainly see there would potentially be
a need for perhaps some Nursery
facilities for workers on on the site if
it's actually approved however there are
there is a nursery at busy bees at the
top of Cedar Park just off castal Drive
um we did have a nursery at Cedar Park
Community Center which is now finished
but I am actually interviewing
candidates on Friday for a potential new
Nursery to take over um regarding other
facilities I think it's useful for
workers on that on the on the site to
have some sort of community facility
they can use but I do not think a
community center would would be um
beneficial in the sense you've got Cedar
Park Community Center within a half a
mile of the state you've got Stow Upland
Village Hall which is probably no more
than a mile from the the estate as well
but there must be something on on the
site for um workers to relax you know
they can perhaps walk around or cycle
around the you know the areas and Etc
that type of thing thank you so we might
be able to add that as a condition and
leave the flexibility for that if and
when we get there thank you counc
mats yeah coming back to to um on this
on this £190,000 and so on there was
questions earlier and it didn't I didn't
really see quite who it was appropriate
to ask but I think it is you um can you
see any any
land um not within the red line um where
which one could usefully um take
ownership of um to to spend some of that
money on providing that which is no
longer on the
site um I think K mat whether the
officer might be able to sort of provide
a better answer on that
one um possibly not as a suggestion no I
mean the the money itself was the the
orange land which was envisaged for
recreational purposes I think
particularly football grounds and that
therefore the money that we are securing
would be towards them replacing that or
using that in some way and I think we
have suggested that that could be um
other facilities and I think we included
active travel in the recommendations
sorry hav got that to hand so that would
be the sort of thing we're envisaging it
um so it could be a mix of schemes and
that could be something that we would
take up in the future rather than
specifying something now without knowing
the specific requirements will
land can I just ask a followup question
on the points been raised about
Community benefit would it am I stepping
way out of the remit but would it be
possible to suggest a a a a a group of
local maybe the local parish council
with the local councils actually look at
what might be the best way of rolling
that forward if if the committee gets to
approving this or is that just going a
step too far
um because I'm just thinking we're
hearing from the parish wanting to
engage we're not in debate now I'm just
asking material fact so chairman you've
got a recommendation in your late papers
which refers to a commuted sum for
recreational facility stroke Act of
travel what you're describing is a
community stroke Recreational facility
conversation um what we might do uh in
other situations is
to uh recommend that uh that include
terms to uh be a portioned in
consultation with um town and Parish
councils so uh we'd build into the
section 106 a mechanism for consultation
over where that money was uh prioritized
but obviously the district council would
ultimately have to choose but with the
advice of town and Parish councils
around it presum would include St Market
that's very helpful thank you councelor
Manel and then we'll go to councelor
Norris uh thank you um councelor Müller
mentioned um the need for a nursery in
the area and yet um from the discussion
that's ensued uh since then um it sounds
as if this this money is actually only
able to be used for sporting or active
travel things and not a nursery can we
have that clarified I think councilor M
said there's a nursery quarter of a mile
away or half a mile away already yes
that we we've we've had one at Ceda part
which is finished but we're hoping to
recruit a new Nursery in the near future
but were you anticipating any funds to
help support that Nursery um probably
not because most of these nurseries are
private
businesses interpreted what he said I
thought you said there was a need for
an okay so councelor Norris welcome and
over to you as the the final Ward
member thank you
chair uh thank you for the opportunity
to comment on this application I don't
wish to repeat much of what councelor M
and uh Council cart I have already said
so I'll confine my comments to those as
a ward member for the adjoining Parish
of creting St Peter in support of the
comments made by their Parish
Representatives whilst I appreciate that
the application site offers certain
employment opportunities I have a number
of reservations on this application in
its present
form traffic potential traffic issues on
the alternative access to the site from
the a120 Via pain Pound Road and M line
in the instance of access on and off the
site at the Tesco roundabout being
congested at peak
times Pound Road and Mill Lane are
narrow and winding and increased heavy
traffic may well back up through
creating St Peter a better alternative
access would be preferable in the form
of a new Access Road the i120 is an
official diversion route in the event of
accidents or long-term maintenance work
on the
A14 as there is a weight limit on the B
tr13 and also the established protocol
is that diversion route should not be of
a lesser class of road than the rout
being diverted from this might well
increase the possibility of congestion
and I believe the fact that the a120 is
an official diversion route has been
overlooked planning policies
t04 planning obligations and highways
infrastructure and T10 highways
considerations in development are
relevant landscape
screening inadequate Landscaping
screening of the site leading to loss of
amuni such as noise from construction
works and light
pollution suffk preservation Society
SPS in their an ultimate paragraph on
page 35 comment that it is disappointing
to note from the design and access
statement that a landscape strip around
the site of only up to 20 M width is
proposed we consider that this is
inadequate to soften the impact of large
industrial scale buildings and urge that
a minimum of 40 m is provided in
accordance with the development brief
for the site
they then go on to say SPS would also
urge that the lighting of the site is
carefully conditioned in order that
illumination is limited to that required
within the development and light
pollution of the night sky when viewed
from a distance is
minimal there is a lack of information
on the height to which boundary planting
will grow the
2014 adopted development brief stated
maximum buildings EES Heights of 6.5 m
in the upper part of the site and 15 m
in the lower part whereas this
application mentions indicative Eaves
Heights of 9 M and 18 M
respectively policies 816 protecting
existing residential immunity and E10
new Industrial and Commercial
development in the countryside are
applicable biodiversity and Wildlife
there appears to be limited provision
for this in their consultation response
on page 34 suff Wildlife trust recommend
that a biodiversity enhancement strategy
should be produced detailing how the
enhancements made within the ecological
assessment are to be incorporated within
the development including their
locations this is not included as such
in the recommending planning conditions
listed on pages 72 to
74 policy
cl08 protecting wildlife habitats and
lp8 biodiversity and geodiversity
apply and finally design code a clear
and fully detailed design code is not
evident in the papers and this is normal
practice to ensure that there is
consistency of building appearance
across the site thus enabling it to
blend into its setting policies sb2
development appropriate to its setting
and gp01 design and layer of development
are
applicable uh that concludes my comments
I would just mention however I've
received more emails on this application
from concerned residents than on any
other application in recent times thank
you thank you very much any questions
for the ward member
no okay yes C pass um Mike
so we talked about the boundary have you
got any sort of minimum height of the um
tree line that you would like to put as
a as a condition to start with if it
were to go ahead for the enhanced
screening and so on for the site
sorry we we've talked a lot about
mitigating the um um the tree lines and
the the landscaping and so on and I
mention right at the beginning we need
an enhanced scheme had you got anything
particular you would like to add to that
concept no that's fine thank you I think
I yeah
thanks okay members we've had all the
information put before us um we've um
had a lot of information put before us
and and can I just thank all the people
that have participated and joined us
today clearly this is a hugely
significant application uh and I think
we've covered uh the ground very well
well so thank you for all those that
have fed in and thank you particularly
to the officers from other authorities
and from other organizations who have
shown up to help us do that today so
we've now got to reach a conclusion it's
not going to be easy but we've got to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
um and it's going to be up to you I I
mean to me I'm not seeing any hands
shoot up so to me there are four key
points I'm I'm not going to say how I
which way I'm going to go but for me um
without saying hand shooting up I've got
issues around the screening and the
Earth Bond and where that sits um and
whether there's enough there for me the
community benefit issue uh which I was
I'm quite having heard what Philip said
to me that gives me a sort of light at
the end of the tunnel the traffic and
the traffic management plan and how much
that management plan will deal with the
traffic issues going forward I guess I
think to me they're the the Crux of of
of the application before us that I'm
most trying to resolve in my mind um
but I'm not going to push further than
that at this stage so I've got councelor
eburn then councelor Passmore then
councelor
Mansel um thank you very much chair and
I think I'd like to Echo your thoughts I
think um an application like this needs
the time um that you've um given it and
the contribution of everybody that's um
come here today um when this site
originally came forward as a purchase
for mids suffit District Council I voted
in favor of that of of the council
purchasing the site because I felt that
it was um important to develop high
quality employment on an Exemplar site
that we could influence the that site to
become an
Exemplar
um I'm concerned that um and I think
that that here we've got um sort of one
one chance to get it right and to really
scrutinize um this application not only
for the general public but because of
the role that mids District Council is
is is playing a with a multitude of hats
in with regards to this
application withs to an Exemplar site
I've got some concerns um and some
things I think should be or could be
included in um conditions so for example
um one of the conditions refers to bream
um standards um very good in CL cases
but excellent in one point well why can
we not have excellent for the whole site
um that would lift the standard and um
move it towards that
um the end of the spectrum that's more
um excellent and better quality I think
the um the issues for the neighboring
communities particularly of Cedar Park
and creating some Peter haven't been
fully addressed um and I think for on
for both those two communities I think
the key points there are in relation to
um landscaping and whether you can see
the site you know how we can um Shield
the site from them um specifically I
think the Landscaping Provisions um
along those two sides of the site are
poor and um to go from a development
brief of saying 40 M Landscaping to one
way we're talking 8 MERS in the corner
where it's um at Cedar Park and the
north um West um corner is is is not
good enough um so we really need to see
much stronger Landscaping um around
those points um I think it following on
from that point I think it's a shame
that we haven't had better justification
for how the difference from the original
development briefs was and um
consultation with the public um in terms
of why we're making those changes and um
whether they can be their concerns can
be
mitigated um there's considerations
about the heights which have changed and
it's very difficult to
um you know understand those Heights
particularly with the level changes um
and I think there is an issue about the
the volume size because obviously once
you get higher and bigger you it's not
just the square meterage on the ground
it's actually the volume of that that
building um that we should be looking at
the um plan for recreational funding I I
agree that um any plan for the commuted
sum should be done in consultation with
the parish council and Town Council and
the um travel plan must take clear um
notice of residents in Cedar Park
including St Peter and you know I think
we need written insurances within the
conditions um that that um should be the
case so at the moment I will listen to
my fellow colleagues on their views um
before I come to a decision but
specifically in conditions I I would you
know if other members were minded to
approve I would want to see greater
Landscaping particularly in relation to
creating St Peter and ceders park the
bream Excellence across the whole site
the travel plan to take notice of
residents in creating St Peter and Cedar
Park and the commuted sum for um
Recreation to be um agreed with the
Paris councils and the town councils
thank you very much CH thank you
councelor pmore you were next thank you
Matthew well I think it's been a very
very interesting um discussion and we've
have a debate now and I would Echo your
comments about everybody's contribution
because we do need to make sure we get
this absolutely right it's a very
sensitive location but I think it's a
very important location and I would like
to make a few comments um if we look at
where we are UK PLC suffk PLC mids
PLC um we do need to get the economy
motoring and it's really really
important we have good well-paid jobs as
I said earlier we don't want a load of
um low paid um minimum wage jobs at all
and I think if we get this right this
site does provide the opportunity to
bring that inward investment that is so
desperately needed um here and and
elsewhere in the country and as being
part of the Free Port I think it has
stands to benefit not just um suffer but
east angler and probably UK overall with
the connections to Felix do and and IP
and so on but that does not mean that
planning should permission should just
be given willy-nilly and that clearly is
not what we're about here today in any
case and the other thing that I'm
particularly concerned about is the
prospects for our young people I know
I've mentioned that many times and
planning
has I almost a moral obligation to do
what it can to help and when I'm talking
about that I'm not just saying
development per se it's about quality of
life the environment and everything else
that goes into it to preserve we've got
that's really good and fantastic about
mid suffk but also provide opportunity
for people to progress their own careers
and become independent and as we heard
earlier to get that tax base up in order
to pay for public services because the
money doesn't grow on a tree it has to
be
earned and so chairman I think on
balance and this is a difficult one I'm
actually going to propose that we do
move to um Grant planning permission for
this site but with several conditions
and I'm very happy for other members if
they wish to add to this um to put them
in I mentioned earlier about the
Landscaping scheme without going into
details it really does need to be top of
the um top of the pile here Rolls-Royce
adequate Landscaping with local Province
Etc I've mentioned it all before really
to make sure this site is a site that we
can all be proud of and it looks the
part as well that in itself will help
people who live and work in the area uh
and so on to be a place that we're proud
of
clearly there are big issues about
traffic management and so on there has
to be a way when we come on to that um
um if it's given permission to nullify
the negative effects that could be had
it's very difficult to enforce these
things because you can't tell people
where they're going to live and exactly
how they travel to work but Common Sense
needs Prevail I am disappointed um but
relieved with your suggestion chairman
of making sure when it comes to
community facilities there is a proper
sensible dialogue with local people why
the hell should they put up with
inconvenience disturbance and so on when
they put up with it I remember we had
this at Blake with the waste incinerator
site we have to do things to help local
people because we want them um to be
able to support the development and
we've already heard from I think lots of
people people are not against this
development per se so it's up to us as a
committee to mitigate those issues to
make sure that it is more acceptable and
I think the agents uh and so on need to
recognize that and the conversations
that we um could condition
I think will help with that very very
important to do that I also mentioned
about security of the site overall I
gather that will be a reserve matter and
also potential pollution of water causes
um acfas and so on air quality all of
these things again any of us um looking
at this with any degree of Common Sense
would wish that to be looked at the
sustainability argument I think is very
important we're all concerned about
better use of scarce natural resources
low carbon Footprints and so on we talk
about restoring I mean we could have a
huge debate about that not appropriate
for today but I do think again that is
something that needs to be put into what
is a really high quality um development
if we have a high quality development
like this then we can track that inward
investment that we all need and I'm
particularly concerned that it helps our
our young people as well to give them
the hope the aspiration the drive and
actually the ambition for them their
families and children in times
generations to come so I think this is a
bit of a a groundbreaking development
potentially but with those following
conditions chairman that's why um I'm
forly proposing we accept it but with
those conditions and happy to add other
things there as necessary thank
you
councelor oh I've got councelor field
and councelor Manel on the same line and
then councel humre
so okay
sorry uh thank you and thank you Council
Phil for let letting me go next before I
forget what I'm going to say say um I'd
like to um I I I I've got to agree with
everything that councilor eburn had said
um and this proposal I think the Crux of
the matter is I mean we all we all uh
none of us are against well I don't
think any of us against this site being
used for employment uses but but what
we've got to be sure is is does the
economic benefit um of having this site
um for employment does that outweigh all
of the um harm that is caused to the
environment and to the community uh in
the area uh and the the plan we've got
for before us today is very different
from the development brief um back
whenever it was we have we have a more
it appears to Me Maybe I I'm seeing it
superficially but we seem to have got
more space being used for buildings less
for landscape buffering we have um an
extremely large building I think it's
plot 4,000 or whatever it's called which
I think someone said it was going to be
21 M High and the development brief had
things about 12 M high now let's not
forget that that scaling um distances we
have to cube those distances when we
look at volume and mass that is going to
be an enormous great building and yet
we've got less landscape buffering so to
me it it really doesn't quite make sense
um I I you know I completely um
sympathize with um the residents of
creting St Peter and Cedar Park in that
you know it does appear that we're
putting profit before community and as
councelor eburn has said this is our
development and it really should be an
Exemplar development um so uh you know
at the moment I I'm not I'm not
convinced by by the um proposal that um
puts more conditions on because I'm not
sure we can um change the area that is
being used for putting buildings on um
with a condition so if we're saying we
need a lot more buffering on that
Northern um Edge uh near creting St
Peter and uh Cedar Park I'm not
convinced that that can be done by
condition um uh so and and you know
we've talked about um the ecological
benefits and all the rest of it um and
there's one sort of outstanding thing
that I'm I'm not quite sure what we can
do about and that is the traffic issues
now we're told that there could be up to
3,000 jobs created here um but again the
development brief um put more emphasis
on manufacturing and Innovation and it
appears what we've now got is more
warehousing and have we actually got any
guarantee that we are going to get these
Innovation and manufacturing jobs or is
it only going to be warehousing I'm not
I realize we can't actually determine
that now but but have we got any
guarantee that we're going to get that
number of jobs and yes it's fantastic
we're going to get all of those jobs but
how are all those people going to get
there uh in a sustainable manner um
we've heard about the traffic issues um
uh and there are a lot of local concerns
about the amount of traffic on the
roundabout by um the new McDonald's area
uh as that is going to be the main way
in and out of this site um and I'm I'm
yet to be convinced that we can mitigate
against those issues so I'm going to
listen to what others have got to say um
but uh I'm not sure this is good enough
um for an Exemplar development from mids
suffk thank you very much uh councelor
field thank
you we seem to be largely in
agreement and I think it's very clear we
all agree we need high quality jobs
1,500 to 4,000 perhaps uh is a very
valuable contribution but not at any
cost we've I'm concerned however that
we've had two
applications so far agreed on this site
that have not
progressed we do seem to need some sort
of change if we look at say the area of
spon or or great Blake in my Lord um
development sites there have progressed
are progressing rapidly
um at the same time as this one's been
stalled so I think we do need some
alterations
however the traffic management needs
don't seem to me to have been fully
addressed in any way there are
considerable questions there a great
deal of concern from local people um and
you know highways always say whatever's
proposed is okay uh we do need some
action to make sure that the villages
like quing some Peter don't suffer the
residents of Cedar Park don't suffer
actions that we can believe will will be
driven
through same sort of comments to me
apply to the
Landscaping has been said several times
it used to be 40 m deep it's now got to
be 20 M maximum 8 meters in or less in
some number of areas it just doesn't
seem that that's sufficiently thought
through sufficiently well defined as to
do what we want which is as it's been
said impossible to hide a development
this size completely but we need to
mitigate its impacts quite significantly
and I think we haven't done enough as
yet um there was other comments
concerning the construction uh I think
our control of construction is always
ineffective one always has uh large
numbers of workers who have really no
option but to park in local residential
streets and that can't be allowed to
occur for a development as large as this
orbe it that it'll be spread over some
years um Community facilities and uh and
and areas for workers to you relax
during breaks and things also seems
necessary the we do lack a considerable
number that were in the original
development
brief so I think
overall my feeling is you know we're
heading the right direction this is a
necessary development largely but
clearly we need to do more work on it
I'm not totally convinced I certainly
not at the moment convinced that the
right approach is to agree the uh the
planning application and then hope that
people will do work in line with the our
requirements uh I really hate kicking a
can down the road but my feeling still
is is um well we'll see where we go with
the proposal but that um perhaps it
needs uh referring back for some more
work on the things that really concern
us see if we can get a development that
is exemp plan which we could all support
thank you thank you councilor
humph thank you Mr chair um because of
all the information that's come in from
everyone and thank you for contribution
you calls me loads of work I've been
jotting down loads of things so I'll try
to put it in some sort of order so you
can follow along but I might be
battening to it because there's so much
information and thank you for that it's
helped us immensely um first thing we've
got to realize is this area has been
allocated for development for an
industrial park of some sort um and
that's way back way back with the Stow
Market action plan or area action plan
so that's already been done uh we've all
agreed that that's what's going to
happen and we've done that on two
previous meetings in this chamber so
it's just now agreeing whether we're
going to go forward with the plan in
front of us now the key bit to me is and
I hear from the Ward uh counselors that
um residents are worried about parking
they're worried about um the lack of
immunity or the loss of immunity they're
concerned about the landscape and I get
all of that I understand the emotion
completely absolutely uh but I also
understand the enthusiasm and the opport
opportunity this brings the enthusiasm
of the developers to produce what I hope
is going to be a worldclass site that
will attract industry of all types
including warehouses and I'll go on to
that at the moment and as the W member
said that's going to bring between
potentially 75 to 250 million pounds
over time to our community well if
that's not serving the community what is
so it's a good thing that we do it as
far as I'm concerned but I do understand
some of the issues with it which I'll
come to in a moment um people have gone
on about warehousing is well this is the
modern world it's 2021 when this was
first looked at in 20 2003 and the
warehouse was whatever size it was floor
space we've now increased to 37% that's
because the population's increased and
we're consumer lead so therefore there
is a demand for more warehouses and it's
a profitable business now we talk about
warehouse wages and everyone thinks
they're low that's not actually true
Amazon for instance they pay between 12
and TW sorry 15 and 20 an hour the na
average in the UK at is1 12258 so that's
a good wage for a 40-hour week so we
need to be careful when we talk about
low wages because it's not strictly true
and it might be true in some cases but
not true in all and therefore on balance
we just got to believe what we see on
statistics um we talk about jobs um and
you asked actually why we would need
that increase in jobs as I explained
earlier in 20 years Stow markets
population has increased by
43% we need work and that's just Stow
market now we're all men of the world
and Ladies of the world and we
understand is development all over mids
at the moment so what's the increase in
mids I've not looked at that statistic
but it's quite High isn't it and we all
need jobs and I'd rather people came to
Stow Market or stayed within our
district and found those jobs rather
than go down on the train all the road
to London up to Norwich or wherever else
they might go to so we can keep it local
that's got to be the right thing when I
was a child obviously not that long ago
uh the local industries that are in my
town consist of foundaries metal
workking uh they also consisted of
vehicle making real heavy industry stuff
but as I said before the world's changed
that's gone to other countries and now
we're in more of a consu a consumer
based society and also high-tech which
is where the work is so now we come back
to the Freeport the Freeport is
fantastic news for us as a district with
Stone market gateway 14 that is
fantastic for our communities direct
communities it will bring jobs it will
bring investment and being a free Port
of all the incentives that brings it
brings a varied and you know massive
amount of different types of Industry
from warehouses and we do need them down
to high-tech computer companies they
come to free ports because it's
beneficial to not do this right now in
my mind is not serving the community we
need to do it we need to do it now we've
got the Free Port now's the right time
the economy has suffered terribly over
the last couple of years now is the time
for that investment now is that time to
create those jobs and get that money
back into our economy locally and
nationally again we'll be remiss if we
do not support this
application um when I go down to the
landscaping and the major concerns which
I think is Landscaping transport I agree
and I think that actually we do need to
think about that Landscaping now whether
that's mature tree growth or whether it
be bunts I don't really mind as long as
it tries to mitigate that view
especially from um from The Villages
close by and also from um from Cedar
Park but I'll talk about Cedar Park View
actually from Cedar Park when you look
out the 12 houses that actually look out
onto that site of the moment um there's
trees this side of the road and trees
the other side of the road so there's
already some mitigation in place we just
need to enhance that perhaps and maybe
think of different ways Reserve m
matters will discuss the nature of these
buildings so it's not for us to discuss
right now as far as I'm concerned and if
it is please correct me good so when it
comes to reserve matters some of these
buildings to reduce you going to come
in Mr Isbell I think sport my flow so
when these buildings come to reserve
matters there's other mitigation we can
bring in and we've seen it we've seen it
up at clayon with the camouflaging
schemes by use of different paints and
camouflaging schemes you can actually
merge these buildings into the
background and of course when you stood
next to it it's still a building painted
different colors but when you're three
miles away it Blends in and that's
important so in reserve matters we can
discuss that but I honestly can't see
any planning reason why we turn this
down none and I can see all the benefits
to our local community and residents
when it comes to employment and
investment and long-term growth and
they're really really important and
you're naive if you think think they're
not so therefore I believe that we
should support this application however
I would like to see some conditions a
condition you spoke about which is
Landscaping especially on the northeast
side I believe it was and I'll come back
to you because you're the proposer and
also uh on the traffic management plan
um it is what it is I don't see and I
know the area well because I'm from Stow
Market um I don't see what you could do
that would change things there will be
still stupid people there will still be
stupid truck drivers who decide in a
roads Block they'll drive through the S
Park estate they're there now and
they'll be there in the future I don't
see any increase massive increase in
traffic through the estate because if I
was a truck driver bear in mind miles of
pounds I wouldn't be going through the
estate I'd go on the A14 which is the
main arterial route between across our
County and I'd go and do my job I
wouldn't be going into seed this part I
just don't understand that logic or that
argument doesn't make sense to me um
when it comes to transport of people
coming into work obviously some of those
people choose to come buy a car and it's
their choice some people will use the
excellent rail network that we've got
through SE it stops at Stone Market and
then walk them 1.3 miles is it yeah 1.3
miles from the train station guess what
great for them great for the economy
great for the rail system so there's no
excuse and the buses I'll get your point
the buses have reduced but that doesn't
say buses don't go to Stow Market buses
do there's a a route from Stow Market to
ipswitch and back every 30 minutes you
just walk from the center of the town to
your workplace I used to cycle 10 miles
to work when I was a kid it's great it
gets us fit so I think all of these are
nebby little things but they're not a
reason to refuse this
application so therefore I will be
supporting the proposal and I do second
The Proposal but I do want to talk about
conditions thank you can I just ask uh
bring Philip isbo in on the conditions
front bearing in mind that the way you
said that it was going to be very
difficult to look at the Landscaping
because of the way it's drawn up if we
were to do an advisory note on
landscaping for further work to be done
between uh officers the team uh bearing
in mind what you've heard and the the
unsatisfaction that maybe there isn't
enough to protect particularly creting
St Peter and then an advisory note
around the traffic management plan for
again Cedars and the shortcut roots that
are being discussed and parking around
the site during
construction is that a doable way of
ticking off those boxes can you
comment thank you chairman so wasn't
quite where we're going to start so if I
might come back to that at the end um as
ever The Proposal of the motion has
given me an interesting problem to chew
over in relation to Landscaping as I
think I said earlier you have a hybrid
application part which is full the area
of that is specified and set what I
understand is currently in debate is
whether that is adequate um and to
change that um either involves amending
the application in some way shape or
form which will delay it and I don't
recommend or to consider including a
requirement for reserved matters to
provide additional Landscaping in the
area adjacent to the northern boundary
however and here's the point Landscaping
is a reserve matter so we have some
details they are the details in the full
element of this if you want some other
prescriptive element to go into your
decision you either amend this
application which means it will have to
be taken away or uh you uh seek to
require Landscaping to be within
specified parameters in a part of the
site that you're concerned with and that
then becomes a reserved matter in of a
particular standard because Landscaping
is a reserved matter so you will see
that as those elements of the uh the
development come forward that are of
concern now we already have a long part
and I don't know G if we could get the
drawing of the northern boundary back up
in some way shape or form we already
have a boundary which I believe from
calculation we reckon to be of the order
of about 15 m in depth then tapering
down and as a planner I'll turn to
committee and say where's the harm so we
have to be able to identify what the
harm is we're trying to mitigate
so uh I'll wait whilst uh Jemma gets
something up which I
recognize so I think yes so that's
alongs the A4 that's alongside the A14
indeed and that I believe we've
calculated is Circa 15 MERS
wide uh and obviously it's not the 40
MERS that was anticipated in the
development brief but we also know the
development brief never came forward
into reality as uh as counselors have
said so we have that which is partially
along the A14 boundary and then the A14
slip drops down and then you have the
Northwestern corner now visibility here
is exposed I suggest to view from
residents in Cedar Park opposite users
of the overbridge and passing motorists
on the A14 who probably should also be
paying equal Focus to the road I suspect
at the same time
so as with most questions in planning
committee I take you back to the
question of what's the unacceptable harm
and where does it arise for us to try to
mitigate if we can go back to the
previous plan and the one before that
which is the North Eastern corner so we
we have an area there which um is is
obviously I believe closest to creating
s Peter and we've got that continuation
at the top of that slide of the 15 M
deep boundary uh planting which is as
provided for um do we have the uh the
the the layout plan as the indicative
layout and and sorry for skipping around
um chairman but
um in terms of the indicative plan for
that Northwestern
sector um not quite that
one probably
don't okay so no no let's let's not
trouble so in the Northwestern sector
you already have uh an indicative layout
with buildings on it and you know from
what's been proposed that there is a
provision of 20% soft Landscaping with
20% soft engineering and engineered
drainage within that and that follows
the design code principles that's
recommended today as a condition if you
seek to include a bigger area of
landscaping adjacent to the A14 boundary
and getting back to the point about
which which areas are you most concerned
with you know we already have a 20% um
provision with within that
Landscaping which you know is locked
into any reserve matters through this
what you might see is that that 20% is
uh inevitably driven to be against the
A14 boundary um as proposed um and uh
arguably that might then lead to some
unforeseen consequences for the rest of
the way those Reserve matters come
forward uh I mean take you back to the
commerciality of this we know this has
been an allocation in the plan we know
has been the subject of a development
pre but it hasn't come forward and and
so there must be some Commercial Point
to the original proposal which doesn't
make it commercially sound um so I I I
urge some caution in considering where
you go with the Landscaping you need to
identify which areas you are trying to
safeguard or en
enhance and I probably start by saying
you have to be able to identify harm if
you to start imposing further conditions
as officers having had this assessed and
consulted upon it with those who are
expert in such matters we don't believe
this area is inadequate and that's why
we make the recommendation to you today
as we do it is possible for you to add a
requirement for further Reserve matters
to improve and enhance the Landscaping
built along uh that Northern and
Northwestern sector of the site um it
may have unforeseen consequences but I
would suggest that if you specify that
as an additional requirement for your
landscaped reserved
matters um it is open to you to do it
but it would be um it will have
consequences as to the way that your
network of um biodiversity across the
site may end up being delivered which
when uh Sue Hoon was here earlier I mean
certainly that's an important point for
her um I'm not sure I've necessarily
answered all your questions chairman um
how am I
doing no that's useful I think and uh
puts things you know makes us reflect on
on on that quite well so thank you can I
can I add some further points about
Landscaping just whilst I I I have the
um the microphone um it is possible to
uh add to the uh landscape and
environment management plan and
Landscape uh Reserve matters to require
them to demonstrate the use of uh Native
species um uh within the reserve matters
that come before you so that when a
submission is made that that Reserve
matter for landscaping includes that
detail so that you can see it and it is
in front of you and we can add that as a
as a condition um and in terms of
managing these areas uh it it's uh
certainly a requirement within the
section 106 to include management um as
a long-term issue we heard from uh Sue
that the requirement should be out to of
the order of 15 25 years clearly I think
you know there is some value of of of
dealing with that and I might come back
to that comment if this discussion goes
further traffic
management there are construction
management plans proposed they uh
effectively require access via the A14
a1120 that's condition o and I think
condition
nine um it will be perfectly possible to
add to those to uh require uh that they
demonstrate how construction traffic
will be managed away from Cedar Park and
from creating and pet so that Vehicles
do not except for errant drivers go
through that point and that's a
perfectly possible uh addition um I
think I'll leave it there
chairman I just ask a full question so
you you you've been very clear around
the Landscaping um uh and the
implications
thereof but um we have you know it has
been probably one of the the thorny
points of the debate so far would a
advisory note asking for further
discussions and evaluation look at the
landscaping that's being proposed so
that when it come with with something
coming back to reserved matters just to
give us that confidence that it really
has been looked over most thoroughly and
we're not missing anything or are you
just saying
it's what we have is what we have so so
if you add an informative note people
can always depart from them if you add a
condition they've got to comply with the
condition you already need the
Landscaping requirement it's already a
reserved matter so you will get to see
that
um the question of the purpose then
becomes the important thing to write
into that so you can require that your
Landscaping details shall be accompanied
by whatever it else you want so you can
do that and perhaps that's the thing to
focus
on okay thank you um y next up was
councilor mat thank you yeah if I could
perhaps first just comment a little on
on what Mr hisel has been saying and and
come back to a fundamental question
question that I didn't eventually ask of
the officers previously and that is
about the status of the parameter plans
there is a parameter plan um diagram
which um sets out the areas for um for
building essentially um that's there one
one of those and then there are there
are the various um Landscaping detail
plans which are also described as
parameter plans and if
if as as members have been saying we we
need and feel the need for more um
landscaping and that that we could write
conditions which would ask that that's
looked at
um it seems that we we would need more
land in order to achieve that and and if
we approve the parameter plan of the
whole site as as submitted um do we not
in fact not not leave the
ability to increase the landscaping area
um because the buildings are pretty
tight up against the red lines frankly
um and the other very general point I
wanted to ask you was um that we we've
got a full application and we've got a
an outline
application and I I wondered
whether given you know given the
acceptance so far of of the principle of
development which is established etc etc
um I wondered whether this there's
actually scope for approving the full
application for for the um for the
infrastructure essentially um but taking
away the um the parameter plans and all
the rest of it um for another look has
has been hint let's bring in
Philip uh to to answer those in reverse
order chairman uh you can't split your
decision Secretary of State can you do
not have the power to split a decision
on this so you have to deal with both
the hybrid the full and the the outline
elements at the same time okay thank you
councelor hadingham
can you just turn your please
sorry sorry thank you um I've been very
interested to hear all the debate and I
have to say um
taking all on board I have have more um
in common with um councelor humph and
Council parore I think this is a high
quality development and and I think
they've um an awful lot of work has gone
into this and you know I think the
mitigations they've done with the
ecology uh have been excellent I think
unfortunately they've rather over
promised on the landscape and underd
delivered which is um unfortunate to um
to to to come in with 40 m and in some
points to go down to 8 m and that is a
worry to me um with creting St Peter and
the view to Ceda Park but um but I do
hope that you know work can be done
there whether it's even the the type of
planting if they can't actually increase
the the the
meterage um but I think overall the econ
uh the the the econic I can't speak
economic um development does outweigh
the harm that it's doing there um and I
hope that um traffic management and
Landscaping can be you know looked at in
detail to to overcome the the locals
worries so um yeah I'm I'm going to go
vote for this thank
you right um I know Council Manel but
I'm letting people that haven't spoke go
first uh so we've now done the rounds
and we'll go around for the second time
so over to you um thank you chair I I
did actually want to speak about the
motion that's been proposed whilst we're
on the subject of conditions um uh I'm
looking at condition X and condition
NN um condition
NN um uh refers to the briam conditions
which were brought up by councelor eburn
when she spoke um at the beginning of
the debate uh and count uh condition NN
says we've got briam very good minimum
across the site and briam excellent
Innovation Center um is there any way we
can have a condition that it's excellent
um uh in in more places is than just in
one of the plots uh and on condition X
which I think is about the lighting it's
got lighting scheme in bracket Wildlife
friendly um can we have it a smart
lighting
scheme thank you thanks um can I come
back on those chair is that right yeah
and Philip was going to come back as
well so there's a go for it um it was on
the brand point I think the issue is the
on the larger units that that's an issue
with delivery of how they could do that
um might be we clarify with the agent if
you wanted to but that essentially it's
possible on the plot 3000 but but not or
a problem on the other plots uh hence
the proposal to split it
slightly s yeah uh councelor
field well that'll be up to councelor
pmore to decide as he's proposed and
seconded yeah councelor
field I was just going to remark that
I'm sure the incinerator met briam
excellent and it's a moderately big
building so I don't quite see the
argument could the applicant just
comment on briam the two briam statuses
whether it's we've got our
sustainability sustainability expert
here today so maybe I could pass over to
Leon who who should be able to answer
that if you if you can if you can turn
your mic on and just introduce yourself
that'd be great afternoon leam Madison
from BWB um Bri exent could be possible
um if conditioned but
uh very good is the current proposal for
the scheme going forward at the moment
uh in terms of sustainability assessment
can just exp why why
not um currently to comply with the
local conditions uh set in the core
strategy uh and the joint local plan
that was just the the the TAC we'
followed
there there's nothing stopping it being
Excellence but it's it's it was just a
choice through the
applicant currently yeah
okay okay um well there's no other
hands okay y of course thank
you right yes I I I didn't quite get the
answer that that I was looking for from
Mr isbel that the if we if we approve
this as as it is then the parameter plan
and the building outlines thereon become
become
fixed um fixed matters as I understand
it that is part of the matters that are
approved rather than the matters that
are reserved can we just clarify that
first so chairman just to um the
application yes one the if it's part of
the full element the landscape framework
plan and the detail plans i' I'd suggest
uh which also reference the parameter
plan the detail ones are the ones that
you will see as part of what is
delivered they are the full element so
the landscape parameter plan is for the
whole site as I recall it the uh the
detailed elements of that are the thing
that get that you have the detailer
perhaps just clarify on which plans are
which JMA yes so the the detailed
landscape parameters plan that we saw
with the different boundaries that is
the plans for the Strategic planting and
it leaves the internal elements of the
site white and essentially that's what
we would come back to as part of the
reserve matters
Landscaping yeah yeah I I get I get that
all right no that the the the point then
is the parameter plan that shows the
building the
buildings
it's there somewhere is it easy to put
it up in Spring and then I can it is
it's it was it's was it's page 265 and
it used to be Slide Five when the papers
were
made and no it's not there's another
one so this is the parameters yeah
that's yeah that's the one yeah so we
got the parameters plan up on screen
which includes the maximum aods and the
uses which I think were anticipating
being an approved plan if that's memb uh
decision whereas the building the plan
sorry with the blue buildings and that
shows buildings on it is indicative and
not for approval right so that's
indicative and that's right okay
understand thank you right well the I
think the the point you know lots of of
useful points have already been made and
um I I think I want to come back first
to the the St market area action plan
actually and um the reason that was that
was um created considerably was because
at that time there was a a proposal to
put effectively use this site to to
stack up a very large number of
containers which was already happening
at woolpit five high and and that was
the first the first principle if you
like was that well we're going to put
the the Big Lots of containers at the
bottom of the site and of course at that
time it hadn't been envis that we'd move
all the all the levels around um and and
and then it was beyond that it was to
achieve um for the council to achieve a
degree of control over the development
of the site and um and
that's that was really why we we
allocated it at that time was in order
to get control of it rather rather than
finish up with the with this huge pile
of containers now these these buildings
uh potent you know potential buildings
uh um are are definitely better than a
pile of containers which is good but
just to understand that that's where we
started from and I I support worked on
and supported the saap um because it it
was it was achieving those things and
then it was looking forward to how do we
develop Stow Market over the next 15
years and I have to say Council humph
that that the saap envisaged that the
population would be grow by that extent
because we allocated the three major
strategic housing sites at that time as
well so I think that the two the
employment land and the housing land
went together um way back when so that
that's um that's the problem which
brings me to the the intensification of
effectively of the site and we we've
established the the the square footage
meterage um is increased by
37% and we couldn't really pin down
quite how much extra volume upwards the
the buildings would be permitted to gain
but it seemed to me that the if you put
those two things together we're looking
at um something like it's between one
and a half and two times the the um the
amount of building Space volume um that
was inv Visage in the sap which is a lot
and inevitably that generates I'm just
going we just got a hold caution with
those figures because they're your
figures is that where you took it well
the 37% we've established we were told
from the agent they didn't have those
figures but that's your perception
that's fine no no no no no no the
37% additional square meterage of land
yes and there is there is an un unfit
and we can't quite get a handon amount
of extra height of buildings from their
floors to their roofs that we can't
quite get all but if you took those two
things together then it's it's it's in
that range of one and a half upwards and
it's difficult to get closer than that
but it's it's that much so that's that's
what I'm looking at now I I
obviously as a member
I I want to have pride in an exemplary
development Etc and feel that we're not
quite there yet and
as you as a member I I look at the
climate emergency and I say we need to
make the best possible use of this site
in renewable energy terms
and it's not clear how much of that we
could gain on a Renew on reserve matters
I don't quite no but it would be more
comforting to see more now of of
certainty on that point the Landscaping
I think it's inevitable that we
can we can gain more ecology which is
also an emergency of
biodiversity um we can gain more by
having wider Landscaping than than what
is on offer now um and that is of course
much less than what was was offered in
the seap which I so as I supported at
the time so that's a that's a big
problem to me we've did we can't do it
half and half and we've established that
the parameter plan is is is the land
that can be developed but it is it's but
the buildings are indicative that's
that's good so yeah overall it needs to
be better for me sorry okay
right so um I'm just going to give my
thoughts on it uh and then we'll see if
anyone else wants to go around again
before we go to a vote so um it's really
interesting for me um you know this is
3,000 jobs coming to mids suffk and we
we've heard Chris starky from the LEP
talk about the fact that we've got a
free Port that this is actually going to
bring high quality jobs uh there will be
some Logistics but it overall the Free
Port is a huge benefit to the area and
that will bring a a different type of
job going forward so I mean we've been
talking about we want greater than a
logistics Park we've got it so for me
that's a very a real positive
biodiversity we always talk about
greater biodiversity in mids suffk we
hear about it a lot we talk about it
endlessly congratulations to the
applicant they've actually gone out of
their way to Bringing greater
biodiversity which is we rarely get so I
would just like to pay credit on that
point because I think that is a
something we should note on the briam
status uh I would I would of course like
to see it Excellence but I think we also
need to be mindful that there is a cost
implication on buildings and this hasn't
been a viable site to date so I think we
should push for excellence but if we are
briam good you know that is an
achievement uh but of course briam
Excellence would be uh and the me and
you're here you can hear what we're
saying um and we would love to see that
particularly in mids suffk as we have a
household waste energy recycling center
next door that is briam Excellence uh on
the same A14 Corridor so it' be good if
we could have a tradition of only
building briam Excellence along that
stretch of road of course um in terms of
the community this is what troubles me
the most so we've had the parish council
and the uh resident very eloquently
describe the concerns they have um the
the stoar area action plan and the plan
we have today are totally separate that
was in a different time a different era
the projects didn't come forward we're
now at a position where we've got
something concrete that will be
delivered and can be delivered quickly
so it's about finding that compromise I
don't know how we do it I do think we
could do a bit more to try and support
the community I think we should be
trying to support the community more on
Landscaping I haven't quite got my mind
around how that works I would absolutely
ask that there is dialogue with the
community about bringing forward that
Community benefit so that the residents
have a say on where that money is spent
rather than it just disappearing into a
pot and going off somewhere and the
residents not feeling they could engage
in it clearly the applicant has said
that this has come forward three times
the pot of money is still there nothing
has changed but actually let's move it
forward instead of just not changing
let's actually commit it that the
residents will have a say on where some
of that money goes in dialogue with
ourselves and finally for me is the
travel management plan um there are lot
I think we have an opportunity here we
have Barbara in the room uh we've heard
the local members concerns if we could
really you know just pick up and note
those local concerns and absolutely make
sure that when we talk about rat runs we
talk about uh the concerns that the
residents have that we do really pick
that up and hold that really tight when
we come to looking at those uh that
traffic management plan so overall of
course it's not 100% perfect the two big
concerns I would ask somehow we look at
how we address them but overall I think
this is a big opportunity for mids suffk
and and an application that we should be
supporting so that's where I
sit so I'm happy to go to the the
proposer and the second as to how you
want to play conditions and I know
Philip's got his hand going up again
before we go to a
vote thank you chairman yes um I I just
wanted to pick up on um a point around
biodiversity bear in mind that got some
aing earlier uh during uh
conversation uh we obviously have uh a
Landscape Management plan it seems to me
appropriate to
include uh a measure within that to um
monitor the delivery of biodiversity net
gain as part of that uh heads section
106 so the longterm the long-term
management plan that you have as section
106 does actually look at and measures
biodiversity net gain now clearly that's
not been proposed by the propos of the
motion but I would suggest that's a
prudent thing to do
and in terms of the reserve matters that
you may see in order to give members the
comfort that these Reserve matters are
coming forward in a way that
intelligently looks at this question of
biodiversity uh it would be uh
reasonable and appropriate to include uh
a requirement that concurrent with the
submission of any reserve matters for
any plot uh that you seek a statement
which details the biod diversity net
gain position on that plot and
cumulatively so that you are able to
take a step by step analysis of the
reserve matter as they come
forward um I think for the time being
chairman I need to hear a bit more from
members around what their aspirations
are regarding Landscaping before I can
advise my only other point is um the
applicant is in the room um it it might
be appropriate to adjourn for five
minutes for for 10 minutes for myself
and uh Gema to discuss with them where
where we this discussion around the
Landscaping to the north might be
because at the moment I'm thinking we
might impose a condition that requires
land Landscaping in that area adjacent
to the a1120 and A14 to demonstrate what
additional measures uh have been taken
but clearly this may then link into the
20% uh requirement and I would like uh
ideally to have some clarity from the
applicant before advising you
further I think um what we would like to
see collectively um if you can find a
way to deliver that and condition it or
advisory notes a combination that to
provide that reassurance it's quite
difficult to sit here and come up with
the absolute precise definitions but I
would I would think Philip you've
certainly got a very strong uh push as
to what what what the concerns are and
if if you were able to talk to the
applicant uh in the interim and come up
with a workable solution that people are
content with okay so so this yeah I I
think I think I think we've got to get
this right and i' think we'd rather hear
from the applicant to know what's being
proposed to vote on it rather than just
saying let's come out so I'm I'm not
going to be popular for saying this uh
because I know and I feel very sorry for
the people who've been waiting for the
next application but uh the only place
you can get lunch here is cool beans and
they close at 2:00 so what I propose is
we take a 25 minute break to allow
Philip and the applicant to discuss but
we absolutely start again at 2:00
because if we don't break now there will
be no lunch uh and that gives the
opportunity for philli and and the
applicant to have a quick discussion so
can we start again at 2:00 and then
we'll run through from that point
straight
through
welcome back everyone and uh
uh so Philip would you like to give us
an update of your discussions on where
that leades for the benefit of us all
and for the proposer and seconded to
think how they want to take that
forward uh thank you chairman yes indeed
um uh constructive discussion and I
think it's fair to say that we have a
solution that we can recommend to
members uh and and obviously going back
to the uh point I made earlier you've
got to deal with the fact this is an
outline and a a full application at the
same time
so uh suggest that we uh include uh a
condition on the outline element of of
the uh planning permission here for the
reserve matters for landscaping adjacent
to the a120 and the A14 boundaries of
the site to demonstrate the supp
supplementary Landscaping measures which
are proposed to address landscape impact
in relation to views from creating St
Peter Cedar Park and the A14 to pick up
the point that Council passal was
interested in regard to species I'd also
propose that we include in this
condition the reserve matters shall more
moreover demonstrate the inclusion of
appropriate use of local planting
species within those Landscaping details
now chairman if I can just carry on uh
picking up on some of the other points
that have been uh in discussion we'd
recommend that the section 106 heads of
terms be amended as you'll be aware that
includes uh a long-term uh Landscape
Management plan uh and would suggest
that includes time AED measures for the
en enhancement monitoring and management
of landscaping features which deliver
biodiversity net gain including Woodland
habitants so that that Landscape
Management picks up the biodiversity net
gain as we see the development come
forward and uh ensure that it delivers
what we are hoping of it and in relation
to the reserve matters and relating to
that biodiversity point that concurrent
with the submission of any reserve
matters an assessment of the
biodiversity net gain on plot and
cumulatively should be submitted to to
uh the local planning Authority for
agreement and the deliv development
delivered in accordance with that now to
pick up the community Point uh I'd
suggest we amend the section 106 heads
of term as it presently sits uh such
that the commuted some for be B for
community community recreational
facilities and active travel which be
made available in consultation with
creeting St Peter Parish Council and St
Market Town Council so that it is our
decision but we have that consultation
process built in uh I probably haven't
covered all of the points that members
wish to get to but I understand that the
applicants are um are Keen to to make
those work as a solution and uh the you
know the reserve matters details I think
um they're they're already starting to
discuss how that can be uh made
practical um the other point I suppose
about construction management is also
that we have a construction management
condition uh o and n on the two elements
of the permission at the moment they do
not in include any reference to Cedar
Park um but we would suggest amending
the conditions relating to construction
management to ensure construction
traffic uh is uh kept away from um Cedar
Park and creting St Peter clearly the
management of that will need to be uh a
matter for practical use on the ground
uh and that will be down to a travel
plan coordinator in due course who will
be appointed as as part of this and they
will be a conjur point which uh should
allow for the management of that to
ensure that any problems can be raised
directly and immediately so that
construction traffic can be uh rooted
away from Cedar Park and creating some
Peter okay thank you very much for that
so I come back to SEC for the proposer
and the second what are your views now
that sounds a very practical solution
thank you chairman could I just check
one other point when it comes to
biodiversity without having a yet
another great big long shopping list but
that would include things like we've
made mentionable Hedgehog Swift boxes
that presum we don't need to mention
them specifically do they that all comes
in on a sensible biodiversity plan
without making it too bureaucratic or do
we need to mention that yes I mean
biodiversity net gain is a is a is a
growing area um and the applicants have
already demonstrated that they have
assessed it so this will simply require
them to consider that on plot as they go
through the development so we see this
come forward and biodiversity is not
limited to one or two species and indeed
arguably with climate change one might
see the species change over time so it's
right to be Fleet of foot with
that and Council H Mr chairman thank you
um yeah happy of all of that the only
point that wasn't answered was Point
x-ray which um Council Manel brought
reference the wildlife friendly lighting
versus smart lighting I don't know what
the difference
is so um I I believe smart lighting is
presumably intended to uh be controlled
in terms of time and energy efficiency
uh Wildlife friendly lighting is uh
probably designed to ensure that it does
not impact on species that would uh be
affected by it um and so that would
probably
involve uh the way that you direct the
light and the type of light source and
perhaps even the um uh the lighting
Arrangement such that it doesn't attract
species nor nor distract them when
they're commuting or
foraging therefore could we possibly on
that point x add Wildlife friendly smart
lighting thank you yes yes okay next up
was councelor manman councelor field uh
thank you thank you chair and thank you
Council humre for picking up on the
lighting yes uh wildli friendly and
smart lighting I don't believe should be
mutually exclusive so yeah let's have
them both in there um I was going to uh
query the the bit about the Landscaping
because I I think as well as the um sort
of Northern Edge against the A14 and the
edge against the
a1120 I think that the residents of
creting St Peter were also concerned
about the eastern boundary which goes at
the moment to Open Fields And I think we
heard from the representative of the
parish council that although the
majority of the village the the densest
part of the village is north of the A14
there are parts of creting St Peter
which are sort of due east of this site
um and you haven't mentioned anything
about the landscape buffer on that
edge uh quite so I haven't um I I would
suggest we need to identify where we are
looking to add uh landscape uh
mitigation and I start from position as
for the papers that we've already
assessed this scheme and consider it M
mitigates Landscape impact so um i' I'd
have to be guided by yourselves as to
where you felt that impact was absent or
was sufficiently harmful to Warrant
mitigating at the moment there is a
greater area of landscape planting in in
that Eastern uh uh sector than on the
Northern and the a120 sector um I I need
more clarity if uh you are looking to
secure Reserve matters in that area
which also uh uh seek to demonstrate
additionality um and at the moment
that's uh that's where I stand on that
okay let's keep let's go around the room
get all the points picked up then we'll
come back to the proposer in a second
and see how they want to play it so next
up is councelor
field thank you really simple one the
wildlife friendly lighting uh Place
Services throughout our papers have been
quoting various color temperatures for
that it's 4K in this paper it's 2,700 in
others could I suggest we just make that
3,000k which is generally available from
Street lighting manufacturers and has
beneficial effects that the blue content
doesn't attract insects and things you
don't want it to and it's probably zero
cost okay and then councel mat yeah I I
think the the magic words concurrent
with Reserve matters is um might need to
be slipped in into one or two places in
what Mr isbel read out probably we found
that to be very useful recently
uh chairman if I may come back on that
I'm not quite sure I did suggest that we
add a reserve matters condition that
requires concurrent with the submission
of Reserve matters that biodiversity net
came it question be addressed um the uh
question of lighting are members saying
that they want to see lighting
concurrent with the submission of
Reserve matters I'm not quite
sure no okay um so I'm going back to
council Passmore and councilor humre is
uh you've proposed it and second it
we've heard of the recommendations added
by philli that he would thinks could be
put in there so that we can move this
forward are you happy that we go to the
vote on that
basis yes and I think the other have
been covered as well so I'm happy counc
H yeah more than happy thank
you um chair can I just ask um Philip is
B to read out again the Landscaping one
because it was yeah I'm going to Long
lot of I was going to get him to just
run through just for clarity so we're
absolutely clear what we're voting on so
Philip it's been proposed by uh Tim and
seconded by Barry humph so could you
just remind us exactly the additions to
the recommendations that on
page chairman if I assist you with page
papers Pages uh two uh three four and
five yes so
so taking page three of of the tabled
papers you have you have an obligation
under under brackets one which is
long-term long-term Landscape Management
plan I suggest um that that be uh
amended to say long-term manage land
long-term Landscape Management plan
which shall include timetable measures
for the enforcement sorry the
enhancement monitoring and management of
landscaping features which deliver
biodiversity net gain including Woodland
habitats so that that's a change to that
head of term then in relation to the
next bullet the £190,000 that that be a
commuted sum for Community recreational
fa facility stroke active travel and
that shall be made available in
consultation with creting St Peter
Parish Council and Stone Market Town
Council and then turning to the
conditions on page four that condition o
construction management plan be amended
to construction management and to be
agreed including access via A14 stroke
a1120 and to ensure construction traffic
is directed and managed away from Cedar
Park and creting St Peter and to
replicate that same wording on condition
nine of the full element of the uh uh
decision uh and then generally to uh
require the uh in relation to the
reserve matters that concurrent with the
submission of any reserve matters an
assessment as to the biodiversity net
gain on plot and cumulatively should be
submitted for agreement and development
delivered in accordance with the agreed
assessment and I think I might have
missed this I've been going too fast
that the reserve matters for landscaping
adjacent to the a120 and the A14
boundaries of the site so I'll
demonstrate the supplementary
Landscaping measures which are proposed
to address the landscape impact in
relation to views from creating St Peter
cedus Park and the 014 reserved matters
shall moreover demonstrate the inclusion
of appropriate local planting species
within those Landscaping details that's
what I have at the moment
CH lighting condition we were going to
add
smart say we're now going to go to the
vote uh and I hand over to you for the
electronic vote thank you chair members
of the vote has been amended to read the
application number DC
21407 be approved as detailed in the off
recommendation contained in the table
papers and with the additional
conditions and amendments as read out by
the chief planning officer may need to
relog into your modov app if you have
brilliant thank you M's been on top of
that M's done it so that vote is now in
progress
everyone voted just waiting for one
vter thank you chair that's six votes
for and two G that's
carried
okay everyone welcome back uh thanks so
we could just move everyone around and
clean the seats between application so
the next application before us is dc21
01735 Wakeland Farm metfield Lane in
fressingfield uh and we'll now hand over
to the case officer to take us through
the
application yes sorry excuse me as coun
um humph is not coming back no council
humph has left for the rest of the day
thank you sorry I should have said that
yeah thank you chair and good afternoon
members I presenting a full planning
application today for the sighting of
six mobile homes for Rural workers on
the site 12 glamping pods for tourism
use and retention of conversion Works to
create a baking facility the site is
Wakeland Farm metfield Lane
fressingfield and as shown by the red
area on the map here is within the
fressingfield ward which is the
northernmost area of the district within
the ward is located centrally to the
east members are reminded that this
application is in support of the
committee report and does not seek to
replace or go over all of the ground
covered within that
report so here we have an aerial map
showing the site in the context of mids
um the two nearest settlements are
metfield which is circled to the
Northeast and is located 2.6 mil away
and fresen field which is to the
Southwest located 2.4 mil
away here we have the site in context um
so we have the a closeup of the site
which is located off of metfield Lane um
as you can see there are rows of trees
with agricultural lands sort of in
between them this forms the basis of the
pioneering Agro forestry operations on
site Agro forestry was set up um on site
dur in the 1990s as a research and
agricultural experiment the site has
however since needed to start
diversifying to ensure it is sustainable
and commercially viable going forward as
it was an experiment the crop yields
produced on site are not large enough to
be sold commercially on a sustainable
basis and th and thus diversification is
needed the current operations on site
are focused around sustainability
self-sufficiency Research into Agro
forestry and educating people through
informative and active events on site
which explain and demonstrate agary
forestry and Associated
operations there is also biomass boiler
ground Source Heating and solar panels
on site and a range of crops and
resources uh are being which are being
processed into food and Rural crafts
it's also notable that work has been
done to support ecological and
biodiversity net gains working closely
with suffk Wildlife trust and the
rspb so in terms of Parish location um
the site straddles between the two
parishes of fressingfield and metfield
with the dividing line shown in blue
there the site itself extends 8.61
hectares but the site as a whole extends
hectares so in terms of constraints
there is a grade two listed farmhouse on
site to the South with several public
rights away running north east south and
west of the site um sh in green there
harm has been identified to the setting
of the listed building at a level deemed
to be above a low level of less than
substantial harm this is however
considered to be outweighed by the
public benefits arising from support for
the economic and environmental
sustainability of the site and its
impact on the wider surroundings and
many of the identified impacts are
considered to be appropriately mitigated
by
conditions so here we have a selection
of site photos um photo number one shows
the glampin
pods uh amongst uh between two of the
tree lines on um land that is not
currently being farmed um photo four
conversely shows the land when it is
being farmed and photos one and four
therefore therefore show the different
stages in AGR forestry
rotation uh the Glam pin pods would only
be cited on land that is not being
farmed on at the time as shown in photo
one photos two and three show parts of
the Meadowland where the mobile homes
are proposed to be
cited as you can see the overall site is
extensively landscaped and enclosed from
The Wider fields and surroundings
including from Vantage points along
public rights of
way so in terms of Highway um boundaries
and impacts um as verified by suff
County Council highways there are two
distinct areas along metfield Lane all
of it is Highway land however this
section as shown uh in red here is
unmaintained Highway land that only
leads to and serves
wakands uh further along metfield Lane
uh which is again shown by the red line
on the plan um the yellow arrows Point
towards site in relation to the highway
on the two photos
there uh the remainder of metfield Lane
is maintained Highway land which serves
the other properties along the lane it's
noted that events and temporary uses of
land are considered to be permitted
development or alternatively not not
development at all therefore the number
of existing vehicles on site whether
they be agricultural vehicles or
visitors to the site alongside any
potential increase are not necessarily
controlled by planning and may happen
regardless of of the outcome of this
application surf County Council highways
have however confirmed they have no
objection to the use of the lane and
that it has capacity for any potential
increase in traffic however they note
that any significant vehicle movements
are likely to be in the short term and
the impacts uh are sort of appropriately
mitigated within that um the idea of
providing both long-term and short-term
accommodation on site through both the
glampin pods and mobile homes um would
be to provide accommodation for people
who currently go in and out of the site
on a regular if not daily basis and
would therefore ultimately reduce the
number of vehicular
movements so here we have the um
existing site plan which shows the
existing buildings on site with the two
buildings colored in pink showing the
buildings where works are proposed these
comprise of an old Piggy and
agricultural storage
building uh we then have the old pigy
building which has already been
converted into a bakery um whilst there
are no increases in the footprint
sympathetic external alterations to
modernized the building have been
carried out alongside the use of the
bakery uh in terms of the eastwing barn
it's currently used as agricultural
storage space um which is open on one
side The Proposal includes new metal
shutter doors to enclose the open
side so the glamping pods will be
located within the green area as shown
on the plan here just to the um left
hand side and the mobile homes would be
located within the pink and orange areas
shown it first important to note that it
is a change of use of land that requires
the planning permission it's not the
glamping pods nor mobile homes and as
such we have no control over their
appearance so long as they called with
the legal definition of a caravan the
glampin pods are for short-term
accommodation primarily for visitors to
the site which could be for tourism or
educational purposes or to partake in
events and activities on the site the
mobile homes are for Rural workers
whilst these would provide longer term
accommodation and could be used year
round they're not intended to be a set a
person's sole residence and would be
used Flex flexibly between workers on
site some of whom may need to be on site
longer than others all workers do long
and irregular working hours and carry
out a range of activities on site um
from working on the land leading
educational courses supervising visitors
securing the site and utilizing the
produce and materials of the land
through rural
crafts uh workers are likely to come and
go in accordance with business
needs those using the mobile homes will
be on minimum wage incomes with many
operating small rural craft businesses
in association with the Agro forestry
and sustainability focus of Wakeland as
well as carrying out a range of other
activities on site based on the site's
remote location there are no nearby
properties are suitable for such workers
given the hours and requirement for them
to be on site
24/7 moreover the price of the houses
for sale or rent within the nearby
settlements are Out Of Reach for the
workers as they are too costly and many
of them are self-employed
the number of PODS mobile homes has been
underpinned by a business plan which
demonstrates that they're needed to make
the site viable going forward whilst the
pods make for several people in each the
mobile homes are intended for six
workers shared amongst the six mobile
homes here are the floor plans and
elevations of the proposed pods um they
are easily moved around and would do so
in accordance with the Agro forestry
rotation Cycles as shown within the site
photos earlier
on um this is not a definitive plan by
any means of the Caravans proposed to be
used on site but shows a typical floor
plan and elevation um as noted
previously Caravans and glods do not
require planning permission in
themselves thus anything according with
the legal definition of a caravan which
is in terms of its size transportability
and construction would be permitted on
site the recommendation is therefore to
approve the development in accordance
with the details set out within the
committee report thank you for
listening thank you so questions I'll
just start off if I may um so can you
just clarify for me so uh six mobile
homes can take six workers per home so
it's 36
workers sorry if that wasn't clear
enough um it would be six workers in
total spread across so one per so
they're three they're showing three or
four two or three bedrooms one person
per so the the mobile homes in
themselves don't as a as say um require
planning permission um so anything up to
what you know is legally defined as a
caravan could be on site um the point is
that they're not intended to sort of
have any more than one person per
Caravan okay and um in the
recommendations you say removal of
mobile homes and pods from the site when
they're no longer used used on site and
any land they were sighted on shall be
remediated so under what circumstances
will the mobile homes not be used if
they're for six people and there's a
bakery there which presum is running all
year um so in terms
of the if I think it it's more to
mitigate against the fact that if the
mobile homes were not to be used at a a
point in the future um they are not to
be
um I
suppose to sort of they would have to be
removed from the land in the event that
they were no longer needed um it's not
saying that we we we don't believe that
they're needed currently but it is just
to mitigate any harm later down the
line thank you chairman yes just just to
clarify I mean it's the usual thing with
with with Caravans in the sense that
you're not judging the individual unit
but you have the change of use that
allows you to station one uh and given
that this is uh an isolated and remote
location clearly um one would not
normally support uh uh residential
accommodation on that basis so
reversability becomes an important point
and to that extent removing the Caravans
uh glamping pods however you want to
describe it ruing ruing those units at
the end of the need for them is the
appropriate course of action to take the
site back to previous state
sare my final question is I'm sorry I I
wasn't concentrating enough so you
talked about permanent occupancy of the
site that can you just refresh what you
said about the difference is there a
difference between permanent occupancy
of the Caravans versus permanent
occupancy of the glamping pods so the
intention is that the glamping pods are
more a short-term accommodation so they
wouldn't be used for you know any sort
of significant months yeah um whereas
the the mobile homes are more to do with
longer term accommodation um it may be
so the intention is that they could
potentially be occupied all year round
but they may not be depending on the
business needs of the site um equally it
might not be that it's used by the same
worker all the time it may change um but
as I say it's sort of intended they are
a slightly more flexible and longer term
um accommodation so there's no
restrictions on their policy there there
would be but it it's subject to us
working out the sort of final details of
that thank you uh
yes uh thank you chair um I've got a
couple of points the first one in your
uh right at the beginning of your
presentation you said that these things
would not be visible from a public right
of way Network and yet there is a public
footpath sort of right around the site
um and can I just also make the same
comment I made on the previous
application we have a multitude of
rotations of plan I've worked out where
the piggy and the barn are in relation
to you've made the point about the map
not facing yeah I'm just saying that
You' made it once I don't think we need
to hear us again I'm not okay and what
I'm just saying is can you please make
it clear on the plan of the pods where
the pods and the Vans are going where
the piggy and the barn are uh for
everyone's benefit um so my first point
is about the public rights away is it
are these um pods and vans going to be
visible from that public footpath that
goes around the side
um I'm looking at the recommendation on
page
310 um and uh we've got occupation
restrictions on both the glamping pods
and the mobile homes um do we know what
those are or or are you just this is
something that will you'll do at a later
date um and again back to the uh when
they're no longer used how do you
determine when they're no longer used
how long they have to have been empty
before you deem that they are no longer
being
used
um so first in terms of the public
rights way um it's more a matter of plan
and judgment that they are not going to
be visible from the public rights way
and that's mostly to do with the um
extensive Landscaping that I mentioned I
don't know if can we go back to slides
that might be
helpful
um
so if you look here um the there's a
public right of way that runs sort
of uh number
two so number two there is a public
RightWay that runs sort of alongside um
that tree belt which that's where the
mobile homes would sort be located so
number three sort of again spans round a
little bit further um as you can see
there is extensive landscape in there
and it is it's mature headro mature
mature trees um so the visibility of any
sort of mobile homes on that part of the
site would be quite minimal um equally
you can see with the the glamping pods
again they are enclosed by the aggro
forestry tree belts either side so that
that's sort of how Agro forestry works
is that you've got rows of tree belts
the glampin pods would be located within
those tree belts when they're not being
used and farmed on um and then they
would sort of move around so going back
to
um just try and work out which one might
be the one with shading
on uh was it is it further
back that one is it that one no the one
that looks
like the one that we've got on Pap be to
show the location all the others
on that the one
of right okay yeah no that's fine
[Applause]
saw slide 14 there we
go um
so in terms of the mobile homes they
could be located sort of anywhere within
that orange
area um and the the sort of pink side
down sort of to the the bottom corner um
you then have the green which is where
the glampin pods would be we have
proposed a condition would be placed on
the pods which would mean that at any
one point when they're sort of rotating
through and round that they're no no
closer than 75 m to the listed
Farmhouse has that answered my question
was actually could you point out where
the barn and the pig are on that map the
barn is uh just to the I don't know how
is that
the how do I do
that right hang on
right so the barn is sort of over
here um can you
see oh hang
on there we
go so that's where the barn is um and
then you've got the the listed Farmhouse
here and a range of other sort of
Agriculture buildings as well on on site
so
that's where that
is yes yeah that's all it's sort of all
in the same building if I go back
to um up on this hang
on so if I go to that one you can then
see it's the pink here so you've got the
the bakery which is the old Piggery
building and then the East swing
building is that so it's all sort of
attached within one sort of unit if that
makes sense
um when do you deem um the Vans to no
longer be used is there sort of time
limit or um and and about the occupation
condition yeah so in terms of the time
limit um I think we'd said probably 12
months I don't know if Phil or Gemma
have any sort of
um input in in what
we'd yeah so it it could be we we
probably specify a specific amount of
time um it could be 12 months um but
that's sort of how we would measure it
in in terms of the wording of the
condition and again the occupancy um
it's subject to us sort of working out
some final details on on how that would
be you know meet the six test of a
condition um but we would need to make
sure that the occupancy is is both you
know enforceable and we can manage it
and also that it reflects the needs of
the business um and is sort of flexible
in that
regard to pick up on that point chairman
um the question of occupation uh at the
moment doesn't have a definition from
the applicant as far as I can see um and
uh I think uh taking that as as a basis
these are not intended as permanent
homes for people I believe they are
intended to have a permanent home
elsewhere um that said I mean 12 months
certainly seems a reasonable period of
occupation um and in terms of uh use it
will be firstly in relation to uh the
mobile homes uh it will be in
association with the various Enterprises
and activities being undertaken here uh
the applican described those and
ultimately this is about the uh business
activities being undertaken on site and
would therefore have an occupancy
condition which for those of us old
enough to remember would be for a person
uh wholly mainly or last employed in an
activity which takes on site so that's
the standard way of approaching uh that
and as regards the uh glamping pods
they're more
shortterm uh and and therefore we tend
to think that an approach similar to
what you have on uh holiday
accommodation in other parts of the
district where you have a limitation uh
timed of 28 days and a register bearing
in mind you obviously need to ensure
that other people that people do have a
accommodation elsewhere uh and and that
those persons occupying those units are
doing so in association with on-site
projects uh and courses and events which
are effectively what the applicant has
described so you have two slightly
different groups of people occupy for
two slightly different purposes and
periods thanks councelor eurn you were
next um thank you chair um just two
questions could the mobile homes
effectively ultimately be rented out as
in the same way the glamping pods are so
for holidays um so you know bringing up
the number of that there and secondly
I'm assuming that there's no Landscaping
plan for near the mobile homes because
they're going to be moved around so
could you just confirm that thank
you uh yes thank you so the mobile homes
um we would condition their restriction
to be for Rural workers they're they're
not intended to be for short-term lets
that is the purpose of the glamping pods
um and in terms of their location within
the site um we're sort of proposing to
to restrict it so that they are
obviously six units and no more um as
the applicant describes um and also to
ensure that they are um not being moved
around as such they would sort of stay
static as it were um and I believe that
there is sort of Meadow Land that the
the site there is no Landscaping PL
submitted because the idea is that the
sort of um Meadow as you see existing
would be um maintained and sort of left
as Meadow Land as it were so the
Landscaping is effectively what you've
seen on the site
photos ccor hading thank you I'm so I
just want to check so that there is
going to be an agricultural restriction
on the the the um homes and um and can
you tell me how many um workers they do
have on the farm at the
moment um so yes we would restrict the
the mobile homes to be for rural workers
on site um they wouldn't be for just
sort of random members of the public or
anyone um and I think in terms of how
many workers there are on the site of
the minute I probably would defer that
question to the applicant who's probably
best place to answer
that yeah Council pass just a quick one
thanks keeps doing that um when it comes
to numbers of occupancy I mean we've
heard they fairly big um mobile homes is
it sensible to condition it that it's
one person per van only because I've
seen what's Not For a Moment suggesting
this would happen here but you do hear
stories of multiple occupancy and we do
have an issue there not around here but
in other parts of the country so it can
always be changed of course but it would
be a good idea would it not perhaps to
look at that in the first place
thanks chairman can I suggest and taking
the model of the Agricultural workers
dwelling of your uh to to heart you
would not wish to exclude people's
household that might be a little unfair
so um one would expect to allow for
occupancy by people Associated or
related to the principal occupant but
their occupancy is dependent on that
main person so you have a main occupant
who is working in the
Lo yeah um I I think requiring one
person as an individual will be hard to
justify in planning terms and it will be
hard and and somewhat unreasonable to
exclude family relatives children
dependence that that thing from the
situation
so can I just check is this a
retrospective planning application in
part or is that really not relevant
because according to metvi Parish
Council the baker is open the pods are
being advertised and occupied
already um so the bakery is that that
aspect is a retention of um I believe
that there are glamping pods on site I'm
not sure if they are being used
currently um so that again may be
something to defer to the applicant to
answer final question the glamping post
they have WC facilities in them or is
that a separate unit that's being built
yes I believe they do um there is a
toilet and shower block on site anyway
um again you may wish to check that with
the
applicant thank you um sorry the final
question
Fireballs so there's been correspondents
about it in the papers we've heard uh
people concerned about it um anything
more you can add about them just for our
benefit yeah um not really much more to
add um from what's Beyond in beyond the
committee report um other than you know
they are a common place domestic
Arrangement and they don't require
planning
permission yeah I I um obviously um
metfield Lan's going to be going to be a
particular issue that has been raised by
objectors and and and so on um I've
found my way to um pce
324 um County highways
um response and I see that the that
metfield lane is partly public and
partly
private and I'd like to see that on the
map and also to know if the the other
householders on metfield Lane um are
they on the public Highway part or are
do they have um a right of way over the
private
part so all of the this has sort of been
verified with suffer County Council
highways in terms of their um mapping
system but all of it appears to be
Highway land um it's just some of it is
unmaintained Highway land um I believe
the applicant would still if they wanted
to do any works on that bit that is um
unmaintained Highway land that they
would need to um apply for Section 278
works from the highway Authority but as
I understand it it's unmaintained um but
it doesn't serve it will only serve
Wakeland that part of the highway the
rest of it is maintained um and serves
the other properties along
that
um yeah that helps I must say so
actually you're saying that what's on
page bottom of page 324 is the note
isn't actually isn't actually correct
and that there isn't a private Lane as
such I must say I've never heard of an
unmaintained public Highway before but
it's always ni to learn something
new yeah so in terms of it it's private
in the sense that it only serves wand's
farm so that's more or less the question
I asked yes yeah so that's that specific
bit um towards the top I don't know if
we can go back to the slides again that
would be
helpful I think let me just see where it
is I don't going to go through all of
these
again so it should be slide eight I
think so this bit of metfield Lane um
which is the the sort of northernmost
bit which curves round um that area is
the bit that as as I say I've sort of
checked with suffer County Council
highways it appears that it is um
Highway land but it only serves Wakeland
as you can see sort of to the end there
um by that red sort of pin um then if we
go that last bit yes yeah so it starts
from a best staries and that red line is
that um is the bit that is sort of uh
unmaintained Highway land all that
and then this one as you can see is it's
a long Lane um so this bit of metfield
Lane again as I've sort of spoken to
suff County Council highways as we
understand it this is maintained public
Highway um and this is the the section
of the lane that serves the the
remainder of the properties that are
along
here okay uh anyone else yes councelor
field
yes just to return to the um the number
of workers I think it says you had a
business plan does the business plan
establish that there are six
workers um and do they need to be there
247 I understand someone running a
bakery may have extended hours but
that's one
person and as to the glamping pods that
that's people attending some form of
courses does the business plan again
establish that there are typically 12
attendees at a course who would need
that form of local
accommodation uh thank you so in terms
of the workers on site of the minute
again I'd probably defer any sort of um
questions about the business plan and
whatnot to to the applicant but in terms
of the submitted information um it was
listed that there are six workers they
don't just necessarily work in the sort
of rural um Enterprise and craft areas
such as Bakery um they do also sort of
act and operate in a a range of um
activities on site whether that be
working on the land picking fruit um
there are a range of things and equally
in terms of the the sort of events on
site that as I noted earlier don't
necessarily require planning permission
um they are also supervising visitors
helping with with the operations and
sort of the viability of the site in
that sense um the glamping pods it may
be that they are used by more than one
person per glamping pod so there may be
more than 12 people um but equally you
know it may range across they might be
some that are grouped together because
there are sort of groups on site um
engaging in activities or it might be
for sort of appreciation of the site to
come and sort of educate themselves on
Agro forestry um that's that's really
the intention of them
okay right we'll move on then so thank
you very much uh so we'll now move on um
I should have said at the beginning
councelor hadingham who's is the ward
member so can't vote on this application
but gets to speak later on okay so first
of all we'll go to the public speakers
um we ask the parish council first Peter
Mortimer to speak you have three minutes
we have a timer here please if I can ask
you to keep to the 3 minutes please over
to you when you're ready thank much Mr
chairman
I'm representing the views of mfil Paris
Council and its perishers and this
presentation is in conjunction with the
lobbying paper which we already
submitted to counselors Whitland Farm
Has a festing Field address but is
geographically much closer to
Mill cine by residents and is impacted
by any noise generated from the site the
application has raised a lot of concern
in the local community reflecting on the
unusual High number of comments
submitted it should be noted that most
of the objectors live within 2 3 miles
of the site 82% of the ejectors whereas
less than 15% of the persons supporting
the applicant live locally the import it
is important that committee considers
the site as a whole as there are complex
interaction between different aspects
and of development with many periphery
issues the planning officer we do feel
has in some respects been slightly
contradictory and she hasn't failed to
ask any pertinent questions to get a
better understanding of the site the
pods are not in keeping with the
vernacular and the bright colors can be
clearly seen through the hes they are
not clear why this additional
accommodation is required there VAR a
variety of local accommodations
available in the immediate vicinity use
of which would benefit the local
community currently those living in the
satic Caravans are the Baker and the
Woodland har dapy lady on our site visit
the applicant explained these units were
self managed so we've assumed they are
independent Ventures there is only 12
hours of Woodland craft courses AB
between June and September so why is
there a need to provide
accommodation concern has been raised
that the accommodation is not restricted
to single workers but to families too
there's currently no changes in in the
numbers of those managing the
agricultural aspect of the farm nor
changed to the agricultural practice so
the proven essential and immediate need
has not been demonstrated The Farmhouse
would have provided an actal
accommodation but this has now been
converted into self-catering
accommodation for up to 12 people duding
the farm of its residency this could set
a precent damaging the community further
by removing permanent residen within
local farms we dispute the highways
report that the visibility spays meet
safety standards required for the
turnoff from the fessing Field Road onto
matfield Lane this is a completely blind
Corner When approaching from metfield
crossing any oncoming traffic the lane
passes through an agriculture Machinery
business followed by two further blind
bends and is extremely narrow it also
forms part of a recognized public rights
of way in the past only the five
residents using this Lane to say the
increase in traffic is memorable and
realistic walkers have reportedly
encounted traffic visiting wakands not
slowing down or giv them the opportunity
to get on the verge in the application
numbers are related to those working on
the farm it does not account for day
visitors and those paying to Camp what
the maximum capacity of the site and
what that creates the restrictions the
parking is extremely limited the current
sanitation can be cated for up to 40
people
and what the sanitation is providing the
foul water from the pods the camping and
the GL glamping we do not know can I say
the three minutes is up so I need the
final sentence right to summarize we
would not we would ask the committee to
look at the wider pitcher potentially
could have up to 60 people occupying the
SES which we feel is first of all
completely overdevelopment we're
concerned about the road usage we are
concerned about noise at night because
we had an instance last year and we've
already had one this year late music I
am going to have to stop I'm afraid take
this into account and the sanitizing and
thank you very much Mr chairman thank
thank
you okay happy to take questions for the
parish council yeah Council maner first
thank you chair um uh you you mentioned
noise uh H have have any um any of the
nearby residents made an official
Complaint to the environmental health uh
about any noise from this site is my
first question and the second question
you made some mention of camping is
there also a camp site at this
venue the one on noise
was perhaps a oneoff last year and it
was accepted it went on all night
through to sday lunchtime and this year
we've had one a fortnite ago that was
going on late from 11:00 but as I as I
understand I do not know the answer to
to whether anybody I haven't and I
haven't heard through the Paris Council
that anybody has officially complain to
that one um asard the other P was you I
I thought I thought I heard you say the
word camping there were people camping
there a lot of this we
feel is uh rospective because the whole
thing's up and
running and and I for three weeks ago
they had had a weekend and there was
motor HS there and camping as well so
you can add up the numbers going up
there little tiny roads that are not
capable to take
it thank you any more questions at
all no okay thank you very much thank
you um so we now move on uh to um we
don't have a we do not have a supporter
so when asked to an obor Linda Finley uh
you have three minutes to address the
committee good afternoon my name is
Linda Finley my husband and I have been
farming at Whittingham hall for 25 years
and we are neighbors of wand's farm I
wish to put forward arguments against
this application being approved the lane
leading to ain's farm is single track
with no passing places and is used by
large agricultural vehicles and
Machinery this will inevitably present
problems especially during the harvest
season the proposed number of static
Caravans and glamping PS seems excessive
for the existing activities at the farm
heritage's response is that the
application does not appear to offer
evidence to substantiate need for
additional accommodation of the skill
proposed nor even to substantiate the
need at at all these accommodation
facilities are also not in keeping with
a grade two listed Farmhouse there's
bound to be an ad Bear's impact on
wildlife and the land itself with a
significant increase in numbers of
people Vehicles noise levels and light
pollution the educational aspect of the
bakery and other courses is acceptable
but the application as it stands is in
appropriate in scale with too many
people and vehicles for the area parking
for visitors will be insufficient and if
more parking spaces are created this
will have impact on the environment and
could be impossible to use during the
winter months parking on the single
Track Road could impede access by the
Emergency
Services the proposed development could
Prejudice the immunities currently
enjoyed by people living in nearby
Properties by way of increased noise and
disturbances associated with additional
traffic and large numbers of people on
site at any one time one local resident
has stated in past years that have been
family partis functions at wakin in the
summer months the noise from which has
spread as far as matefield Village
because of the Goodwill engendered by
Martin and an wolf and the fact that
these were infrequent neighbors have not
really complained now that the intention
seems to be to keep people on sight if
possible the potential for noisy
evenings is much increased the wakand
website has already been advertising
lettings for pods The Farmhouse
and even camping before planning per
permission has been granted fire pits
provided for each pod will be a
potential fire hazard and are not
mentioned in the application neither is
there any mention about a site manager
which is extremely
concerning in conclusion this proposal
should not be given approval as there is
not the infrastructure to support the
number of residential units for example
inadequate toilet facilities the lane
access no detail and waste disposal
recycling this is an overdevelopment for
a very rural location with little
benefit for the local
community thank you thanks very much
happy to take any questions at
all no okay thank you for that um we I I
we do have we do have supporters here
but I didn't think a supporter wanted to
speak or did you actually you did oh
okay sorry I was looking at Old notes so
you now also have three minutes
um hello everybody my name is Fay I am
the Woodland habash lady as mentioned
earlier one of the on-site rural
Enterprises um who's on site making use
of so I'm renting workshops based off
David and Amanda um and being having
some on-site accommodation would be
extremely useful I'm born in suffk bred
in suffk lived rural suffk all my life
and on a sort of rural Artisan wage it
is almost impossible to rent anywhere
not purely from a financial point of
view in terms of monthly earnings but
also when you have to go to a letting
agent you have to submit they have to
sort of you know you have to get credit
checked effectively and they don't like
self-employed books so as much as you
could actually support yourself Cashwise
it's very difficult to get any kind of
letting in the in the local area I've
tried West suffk East suffk now we're
trying miduk um and it's uh it's very
generous of somebody like David and
Amanda to support uh rural Enterprises
startup Enterprises um young people
trying to keep in the countryside who've
always been in the countryside and not
feeling bullied out into into an urban
environment I realize that the Caravans
looks a bit uh can look a bit dodgy in
terms of sort of long-term occupancy but
really we are all startups and we just
need somewhere to stay for the first
year 18 months of these businesses by
which case we have then an established
business and we will be able to sort of
move out into the wider Community it's
incredibly hard especially in these
times to keep going and to even get
started quite frankly so to find
somewhere like wakands where there is a
community where we're all sort of
integrated I understand maybe from the
planning it's unclear how all the
businesses work together um and God
forbid anybody could actually be that
altruistic in this modern day and age
but that is the ethos of of Wakeland we
are all working within elements of the
farm we're not sort of you know a Potter
coming in or somebody coming in just to
rent unit space it is pertinent to the
uh materials and all of the sort of
Enterprises and previous work on site so
the bakery with the wheat I am
personally involved with more of the
woodworking side of things so taking
into that that into consider
consideration um and it is very variable
courses it's not just a case of pods for
courses it's a case that there is
Workshop space required for private
commissions um and personal work and
development so it's not a sort of a
direct input output kind of um scenario
again we're all startups we're all
getting on so the events program may not
be as developed as people seem to be
taking from the website there are things
in the pipeline and obviously these
things take time to get uh established
um that thank you
thank you very much any questions at
all no okay so we now move on to the
applicant uh David wolf
again oh right sorry keep y do keep
going does that work yeah um my name is
Henrietta I'm also a supporter of this
application I run the bakery at wakands
where we use the organic wheat grown on
the farm um in our bread and we also use
we're also in charge of um harvesting
the fruit grown on the farm um baking
involves very early mornings and our
fruit tfing work is very seasonal at the
moment we're working very long hours
waking up early to harvest the plums
we've got at least uh 30 plum trees um
so we staying on sight is really
necessary um for this and for our
well-being um it's a really new business
I've invested a huge amount in fact all
of my savings um so um renting or buying
accommodation locally would complet be
completely impossible for me and my
colleague Maisy exactly as fa stated um
as well as creating jobs our Bakery is
enabling learning we run courses
empowering people to grow their own that
is the 3 minutes up with the extended
time for the break between so I have to
ask you for your final sentence please
just make a comment on the previous
oppos in terms of benefit to the local
economy um just has to be literally the
final sentence
okay above all Wakeland is a place of
vast biodiversity and natural beauty and
everything we do there as collaborating
Enterprises will uphold those values
thank you very much sorry to cut you off
I didn't realize you were going to more
than one speaker Sor okay uh any
questions for the supporters no okay so
we now U head back to uh David wolf uh
as the applicant and again you have
three minutes to address the committee
thank you very much um so my parents
bought Wakeland in
1992 um my father had been an
agricultural scientist working for the
government for his working life and for
them it was very much an experimental
scientific project they planted Agro
forestry which was then incredibly
Innovative and pioneering um and they
sank their money into it and because it
was scientific they drew in research
money um from uh the UK and abroad which
sustained it financially um and allowed
it to operate as a research
establishment for 25 years
um what you see as a result of that is
the AGR foresty system now operating the
tree lines running north south um 12
MERS apart which means it's incredibly
well landscaped and that's part of the
farming system um uh but their system
and once they died and once the science
experiments uh could no longer carry on
that their system stopped being
sustainable and we can't carry on that
system as they ran it it was never set
up to be a commercial Farm um ironically
it has then been the demonstration site
for other people um other farmers in in
suffk and in East Anglia and indeed
across the world have come to Wakeland
and continue to come I entertain Farmers
visitors on an almost weekly basis who
want to come and look at this uh
alternative farming system sadly not
taken up by any of our neighbors um but
Wakeland is now an absolute jewel in the
uh agricultural Crown we've been on BBC
World TV recently um uh we have uh many
many visitors uh we work very closely
with uh the the wildlife trust as you've
heard and so on to integrate all those
things um and in many ways it's the fure
future of farming and the government
financial schemes are going to start
incentivizing it soon but we can't carry
on this demonstration site without the
additional diversification and that's
what this application is all about um
each element of this diversification is
carefully crafted so that all the
elements work together um they are all
designed around the farming so the
organic rotation that you've heard about
um uh is growing lentils wheat chickpeas
uh uh squash various other things um in
the tree lines we have 50 sorts of plums
PLS cherries apples um not commercial
viable crops because of the scale of the
operation um but we are now beginning to
be able to use those in what are called
short food chains so we can't sell
cherries economically into the market
it's not viable financially what we can
do is have en and her team on site
making uh Cherry baking things which are
then sold through the local shops um 10
or so local shops in in the area are now
selling bread and other products made at
Wakeland that simply not sustainable
able um for reasons you've heard without
the things in this planning application
likewise we are now running courses
beginning to run them um they are very
limited in scale and number at the
moment because we can't attract the
number of people we need to make them
viable and that's essentially what the
glamping pods are about um this is an
integrated um carefully thought through
plan and we think it's necessary and
sustainable and as you heard from the
planning officer um no impact on
residential immunity in the area thank
you very
much thank you thank you yeah questions
yeah councelor Hingham thanks um apart
from M feay and henriet um what other
the workers do you have there that would
need to um have year round um
accommodation um so the other third
person you would have heard from if you
had more time is Rachel who's sitting my
right um Rachel Holly and Khloe are
involved in a community supported
agriculture project um they've been
working there since March they're now a
running a box scheme which supplies uh
30 families in the area with a veg box
uh every week
um Rachel and Chloe are currently living
on the outskirts of Norwich they can
only come to wakin occasionally because
of the distance involved and the finance
involved um at this time of the year
they need to be on site for very long
hours to carry that on so that's three
Enterprises um and this is the beginning
we would like more because it's those
Enterprises that um allow for Rural
workers an activity which we think is
important and which will allow us to um
properly uh I don't mean use in a
utilitarian sense but um make the best
benefit of the Farmland so um we have
currently it depends how you count it um
including part-time and voluntary people
coming on site we probably have dozens
of people involved in farming compared
to the farm next door which is a
thousand acres and basically employs one
person so this is bringing rural workers
back to the land um in a way which is
actually what suffk used to be like for
hundreds of years um as opposed to the
sort of Baron Farmland around us and
also bringing and sustaining the
biodiversity without that um we are
nothing
yeah please um would you say if the
committee were minded to to condition
the the the term of use I from say May
to um sorry November to or may to
November would you say that was
unviable uh well it um we we um if we
were only talking about seasonal
agricultural workers that's permitted
development we wouldn't be here yeah so
so the answer is yes um for example uh
the veg operation is basically all year
round the bakery operation is all year
round um and Fay's operation just to
take the three examples we have already
um Fay is on site all year round well
will be on site all year round um not
just running courses but also she uh I'm
going to use the word scrumps she'll
kill me for that um scrumps things from
the tree lines and the hedr it's an
additional activity that is then running
a commercial craft business which takes
place all year round she is growing WOD
to make traditional you know all of it
goes on and it's it's it's phenomenal to
see Council man uh thank you thank you
chair um uh we have received lots of um
um lobbying emails about this
application uh and I I I sort of got the
impression that um uh some of the people
we've heard from uh have said that
you're advertising these glamping pods
for
holidays um can you confirm that that
that the the glamping pods are only
going to be let to um people people
coming on courses at your establishment
or at some of the other um businesses
that are going on um sorry um uh the
principal use of the glamping pods I
hate the word glamping pods is for
people who are coming on events and
activities um I can't guarantee that
there'll be some won't be somebody there
who doesn't take part in an activity so
for example um a couple might come and
one of them will go on a course and the
other one will simply wander around and
enjoy themselves um uh and I can't so I
can't promise and it would be an
unreasonable condition to require that
sort of restriction um and there may be
people who simply come because they want
to wander around and use enjoy our sight
because it's um it's a beautiful place
to which people want to come so for
example a couple of weeks ago we had a
butterfly day for the community 130
people came some of the people came on
that um and said could could they stay
no now if they'd stayed on for an extra
few days simply to enjoy the suffer
Countryside and what we can offer um I
can't say no to that can I
can we can you just talk about noise
management so um obviously we've heard
that there have been G Camp there was a
camping event I think someone said the
other day how who's on site who will
manage that if that were to happen and
you know people start gathering in
numbers around a pod and making more
noise than we're very happy to restrict
the activities to take around around the
pods but that's um uh that's very small
numbers of people uh around uh units
which as you've heard from the planning
officer would be very located way away
from all the the the farmland and so on
um we've had a family party I think that
was what was mentioned we've had a
family party in previous years which
didn't go on all night that's small
Point um and that's nothing to do with
his planning
application yeah but it but you are
attracting people to the site so is
there going to be someone who be who
will be the seter point of contact if
the community feels there is a noise
issue who who they can if I could just
finish if they can deal with and contact
a central point who is known to the
community as the sort of contact number
because that often makes things a lot
smoother when there is a problem yeah no
I understand the point um so one of the
things that put in various objections
was um there is no on-site Duty manager
now that's actually um uh a a twisted
version of a distorted question that was
put to me I was asked will you be
employing a 24-hour Duty manager to
which my answer was no I won't be
employing a 24-hour Duty manager um but
we will there are always people on site
and indeed part of the roles of the
people you've heard from is to provide
exactly that kind of supervision um my
phone number has been published on our
website now for um more than a year um
with a clear indication that people can
can contact me it's never been run um
and that will continue to be the case we
we will always have indeed we're about
to have a if you like a duty phone so
that it's not necessarily my phone well
not actually me that's got it in my
pocket but somebody will be allocated uh
24 hours a day to have the duty first
phone but as I say um I'm not aware well
that hasn't my phone hasn't rung uh in
the last year and I don't I'm not aware
that any concerns were raised previous
to that um so I don't I really don't see
any problem with that the concern that's
raised in the papers has come from a Sor
you've I think you've answered the
question so there will be a contact
number 24 hours a day if needed for the
community yeah councelor pass thanks
Matthew yeah ju just a quick question if
you did were to have permission granted
there you've got the mobile homes and
the glamping units um I think it was
mentioned by someone all hinted that
what about F water drainage these sorts
of things how's that all dealt with and
I think you going to have a shower block
or other facilities there cuz you could
have an extra 25 30 people in theory
maybe 35 sure um uh so that's it's very
straightforward uh we have each of the
pods has uh a toilet inside with a
caravan style cassette unit which are
emptied so they're completely standard
units they're in every mobile home in
the land they're absolutely standard and
safe and hygienic um they are emptied
when necessary in to our uh waste
treatment plants we've got two large
claresta units on site um one is only a
few years old the other was newly
installed last year by binders in
ipswitch we have full service contracts
for them they are modern units they're
specified in capacity terms to be more
than enough to deal with all of this so
we don't we really don't think there's
an issue in that regard um we have uh an
existing uh shower toilet Block in
addition to that um and indeed three
toilets which are sort of not part sort
of public within the site um which we
think is plenty of capacity um so
there's no I don't think there's any
issue and that they all feed obviously
into our claresta units we're not on
Main's
drains any other questions yes councelor
Matson yeah I think you you've covered
some of the points I think we we've sort
of established that there will be a duty
site manager role so to speak um the the
other the other point Point really um
are you are you ruling out a
commercial camping
operation um or can we condition it so
that there isn't there isn't that other
other thing um possibly going to happen
and I just wonder whe there's anything
you can do to to to help with the
problem with the
lane um although it does it does seem as
if the the the problem that you can deal
with is actually within your control
anyway which is the well no it's not is
it's the public Highway not
maintained um so I don't know exactly
you're able to do anything about that um
but it doesn't actually affect other
people so it's it's it's marginal it's
difficult um you know are are
you willing to offer any any you know
Comfort to people that are saying that
that that might get worse and worse
bearing in mind it's a public right of
way as well isn't it I think I establish
that want try and do you want me can I
try and answer do you want me to try and
answer yeah um can I do with the
highways Point first um so the first
part of metfield Lane is a suffer County
Council Highway as it happens um they
are repairing it tomorrow by sheer good
luck um good old suffer County Council
the next section is a Private Drive I
don't know where this notion of
unmaintained public right it's not it's
a private drive it doesn't have a public
right of away going up it there are
public rights foot paths around the
periphery all as your planning officer
said heavily screened from us by very
mature Hedges because we let our Hedges
get mature but there is no public right
of way anywhere on our land as it
happens we've offered a permissive
scheme to allow the public to come and
enjoy the land but that's a completely
separate question so there's no
maintenance question or anything like
that to do with our private driveway um
as far as I can ascertain um so I hope
that deals with that question on the
metfield lane bit the highway bit um we
have offered and you see it mentioned in
your committee papers to put in a
passing place which we could readily do
on an existing field entrance all on our
land your officers haven't required it
of us nor did the highways Authority
require it of us we'll probably do it
anyway but if you want to include it in
a condition that's absolutely fine um
completely um on the camping Point um we
like anybody else have permitted
development rights in relation to tent
and that's what we
do Philip you want to
come thank you chairman yes just two
small points one relating to the footp
footpath rights of w question I think if
you look on page 323 of the agenda
bundle you see a comment from the
British horse society which helpfully
includes an extract from the ORD survey
map so I think you'll find that um and
my recollection of Rights of way
notation on these Maps is a little rusty
but you've got public rights away and
the foot paths are shown I believe as
the pecked green line lines um I'm not
quite sure the status of the green dots
from memory but they're certainly C
rights away and they probably overlayers
rights the um Highway rights that the
county have within their Road Network so
you probably got both going on over that
but obviously they don't they don't they
don't from the spur heading Southeast
shall we say back towards Wakeland they
don't go from that elbow towards the
house proper as one point secondly as
regards um fou dry and service water
treatment um clearly it's a sort of
matter that technically you deal with
byw condition
so that You' effectively impose a
condition to establish whether or not
that is an adequate um uh sewage
treatment facility to support the number
of people using it and if not uh seek
Improvement of it as a an engineering
matter under a planning condition thank
you
chairman
okay well you just been given
unfortunately no no I'm sorry you you it
doesn't you can't come in unless you're
ask a question
um any other questions at all CH
chairman just if I may leap in um Mr
Wolf clearly thinks I've misled the
committee I think it's important for uh
the committee to make a decision on the
facts and if he thinks I'm wrong I'd
welcome his
correction thank you I'm grateful that
the um the plan on
323 which is attached to the BHS
application British hor Society
application um is uh if you look at it
if you just look at the word at the
bottom where it says wakands by metfield
Lane farm so that's the metfield lane
coming up then you've got the word
wakands that route goes slightly
Northwest um and they've marked on a
dashed line I don't know what color it
is on your color plans um but the first
bit of that running um up the side of
our boundary which is where the tree
annotation is that is an existing public
footpath but it's on to be very clear
it's on land that nobody owns yep when
it gets to the corner um that public
right away then turns West and you see
that going west and with a slight
s-shaped Bend in it but the bit that's
dashed going north from there has been
marked on by the BHS because
historically that was a public right of
way it's been plowed over and um
effectively is uh Trashed by one of our
neighboring farmers and the BHS has an
aspiration to reinstate it um so if you
read their letter that's their
aspiration to reinstate it we we would
be delighted to support them in that
because we think the public rights way
network is important but that Northerly
bit is not currently a public right of
way um I think you had another plan that
the planning officer showed that not in
the pack that showed the public rights
away on a on a slide uh and chairman
that that slide is Slide Five on page
347 and uh I'm obliged to Mr wol for uh
providing that
Clarity can we have a comfort break
before we start the debate
please uh three minutes I can't say no
if you've asked but let's just see any
other question questions at this point
can we just have the ward member Speak
oh sorry yes yeah and then after the
ward member we'll literally take a
two-minute break so now I hand over to
the ward member
linia thank you very
much as you have heard local opinion is
split prestonville Parish counil gave
their opinion without a site visit and
gave only four lines of comment both
mendum and metfield did a site visit and
asked that you refuse this application I
have to say I've heard more people
objecting to this application than
supporting it that is why I'd like to
ask that a site it be arranged for this
committee to visit weakland farm for
themselves and the decision deferred
until then however in the meantime I
shall go on I'm all for Farm
diversification and Wakeland has long
been a leader in this area and the
applicants parents Martin and Anne who
lived in The Farmhouse there were
respected and well thought of I have no
problem with the Farmhouse being used
for Holiday lets or the bakery which
which are both up and running before
change of use been given or for the pods
which need no permission my only
reservation lies with the static
Caravans firstly six of them seem
excessive only met two members of Staff
who wanted to live on site I appreciate
that I only made one site visit but to
all workers there need on-site
accommodation I commend David and Amanda
for supporting L young local Artisans
like Fay and henriet and I do think
that's marvelous but I but I do want to
say that they're um basically permanent
homes with all year round occupancy if
the application was for six permanent
dwellings there's nowhere be acceptable
but that is the kin to what is being
asked for is there really a demonstrated
need for all six it is not a large farm
at 56 acres and why year- round
occupancy instead of say March to
November this location cannot be called
sustainable by any stretch of the
imagination the officer and her own
words calls the site very isolated the
nearest shop is metfield is in metfield
Village almost 3 miles away and
Freshfield shop is the same and the
nearest public transport is hon 7 miles
away it is located at the end of a very
narrow single Track Road that comes off
another single Track Road from
fressingfield to metfield with passing
places in one of the lobbying letters
from the closest neighbor it showed
photographs of the lane and um and how
very narrow it was it also showed an
email from CCO explaining how a special
smaller vehicle was needed to collect
the rubbish owing to the difficulties
previously had there due to the deep
deep ditches on either side which caused
concern for the drivers while turning
and I feel that the officer saying
there'll be only a slight increase in
traffic is grossly
underestimated our own Heritage officer
has raised concerns regarding the
setting of a grade two listed build
regarding the setting of of a listed two
buildings saying there would likely be
an above low level of less than
substantial harm arising from the
sighting of the glamping pods in mobile
homes they also raised concerns that
there is no evidence of Need for
additional
accommodation the mppf states in
considering the impact of proposed
development on the sign significance of
a designated Heritage asset great weight
should be given to the asset's
conservation the mobile homes and pods
would cause less than substantial harm
to the setting of the listed Farmhouse
and notwithstanding the economic
activity ass associated with the
development I feel this does not
outweigh the great weight which should
be given to the conservation of a
Heritage asset to allow such harm would
be contrary to paragraph 202 of the nppf
2001 and contrary to public contrary to
policy hb1 of the adopted mslp 1998 and
would not respect the built Heritage of
mids suffer contrary to policy CS5 of
the core strategy 2008 therefore I
implore you to come to the site itself
for a visit and see it for yourselves
else why or else I refuse this
application thank
you okay thank you any questions for the
ward member before we take a quick
Comfort break yeah counselor yeah um
just asked you talked about a a site
visit and sometimes I think that can be
really worthwhile are you saying this
because of the complex nature not just
of the site but the various activities
and it's very difficult to get a
description not withstanding all the
contributions everybody's made which has
been very very good and thank you for
that but there are times I think seeing
it actually is believing is that really
what you're saying pros and cons for
this it's not
just on there but you need to see it for
yourselves okay thank
you do we want to keep going or do you
need that Comfort break keep going I'm
getting the thumbs up can we keep going
John no
okay literally can we really only be 4
minutes please
because
okay thank you welcome back everyone so
um yeah so we've heard from uh everyone
now it's up to us now to discuss debate
and come to a
conclusion um Council eburn straight off
I was going to go as well but go for it
I think we're all going to say the same
thing you can you can go if you wish
chair I just in the interest of moving
things along as I say um I um
with regards to this application I mean
I think it's very commendable the work
that's been done at wakands and I think
the fact that we spent all morning
debating a um planning application that
was going to create industrial jobs in
the edge of Stone Market that we should
really be supporting creative and Rural
jobs in the countryside and I I kind of
think it's a shame that this application
didn't come a sort of more of of a hole
in terms of you know from the beginning
and what they' wanted to um achieve um
and and putting kind of the the rural
jobs case and so on so forth because I
think that would have possibly engaged
the um local community more in terms of
not starting off um glamping pods and so
on before um this has come to
committee however um it has come here
and it's for us to kind of um look at
regularizing um some of the work that's
gone on but also to um agree or not um
you know where where they're at um and
personally I would be in favor of this
application um with a couple of um
conditions I knowe that the um applicant
has mentioned a passing point and that
traffic in and in and out of the site
has been um mentioned as an issue and if
they were prepared to offer a passing
point then I think that's um very
useful um and I think if there is
something that can be done to um
limit the um use of the mobile homes and
perhaps numbers and however that can be
monitored and I'm a bit unsure in
planning terms how how that is possible
to be
done um then I think there should be
something to do with that but I think
overall I think these are um it's
creative rural work in the in the
countryside and um we should be
supporting that thank you chair thank
you councelor pman well I'm not sure
whether that was a formal propos
proposal or not but I was going to pick
up on um what the W member of inia hadum
said and um propose that we do have a
site visit because I think it is a it's
a sensitive location I understand all
the arguments from both sides and I'm
not in a position to make up my mind
here and now but I do think a site visit
would add value because picking up on
Rachel saying jobs in the country so of
course it's important and we all agree I
can't believe anybody would disagree
with that but it's just making sure it's
done in the right way and I think
because of the complexity with the
glamping um pods the mobile homes the
other activities there an awful lot
going on here and I'm not in any way
saying that's wrong but I personally
would feel there would be considerable
Merit in having a site visit I don't
know if anybody else agrees with that
you may not but I'll put that on the
table as a formal proposal and if nobody
seconds it well we can't do it thanks
well funny enough I that would be my
preferred route as well um I only became
a counselor I will say this I'm really
sorry but I only became a counselor I
had no intention of ever becoming a
counselor I was living in suffk and I
got asked to speak at a parish council
here at this committee by my Parish
Council on a planning application around
a campsite that developed in the village
and actually is when you do the site
visit you really get to see the detail
and I think it's really hard for us to
sit here we're hearing some wonderful
things that are going on on the site but
we're also hearing from residents who
are clearly very upset and I think a
site visit would just help help me make
my mind up because at the moment I'm
finding that a difficult decision so I'd
be happy to Second a site visit
uh as
well anyone else wish to speak yeah
councelor mat yeah I I did if you
remember a very long timeo now I did
declare personal interest um and that
was because I did visit the site some I
think it's 18 or 20 months ago now so I
I am actually familiar with this I I
think the um the you know the
committee's understanding would
certainly be enhanced by by um by a
visit
um and um so yeah I'll I'll support the
idea that you go and have a look and see
what I've already seen although at that
time obviously I wasn't looking at it
with with this
application uh
envisaged anyone else wish to speak or
we'll go to a vote it's been proposed
and seconded for a site visit uh let's
just any other any wish to speak we'll
go to the vote on that first okay let's
go to the vote on that
thank you
members that vote is not there
yet he in he's now in
progress
that's it that's four votes for and two
votes against site visit so that's
carried okay so the site visit will take
place uh next Wednesday morning and
details will be emailed to everyone uh
in the next 24 hours for the site
visit okay thank you very much so we now
uh clean the desks and move another team
in so thanks everyone thanks for joining
us and again the parish council uh and
the applicant will all get an
opportunity to you know show us your
concerns or show us around next week but
we'll send you notification on the
process and how that
works
okay welcome back everyone so we're
going to move on now so we're going to
um re jiggle uh the order because we've
got various people in the room so we're
going to go straight through and do the
uh DC we're going to do the two and bton
effectively so uh 8 a and and 8B next uh
as we have the parishes here and the um
Ward member so we'll go straight into
dc211 930 Land north of Church Road bton
hand over to the case
officer thank you chair uh good
afternoon members ladies and gentlemen
um the application you're being asked to
consider now as a reserve matters
proposal um for the erection of 81
dwellings on a site north of Church Road
in
bton uh this is a wider aial view map um
of the site um and if I could just point
out with a little red dot here you can
see the general settlement of bton um to
the right you've got cotton um and over
here
wyon this plan shows a l It's a larger
scale plan showing the site in relation
to the the settlement of bton which as
you can see is fairly linear running
along the road um and the site stretches
back faces onto Church Road um and then
backs up towards uh sorry uh abouts the
won Road as
well this is the constraints plan um
you'll note from that that the site is
not inside the settlement boundary at
the present time it abuts it um the
other constraints worthy of note are
listed buildings um and in
particular the grade two star listed
building you can see where my DOT is
which is the one for which sorry which
is backton
Mana um this is the red line application
site the only thing I would point out on
this particular plan is that you'll note
that the red line Covers Part of wyon
road which reflects the fact that fall
planning permission has been granted for
the access onto the
site um this application came to you
with a recommendation sorry not this
application the outline planning
application came to committee with a
recommendation of approval but the
recommendation was
overturned um and at that time um this
indicative master plan form part of the
planning application that you were asked
to consider um as you will have noted
from my report yeah uh the refusal was
sub subsequently tested at appeal um and
the inspector allowed the appeal um and
he saw fit as part of his approval um to
identify this plan um as something that
he felt development should follow in
terms of General accordance I think it's
a frame General in accordance with um so
I thought it's useful admitted it from
the original package so apologies for
that but so you got an idea of how the
site worked in terms of the indicative
master plan you can see the point of
pedestrian sorry vehicle access taking
place over wyon Road a large area of
open space to the bottom with
attenuation areas um the area of
residential development including a
linear stretch going up the main spine
Road and an area of open space to the
top
so um that was included within the
package that was considered at the
appeal this subsequent Reserve matters
application in our view follows the uh
indicative plan in terms of site
Arrangement generally as I said before
the access to the site is fixed um at
this point off of Wiston Road you have
the open space at the frontage the areas
of residential development um and the
open space to the north so the general
Arrangement as I've said in the report
um we feel follows that plan that was uh
identified to be a spectre at outline
stage this plan um shows a smaller scale
and a larger scale of the uh approved
access means of access um which will
serve the
site um and this leads to a movement
Network layout which again I've tried to
enlarge this top part so you can see
exactly what we're talking about but
there's a primary vehicular route which
goes through the main spine Road as
you'd expect a tertiary route um and
private drives which are in the yellow
and then public foot paths and public
cycle paths um the color isn't
particularly good but that line there
and that line there are indicated as
being public cycle path routes
um this is the housing distribution
layout the housing as I've said in the
report ranges a mix of two three four
and five bed units across the site um
and it's a mix obviously um affordable
and
private um and this plan shows the
affordable housing development which is
up in the corner which you can see um
the darker blue units are the affordable
rent and the lighter blue are shared
ownership um parking provision across
the site um meets the required standard
the arrangement of parking is
identified um in the case of two
particular plots which are
here does have instances of triple
parking but the reason we've taken the
um option of bringing this to committee
with two triple plots or two triple
parking spaces is that the arrangement
of development here we felt was the
optim optimum solution in relation to
protecting the amenity of the nearest
residential development on that side
which is uh back to Manor itself so
we're happy with that Arrangement which
is served off a a private Drive um and
in terms of the uh visitor Arrangement
you'll see there's a concentration of
visitor spaces along the bottom um
that's in reflection of the likelihood
that people may want to use some of
these spaces here in order to access the
shop um so it's more of a convenience
element for that they're not allocated
for that purpose and that was tested at
the appeal the inspector was quite clear
he didn't think there was sufficient
reason to have a community car park on
this site within that open space that
you can see but I think the developer
um have reflected that in terms of the
arrangement of visitor spaces so there
is a concentration towards the south in
consideration of the commercial sorry of
the shop unit that's down here and the
the general
traffic um this is the open space layout
again um it rather starkly shows the the
attenuation which is on that um that
Frontage space which I'll talk about in
more detail in a minute um um and the
top half which contains the the play
area a for formal children's play area
um on the boundry which again was shown
in the parameter plan
earlier this is the landscape master
plan which works up um details how it
would work we are suggesting there would
be a final uh condition regarding uh
Landscaping uh so that the actual detail
final detail of that um would be further
agreed but the actual framework that
you're seeing there we're happy with in
terms of an approach on this site I
think key things to point out on
this are the amount of mature or sorry
the amount of native planting that would
go on the front um to augment what's
already there cuz there's a as you'll
see from my photographs in a minute
there's a nice hedge along the front
edge um and none of the existing hedging
and trees along the boundary boundaries
of this site would be removed as as a
result of this development taking place
which again is a key consideration in
landscape and also ecology
terms um this is a frontage landscape
detail which shows the area at the front
um the attenuation is all Suds and it
uses um uh non- piped uh attenuation so
you have reels going along the main road
um into the site sorry I'm using the
wrong Mouse
um along here and going further into the
site and that all all drains South um
and is attenu any rainfalls attenuated
in this area and eventually crosses a a
pipe and into uh the drainage ditch on
the south side of Church
Road if I quickly go back to that plan I
should have said that this particular um
depression here would be a pond um it
would be permanently filled with water
that's the intention as part of the
attenuation um and if that over toed
then these lesser areas would be used
but I think in terms of the the way the
site is organized this is a um a section
across that overall site and you'll see
that excuse
me the um the general depressions that
you're looking at there I think this one
is uh 40 cm and this one on scales were
shown as scales at 60 so they are fent G
gentle um clients rather than the usual
sort of all the the attenuation basins
you're probably used to seeing in the
past um and I think on this particular
one as well it shows where the kickabout
area would be as one of the um the
elements of that overall
landscape um another important
consideration of course as well as the
impact on backt and Manor in terms of
amenity um is the impact on the other
properties of won Road um here you can
see that there would be a line of units
along the back um but the actual
distance between the units um is clearly
SC well hopefully fairly clearly scaled
but it scales up between 32 and 33 M um
which by distance standards is felt to
be acceptable in this location the other
thing to bear in mind is that there
would be a 5 m wide belt of
trees um and additional planting along
here and the developers have specified
extra heavy heavy standard units uh
trees in that particular location which
start start off at 6 M height so it's an
instant impact in terms of filter
screening which I think in combination
with the distance we were happy with as
an approach to protect protecting you
know it's the important consideration of
protecting the amenity of the occupi of
these two
dwellings um this goes into the the
section drawing you can see here goes
into into more detail relation to that
so this is the boundary with the
properties um on wyon road I was just
talking about there's the 5 m wide strip
of
planting extra heavy standard tree
planting going in and then you can see
the two rows of houses so that's the r
houses nearest the boundary um and
turning to backton Manor there's the two
houses I was talking about which both
have the triple parking Arrangement um
and then you've got a 7 m wide strip
there and extra heavy standard planting
importantly there's no windows front
onto that side at first floor level
either so that's a further
protection um I'll I'll go through these
at some speed these are the the design
uh approach that's taken on the site uh
which is traditional architecture but I
think bearing in mind the context of the
surroundings and also the important
consideration of the the setting of the
listed buildings um it was felt that
that as a design approach would be
appropriate in this
location um the house types themselves
are traditional um all detailing um it's
been work up since the initial uh
submission so for example where you have
large flank elevations that are uh
without any detail the the developers uh
sorry the applicant has been um
negotiated to to put some features in
those um flanks to break them up um but
generally uh render brick tiles the
sorts of thing you would normally see um
in suuk um as a design
response um importantly the design also
doesn't discriminate if that's the right
word between affordable housing units
and Market housing in terms of
appearance they look exactly the same in
our view so you would you could say the
visually the tene
blind
um this example of garaging which again
follows that traditional approach um
I'll finish off with some views this is
looking eastwards along uh Church
Road uh that's backton Manor uh which is
a very nice house to grade two star um
and was a subject of much discussion the
impact of this on the setting of that at
the appeal so I understand uh because
that was one of the reasons the um the
council originally rejected this um and
the as I said the inspector was happy
with the impact on the basis of the
amount of open space that would be
provided on the the frontage of the site
um that's the end of the kurage of
beckton house um and this is a
sweep across the site from Church Road
level agricultural land as I've said in
the report there you can see um the
hedging which is a feature that would be
retained which obviously helps with
regard to the overall visual impact the
only puncture that would take place in
that would be the um the cycle way or
way that comes out on the onto the
road that's a view up Church Road and
again you can
see the ctage or bton Manor and its
Associated grounds and opposite the site
is the local
pub um this is a view approaching
further down the road towards the
junction with won Road you've got the
the pond in the foreground and uh the
shop there which I was talking about
earlier um and this is looking
northwards up won Road and at time my
visit uh delivery was taking place as
you can see um this is further up wyon
Road this tree here would not be lost as
part of the development um the point of
access would take place the other side
of the tree so north of the tree so that
would not be coming out um and these are
the two houses I was talking about
earlier which back on to uh onto the
site um in terms of the the amenity
protection
issues um and this is a sweep
across the
site from Weston Road and again this is
the approximate position here where the
uh new access will be coming
in um there's a couple of um CGI views
of development this is across the open
space to the site Frontage from Church
Road um and it's important I thought to
so you could get a flavor of the sort of
development which would be for the
affordable housing units which um is
located to the rear because it's in
terms of the the value of the space they
all have value and it's important that
they make sure make sure that that's uh
you know an appropriate standard for
this development so I think that's all I
need to say at this particular stage um
happy to take question thank
you yeah we got some hands got councelor
eburn and councelor
maton um thank you chair um just for for
context um thanks for the presentation
um could you just possibly um point out
the site immediately north of the Middle
School site and confirm what the status
is there please in terms of um
planning um I'm I'm terribly sorry
cancer I'm starting to get an ear
infection in my it's not that you
haven't spoken loud enough it's just
that I'm I'm I'm struggling to hear it
occasionally okay so just the the site
um that's immediately north of the or
Northwest of the S of this site is the
bton old bton Middle School site yes
could you just confirm the status of um
just for context what the status is
there at the moment for of planning
applications um outline planning
permission has been granted for
redevelopment on that side
I don't think we've had any reserve
matters in um so yeah I mean it's got an
outline an extent outline planning
permission thank you and the
um two or specifically up here there's
two there seem to be a lot of
attenuation um is that you know plus a
pond so two
attenuations areas plus a pond that
seems quite a lot
for in from sites I've seen um just if
you could comment on that and the other
point is the um foot path seems to
extend from the site directly onto
Church Road so young people could um is
there any plans to have that um a
Crossing or have that actually stopped
off a bit so that people young people
particularly on bikes don't race
straight out of the site onto the onto
the main onto the Church Road the main
road because it is quite straight
through Road in bton so it's not it's
busy um turning to the issue of um
attenuation if you could get the
presentation up
please I'll quickly get
uh well actually we'll go the other way
I've got one right at the
end
right sorry about that yes there is um
three attenuation ponds um in terms of
how this work attenuation areas I should
say in terms of how this works the fall
is from north to south um and this
drainage would be through this site um
this would be a permanent um feature
which I understand would be at 40 cm
deep at any time but it would be a f
permanent Pond feature and there is um
another pond on the site which is
currently um overgrown I understand
which is approximately this position
excuse me in this position and the
proposal is to utilize that and make
that um part of the drainage as well
these two basins here are there in in
basically to deal with the unusual one
in
100e um
event um otherwise there would be uh
percolation or or or basically the
runoff would would just soak through as
normal but that's why they can afford to
be shallower um and in the case of this
one um they're even showing a a
kickabout area within that site so they
would be dry for most of the time it's
just in that unusual event there they're
there to attenuate even more um turning
to this
that that foot foot path does come
straight out onto the road well there's
a foot path there that it would land or
connect with um I must admit I don't
know if there's any detail of that
that's been agreed at this stage I dare
say that the uh the highway
Authority um may want to consider the
issue because I I take the point I
understand exactly the point you're
making with regard to what happened to
the pedestrians coming out on the main
road but it's not coming out straight
out until Gage way is coming out onto a
a foot path on the Northern side yeah
thank thanks for that just the school is
the primary school is north um East on
that map and it's not very far so it be
easy for people to cycle and I'd be
concerned that they're just zooming out
so anyway we'll see what happens
thanks thank you councelor
maton thank you yeah the I'm looking at
the the the access with benefit of
planning permission Etc um
are we you said we weren't Lo losing any
trees um are you sure that that I mean
the visibility playay on that slide
appears to go right through that lovely
tree which I I pray we do not lose uh
are we really confident that highways
have agreed to that and keeping that
tree
yes yeah thank you I I another the one
you mean I just hopefully get it up so
everyone can see it properly um yes
um that line there is a vis visibility
playay that's obviously the tree that's
been been um shown on the site or just
taken from the the survey drawing I'm
reading that that the the visibility
playay goes to that side of the trunk
when I say that side I mean to the west
of the trunk as you look North so
therefore that the uh the actual tree
will be retained it's it's not shown as
as being taken out counselor so that's
what I'm I'm relying on in terms of
giving you that advice it's not shown as
being removed REM because normally with
that type of drawing if it was proposed
to remove it it would be shown dotted so
um can double check with the applicant
yeah definitely thank you uh councilor
maner uh thank you chair um could you
please um uh inform us of uh the uh EV
charging points um on this particular
development and uh do you know how these
houses are intended to be
heated thank you counselor the EV
charting points was a condition imposed
by the
inspector um so he's basically said in
his decision notice that details have
have to be provided but the wording of
the condition is that they would have to
serve all dwellings as I understand the
wording of of his condition that's why I
haven't suggested it in my list but
there would need to be charging points
for all all um all the dwellings there
um and in terms of the heating having
read through their um energy statement
the applicants are saying in this case
it would be electric
heating can I could I come back um I
noticed on the plan that I think it's
some of the affordable housing has got a
rear parking Port um the sort of um uh
well well it's on all of them I think I
I think it's um where's is there a
parking
plan um but they're none of them are
very big scale 611 um 611 seems to be
the parking provision layout uh and it's
all a bit small but I think it's the
ones uh and almost in the middle and the
north there seems to be a rear parking C
and I'm just concerned about the EV
charging points in there but if it's
being conditioned at the outline stage
presumably when it what happens
well because obviously sometimes things
are conditioned at outline stage and we
see them at Reserve matters about what
they're going to do with them but
presumably this because it was an appeal
decision you haven't heard anything
about the EV charging provision
especially for those ones in the parking
Court I haven't had any um involvement
with the developer or the applicant
about that particular Point um there are
three po three parking courts on this
site um two survey spaces and the third
one serves for um they would have to be
served by EV in some way or other even
though they're remote from the curtilage
so the onus is on the developer to
Accord with the with the condition we'll
ask him maybe if he's
here any other questions at all at this
point oh yes
yes um yeah yeah affordable housing um
the
did you briefly give us a verbal update
on the the um strategic housing views
about this only I I note that the the
layout is is not within our usual um
limitation of of um 15 clustered a
maximum it's more than that um have they
[Music]
commented um sorry I for the admission
counselors I did have my late paper
which I should have drawn your attention
to we did get a comment from the
Strategic housing team on the particular
point of the affordable housing location
I understand that the applicant met with
a strategic housing officer to discuss
that um and it was a question obviously
because there's a requirement of the
amount which is in accordance with
policy but the location has been driven
as has the organization of the whole
site in relation to the constraints
presented such as the listed building so
as you look at the
development um the further north you go
the denser it gets but there is an
incursion of uh affordable housing
within the private part to the South the
area further south and and on that basis
the affordable sorry the Strategic
housing officer was happy with that
Arrangement As I understood it so you're
saying some afford it to the
no no sorry sorry there's a cluster of
affordable housing as you look at the
plan at the top but there's a a number
of I think they're um shared ownership
units which actually form part of a
perimeter block which is south of the
main cluster that makes sense
yeah yeah I I heard you say 10 year
blind for those but um well visually
okay well yeah we'll come back to that
possibly Council man come back yeah
thank you thank you now that you've have
pointed us to the late papers which I
hadn't really had a chance to digest
because they only appeared sort late
yesterday afternoon um am I right in in
assuming that because of the um this
comment that the some of the affordable
units are not um to the nationally
described space
standards uh and and you seem to think
that that is
acceptable um well the I think that the
the ident sorry the officer ident
um that the ndss standards or ndss
haven't been achieved um but it's not
something I don't think at this point we
can insist on and I think that's
recognized in her consultation response
back to us so I think it's um something
that we would want to seek but we have
no policy basis on this point to
actually do that so that's the position
we're in
unfortunately
only to say that I I'm I Bradley won't
mind me saying I'm sorry to say he's
quite right as a matter of
law okay any other questions before we
move on no okay so um we'll now move on
to the parish council uh welcome uh
thank you for staying the course uh and
uh over to you and you have three
minutes thank you chairman and uh good
afternoon um backton Parish Council was
active in its successful effort to
persuade this committee to refuse the
outline planning application of this
development and made representations to
the planning hearing when that went to
appeal but we accept the outcome of that
process and have endeavored to work
constructively with the applicant on
their proposals for the site which is a
sensitive and significant location for
the village Parish Council recognized
the applicants have engaged with
neighboring Property Owners including me
and my wife as the owners of bton Manor
to address our concerns they built a
number of questions issues raised by the
council and others since the first
iteration of application but many of the
council's original concerns remain
despite some minor changes have we heard
the affordable housing is still
relatively clustered together
Northeastern corner of the site we
really do feel these dwellings be better
distributed evenly throughout the
development to create a more balanced
community and avoid the risk of social
isolation uh we note the proposed
changes the attenuation basins but can
we be assured that they will now provide
accessible multi-purpose space of
recreation and community activities and
whilst this will be a welcome open space
to the Village the council is concerned
about the location of the natural play
area um top left which is currently out
of view of the dwellings in one corner
of the site and possibly encourage anti-
social behavior and at 300 square meters
a relatively small space given the
overall size of the development uh we've
heard concerns about the VIS of parking
and that's encouraging if it's thought
the developers can accommodate all the
shop traffic we hope it can but it needs
to be born in mind we suggest the street
lights might be more traditional in
their design even if utilizing low
energy technology and installed a low
level to minimize light pollution as we
see no changes in the proposed
specification the cycle paths are
welcomed as the potential link to any
future development to the north that was
mentioned um but the safety of cycle
cyclist children and the accompanying
adults in negotiating Church Road
concerns the council greatly as there's
no propos for a safe Crossing to access
the only primary and preschool in the
village as we've just heard from a
counselor we'd like to see a raised
Crossing as installed at Hy serving the
bellway eve Meadows development linking
the adjacent foot paths opposite the
bull and a similar Crossing between the
foot paths on weberon road uh near the
tree we've talked about both of which
would Aid pedestrian safety and act as
traffic calming measures on The Wider
traffic issue we do not feel the
limitations of the junction of w Road
Church Road to safely manage the
anticipated number of vehicle movements
from this and the adjacent sites
scheduled for construction the next few
years has been recognized and suggests
that through you hopefully the highways
might be asked to evaluate the
construction of a roundabout at their
location Parish Council asked these
issues might be addressed through
appropriate conditions if the
application is
granted thank you very much any
questions for the parish
council no okay thank you very much um
now we don't have an objector or a
supporter uh so we'll move straight to
the agent or the applicant and we have
Dan humpr and Mark Chapman over to you
and again between you have everyone to
do three
minutes good afternoon chairman members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today um as
I say my name is Dan Humphrey's planning
coordinator for Taylor wimpy East Anglia
and I'm joined by Mark Champlin planning
and technical director who will assist
me in answering any questions you may
have uh Taylor Wimpy have been involved
in this project since early 2020 and had
the benefit of several rounds of
collaborative pre-application
discussions with officers key
stakeholders near neighbors and the
local community this included an excess
of 500 newsletters being circulated
locally inviting comments in relation to
the emerging proposals all comments
received today have helped positively
shape the proposals triggering numerous
improvements to ensure that the scheme
sits sympathetically with its immediate
surroundings as referred to in the case
officer's reports this particular site
does have the benefit of an indicative
master plan and Suite of parameter plans
which are widely recognized as an
appropriate starting point for the
determination of Reserve matters such
plans provide clear and well-considered
framework under which the development
should be brought forward and such
guiding principles have being carried
through the design process and approved
upon wherever possible such improvements
include the addition of internal cycle
paths widen landscape Buffs buffers with
mature planting looped internal highways
offering improved functionality the
sensitive placement of buildings to
boundaries and enhanced detailing
materiality to numerous homes
furthermore discussions have been held
directly with the LFA to ensure that the
SS features provided within the site
Frontage can perform as multifunctional
spaces fully accessible to The Wider
Community similar discussions are
ongoing with bton Parish Council as to
what this important space may contain in
the
future final development layout design
closely reflects the master plan in
terms of site access internal Highway
movement Network the spatial arrangement
of buildings and the provision of open
space important buildoff Dimensions have
been honored and existing boundaries
have been fully respected as intended
many of the new homes are afforded
natural green outlooks to promote
healthy living due to the outward
looking nature of the layout design
which wouldn't be achievable through
other design responses such as inverting
the layout in terms of architectural
design first and foremost this proposal
does not look to compete with the
adjacent Mana house only to respect ex
evidence stature and set setting this
approach shall help preserve a clear
hierarchical sense of place to be
complemented with simple attractive and
uncluttered building styles and
materials such styles that are commonly
seen elsewhere in suffk and where Cap
were also captured in the local
character analysis undertaken at the
outline application stage in conclusion
members Taylor wi pangle are extremely
proud to be involved in this project and
are grateful for the positive
collaboration with the council and other
stakeholders The Proposal complies with
the principle set by the Outland
planning application that's POS POS been
positively received by officers staty
consules including the Heritage team
therefore we would respectfully ask that
you support your officer's
recommendation today thank you thank you
very much okay do we have any questions
at all yeah uh start at the back Council
Reber and then Council man um thank you
chair thank you for that um couple of
questions the attenuation ponds again um
and the large area of them short could
it not be possible to actually rather
than the two big ones yes I can say
you've got a pond if there's a pond in
the middle as well can that not be made
into one so you can clearly delineate a
play space or whatever someone refer to
as a kickabout space but whatever space
there is um secondly the play area that
fronts onto Weston Road at the back of
the site was there no um did you not
discuss putting that in the middle of
the site somehow which would also
probably add as another feature really
for the those people living there and
and thirdly as I raised in the questions
the officer um do you have any um
structure or plan to prevent um
particularly young people going cycling
straight out of the um site onto Church
Road and yes I know there's a pavement
there but it's not that wide and um I
can just see you know that an accident
waiting to happen as somebody shoots out
so i' appreciate your answers to those
thank
you um yeah with the first uh instance
of the uh the balancing ponds uh the
actual overall surface water drainage
strategy was looked at and discussed at
Great Lengths with the llfa um the
original ponds from the master planning
stage were actually due to be a lot
deeper than what are currently shown um
but to enable us to get to a point where
the surface water runoff is no greater
than the current use of the site um it
did mean that we had to expand the
overall size of those ponds but decrease
the depth so that they were still
accessible
um so that is the reason why you've got
three ponds in essence um albeit they
are very shallow to ensure they're
accessible but it is to to reduce the
the surface water runoff rate that's
anticipated for the
site um secondly with the POs uh to the
the Northwestern boundary um again our
standpoint at the beginning was to
follow the approved master plan and
indicative parameter plans um that was
clearly the the location um that was
deemed Suited suble for such a a play
space I appreciate the comments um
regarding whether that's safe whether
it's overlooked we do have um an excess
of three houses directly overlooking
that space um and obviously it will be a
through route from elsewhere in the
village into the new development as well
um via the new cycle path link that's
due to be
provided um and thirdly um with the
access to Church Road again with a new
cycle path currently we don't have any
proposals um in terms of barriers um or
anything to prevent children pedestrians
from going out onto the road that's
something we could discuss with the
highway Authority when it comes to the
detailed design stage so we're gladly
take that point
away okay councilor man uh thank you
chair um I'd just like to F follow up my
questions that I asked of the officer um
about the the he he informed us that
these houses are to be electrically
heated um now now I first looked at the
plan and I thought they're not really
orientated for solar PV um was that any
ever part of your consideration um about
the design and layout of this uh
proposal um I'd also like to ask about
um the EV charging points particularly
in the parking courts and whether that
that you know that is really going to
happen uh and also I'd like your
comments on the fact that the affordable
some of the affordable homes are not to
the National Space standards thank
you right thank you for those questions
so um yeah the electric boilers um so so
I can confirm it is electric heating
here so there's no no gas in the area um
each house will then have waste water
heat recovery system and there is also
photoptics on the roofs around about 20%
of the homes will have those and there
was actually a
sustainability um report submitted
alongside the application which which
gives all the data in the background of
that as well um in terms of the EV
charging um the as case officer said
there is a condition on the outline for
condition seven the reason we haven't
submitted details at this stage is
you'll be aware there's emerging
government guidance on on how EV
charging should be brought in and
regulation so what we didn't want to do
was preempt that at this point when
actually you know there will be some
clearer guidance from government on how
we do that we have an approach where we
tried to pre-wire all homes with parking
adjacent ready for mode three but like I
say we we haven't actually submitted
those details but that will come in as
that part that discharge
condition yes that's right yes yeah and
sorry what was the National Space
standards and and space standards um as
was said earlier it's not something that
is a requirement in the area at the
moment so so that's why we haven't put
it Forward um there is around 45% of the
homes on the on the site actually do
meet the space standards anyway it's
just when you get down to the smaller
ones because of how um things like on
Suites are measured in the National
Space standards technically they don't
meet the the size area but it doesn't
mean that they're drastically undersized
it's just how you measure on Suites in a
space standard property home but as we
said earlier it's not a requirement at
the
moment councilor Matson yeah I was going
to ask about the the described space
centers as well I mean do you not feel
that the you know your company
reputation would be would be better
served uh if you could put your hand up
and say yes we're meeting them um second
question I did ask earlier about the the
tree um or perhaps trees even but
particularly the one tree on um slide 7
page
607 um as to whether we can be assured
that the visibility playay um dotted
line is not going to remove the
tree
[Music]
yeah I come back on both those points so
in terms of the tree um yes the
visibility playay won't clash with the
tree that's been checked by the highways
uh officers already um there's actually
been some very detailed conversations
about that so um you're probably aware
that that we have a planning level
drawing planning stage we then have
what's called a section 278 uh which is
the detailed design afterwards those
conversations have already been Ono
going so there's no chance of changing
from planning level to that what we call
that technical design stage so that's
that's absolutely fine I take the point
on uh the ndss um it's not something
that we're required to do today there
are some uh uh what I would call some
Oddities around how you measure that you
can you can build a smaller house
without an onite bathroom and it's ndss
compliant or you can build a bigger
house with an nonset bathroom and it's
it's not now you know we are obviously
Market Le we take a decision that that
uh for our customers in this particular
area they value an onsuite bathroom so
therefore that's the size of the home we
build and we provide the onsuite
bathroom so but I do take the
point okay any other questions yes
Council man uh thank you Mr chair um the
um houses show chimneys although clearly
they're not going to be functional are
they just a design
picture they are yes
we've had great debate about that over
the years we we might get to that later
who
knows okay uh right that's it on the
question front we'll move over now to
the ward member uh so over to you
councilman thank you uh I'll try and be
as brief as I can um thank you members
um the original application for this
site was refused by mid suffk um but
that decision as we heard was overturned
by by the appeal inspector so this site
is one of three in bton which were not
within the original proposed jlp
settlement boundary but which have
subsequently been approved and are now
within the amended proposed jlp
settlement boundary now this site sits
at the heart of the village uh it's a
short walk to the shop the pub the
school and indeed the potential new
School site on the old Middle School
site it's close to the doctor's surgery
and the church and as such it represents
a reasonably sustainable site though I
will make the point that public
transport connections from back to a
poor uh and much worse than when I moved
here 15 years ago I can commend the the
developer for their interaction and
discussion with the parish council and
with the district and County councilors
we've had some very useful discussions
um however there are still a few
outstanding concerns which I'll just go
on to go through
through firstly the imunity play area is
tucked away in the northwest corner of
the site it does not appear to be well
surveilled and I would preferred to have
seen it within the bill site more
centrally um secondly the the appeel
cons inspector conditioned that the
building line be set back from church
Road in order to respect the adjacent
Mana building and this would I quote
maintain a large area of public open
space in the southern third of the site
now while this application does show
Green Space at the front of the site
almost like a Village
Green um this is largely taken up with
the attenuation Basin so I have concerns
really about how usable this space is is
it really public open space as the
inspector
described uh my third point the the
affordable housing is clustered in one
location is not what we generally like
to see and officers usually object to
that fourthly the inspector conditioned
that the access to this development
should come in from wyst Road rather
than Church Road as was originally
envisaged so that means that most
traffic will have to come to The
Junction at shop green that's where
wyver Road and Church Road meet and we
will have more traffic from the other
developments on W won Road one site's
already under construction and then we
have the Middle School site to come so
this Junction is going to become quite
busy and that it is a tricky Junction
it's it's a sort of traditional shaped
with an island in the middle as we saw
in the photograph so it can actually get
quite difficult to negotiate and it does
need to be
redesigned um while I welcome the new
spaces for parking on in the entrance
way to the the de to the development
there will be a loss of parking opposite
the entrance play because you simply
can't have cars there and they were
shown uh parked there on a couple of the
photos in in the in the um presentation
um people do Park opposite this entrance
or the potential entrance to go to the
shop and they won't be a to do it when
this development has been
built um I do have a question mark over
electric boilers why not airs Source
heat pumps which are more efficient um
it seems to me you've gone for an option
which is cheaper to build but will be
more expensive to run for the residents
in the long run I do agree that
development will come to this site and I
do agree that the developer has listened
to the community I just wish they had
gone a bit further thank you
chair thank you very much any
questions to the yeah Council
M yeah I'm I'm I want really wanted to
go back to the to the agent because I'd
assumed when that the word electric
meant electrically powered air source
heat pumps um but now um councilor melan
saying that it it doesn't which is is
quite
concerning Yeah Yeah
by um so that that's right we haven't
proposed a source heat pumps here as as
I said we've actually got Wastewater
heat recovery and
photovoltaics instead now one of the
reasons we haven't gone the for the air
source heat pumps is is obviously it's
something we know will be coming um but
at the moment the supply chain the the
training of people who can fit it all
those things is still you know being
worked on should we say also where you
see the real benefit of air source heat
pumps will be um and sorry to get too
technical but the the the sap assessment
which is how they assess assess sorry
how uh the energy of a home um sap 10
which is being updated for the new
building regulations um part of that
update takes into account account the
fact that you've got decarbonization of
the energy Network so at the moment if
you run an electric heating Network
because uh historically our electric has
come from uh uh coal fueled Energy power
power stations it actually uh is shown
as very inefficient and until that sap
software is adapted to reflect the fact
that more energy comes from Green
sources electric heating and and things
like air source heat pumps uh are still
shown through the software as not being
as efficient now we know that that will
change um but you can't actually model
it at this time so that sap software we
were expecting around July this year and
it's now looking like the end of the
year and that is all part of the new uh
building regulation roll out that that's
that's coming but what we have done like
I say at this point in time is is is
show that we can meet the required
standard just in a different way um and
the other thing to note is is all of our
homes when we sell them uh we obviously
need to make sure the lights and
everything switch on on the day that um
customers move in so Taylor wimpy signed
all of our customers to a renewable
tariff so the the the first tariff
they'll be on in their their home is uh
guaranteed to be through uh renewable
sources obviously after that it's up to
the customer if they need to change that
but it starts them off on the right
footing in terms of getting their energy
from the right
sources thank you for
that yeah chair I that that's really
interesting um I wonder if we could get
our our sustainability officer to um
give us um give us a bit of a briefing
on that sometime um not in the context
of this application but but um it's
quite
interesting yes I'm sure we
can
okay yeah I think John I think the best
thing would if you if you can just
ping uh if you just ping well if you if
Andre and can ping Susie and just say it
came up at planning can we have a
briefing on it that probably the best to
make sure it actually happens let's do
it that way yeah I think yeah a group
briefing a briefing for the members yeah
yeah okay thank you okay so thank you
that's all the questions so open up for
debate and caner Passmore your hands
gone straight up over to you I was just
going to ask a question actually you
didn't see it was just really concerning
the parking on won Road being near the
the shop and and so on have you got any
suggestions I mean Highway from what I
can see here raised no objections they
apparently seem to be satisfied I just
wonder if quite um no comment um if
there is anything that could be done or
whether that could be added as part of
the conditions to make sure they do
actually